have you ever watched a tutorial that
uses vs code and thought how do they do
it so effortlessly the answer often lies
in mastering the tools not just the code
vs code is more than a text editor it's
packed with features like intellisense
built-in git and terminal but harnessing
its full potential can feel daunting
this course demystifies that process
learn to enhance its Aesthetics navigate
with lightning fast shortcuts integrate
top extensions and employ over 100 tips
and tricks Chris EV developed this
course he's a developer Advocate at
digitalocean and founder of scotch.io
hey there this is Chris Sev with better
Dev here and have you ever looked at
somebody using vs code and said oh my
gosh how in the world are they doing
that and they're moving things around
and everything's flying around really
really fast
those are 10x developers and every 10x
developer knows how to use the vs code
to the absolute maximum capability
and that's what I love about vs code is
that there are so many ways to make it
your tool to be a 10x developer there's
settings there's fonts there's themes
there's workflows extensions and all of
the built-in amazing features like the
terminal so I've been through it all
I've been through Sublime Text Vim all
those editors webstorm and I've landed
on vs code as being the awesomest
coolest most productive editor and
that's what this course is about is how
to make vs code AS productive as
possible how to make ourselves as
productive as possible using vs code and
creating our own workflows and that's
what this course will do it'll teach you
how to make vs code work for you
specifically so let's get into it we're
going to learn a lot about all the
built-in features all the things that we
can add to vs code and we're going to
make ourselves a little bit more
productive
so this course is called productive vs
code so I thought you know what let's
show off a productive workflow before we
get into the larger part of the course
this is kind of just a preview to see
the kind of tool set and super powers
and skills you'll get by the end of this
course
so here I have vs code let's say we
wanted to clone a repo down from GitHub
we can do command shift p open up our
Command palette and say clone
and we can clone
clone from GitHub and I'm going to get
the productive vs code
site which is the website for the
productive vs code course
and I'll save this to my Batcave folder
this is where I put all of my working
stuff select repo
once it clones I can open it in this vs
code instance and here we have our next
JS project which is the code for this
website
and if I close the sidebar open up
package Json you can see down here
that there are dependencies
so we need to install them I'm going to
install them a quicker way I'm going to
do command shift p install right here
and throughout this course you'll see
how much I use the command palette and
try to keep everything going from the
command palette so it's all keyboard
shortcuts okay so that installed now we
can
npm run script and we're going to run
the dev script because next.js uses the
dev script to start up so I'll run that
and you'll see localhost 3000 is where
our app starts
cool so we've been able to install we've
been able to clone we've been able to
run a script let's go and actually do
some changes here site hero let's say we
wanted to bring in use state
we'll use a snippet there message is
there and we'll go here so that's cool
we have that let's have site header
let's make some more changes and we'll
say console.log hi everybody
okay that's cool but now let's say we
wanted to commit this code up to GitHub
we've made some changes across two files
let's go see how to do this
we can open up our git panel right here
and you can see that the package.lock
has changed the site header and the site
Hero has changed I can click here and
say okay what happened here let's see I
added this console log okay that's fine
what happened to site hero right here I
added this use State okay cool
so let's say I don't want this use State
I can just say undo here
discard that change I can add these two
files right here and say super cool
stuff
because that's how all our commit
messages go right
and I can commit that and now I can push
that to GitHub all from my command
palette git push right here and we'll
push that up to GitHub
now what did we change the site header I
think cool so I can also say you know
what let's go see this in Chrome in
GitHub so I can right click right here
go to online Link and we can go see our
changes right from within GitHub
and it gets right to that line in the
productive vs code site repo
so all of that was done from vs code we
really didn't leave it right we were
able to clone install run make changes
commit all that good stuff use Snippets
all within vs code
so that's kind of the workflows I'm
talking about in this course I really
want everything to be as streamlined as
possible and I've spent a lot of time
figuring out the best ways to use vs
code to be an efficient tool
I hope that was helpful let's get into
the course
let's get to it so to get us started we
are going to go to code.visualstudio.com
just to download vs code and get it
installed so that we can start running
it
it is available on Mac it's available on
Windows Linux I'm going to be working on
Mac so whenever you hear me say command
you're probably going to want control on
Windows if I say option you'll probably
want alt so once we have vs code
installed and we have it here this is
the screen that you'll see when you
start it up it'll look just like this
and what we'll have here is the welcome
screen so you can actually turn this off
down here show welcome page on Startup
and we'll have it set on for now
and here the getting started section is
actually really good to go through
customize your setup they have you go
through themes coding in any language
switching from other editors opening a
project folder very very cool guide and
getting started
is a really fun thing to go through when
you're starting with vs code in this
course we're going to go through
everything that these three cover so you
don't have to but it's really fun to go
through and one that I recommend you go
to is boost your productivity
over here under redefine your editing
skills open interactive playground and
that will open the interactive
playground to the side you can close out
getting started here and just scroll
through this and kind of get a lay of
the land because it's cool you can
actually type into these sections right
here and see what's going on
it's a really fun interactive on
boarding again not totally necessary if
you are feeling like you have the four
or five minutes to go through this go
ahead if not let's push through and
we'll learn about all of this stuff in
this course
first up let's talk about the UI of vs
code so I just want to get us both on
the same vocabulary so when I start
calling things out and moving things
around we both know what we're talking
about
so to start us off this is the vs code
interface
down at the bottom here we have the
status bar this purple thing
right in the middle we have the editor
and we'll get more to that in a second
over on the left we have the activity
bar and this is where a lot of your
clicking is going to happen
so the activity bar has a bunch of
different things in it so let's go
through them one is the Explorer and as
soon as you click that icon this opens
up your sidebar
and the sidebar is now filled with the
Explorer here
I can click the find right here or
search and that'll open up search into
the sidebar
I can click this get icon and we can
open up git into the side Part Source
control right here
the debug is right here with a little
bug cute little icon and we have it
right in our sidebar and we have
extensions in our sidebar as well and we
can search through those and if you
expand the sidebar out a little longer
you can get these nice icons
so overall this is going to be your
activity bar and your sidebar there
you'll do a lot of the work you have in
and we'll go through each of these in
depth throughout this course if we open
a folder right here let's talk about the
main part where you'll be typing the
most let's open up this productive vs
code site and I'll open up the whole
folder
now if I go ahead and click on
package.json right here
you can see that this is our editor
so this is where you're going to be
doing all of your typing you have your
sidebar over here that can hide and show
whenever you need it just keep on
clicking those icons
here you have all of your text
here is the tabs so we have one open
let's say I wanted to keep that open and
I'll open up the readme right here
that is the tabs right here
right here we have what are called
breadcrumbs so you can actually let's go
into an actual file let's go into this
index.js
right here the breadcrumbs actually show
you what's going on in the file so
you're in the pages folder right here
you're in index.js the file and here you
can actually see all of the different
things that you're in so you're in the
home function there's not really many
functions in here but once there are you
can actually click this and see all the
different things in a file so
breadcrumbs is really useful
and let me shrink this over here and
over on the right here we have the mini
map which you can click and drag just to
see how long your code is and if there
are any errors you can see like a little
red line in there really helpful and I
personally really like to have it
so overall we have the status bar we
have the activity bar we have the
sidebar
we have tabs and our editor
and the last thing here and let me close
these out is the panels and they don't
really show right now I'm going to open
up the terminal with Ctrl tilde
and the panels are what show on the
bottom right here so we have the
terminal
we have problems tab
output tab ug console but I imagine
you'll spend most of your time in vs
code in the terminal and in the debug
console for this area down here and
we'll talk about those more in this
course
so there's a lot of really fun little
hidden things around vs code and the
biggest one we haven't even talked about
yet which is going to be the star of
next video is the command palette so
overall I hope that was a good
introduction to vs code's UI there's a
lot going on but don't worry we'll be
going through all of it and making sure
we understand and know how to use every
bit of it
in this video I want to talk about the
number one essential tool to using vs
code and that would be the command
palette
now this is so essential that this is
going to be encompassing the entire
course you really need it for the entire
course to follow along with everything
that we're going to do
and it is also essential to productivity
and this being productive vs code the
command palette is front and center
so you might be asking okay well what is
the command palette Chris where is it so
it doesn't show up at first but to show
the command palette it actually shows
you right here show all commands shift
command p and if you're on Windows
that'll be Ctrl shift p or command shift
p which I'll say a lot in this course
so command shift p and I'll just do it a
couple times just to get in the habit
command shift p Escape command shift p
that will open up the command palette
and the command palette is pretty much
your command center for vs code it's
going to show up right at the top here
and anything that you can do in vs code
is going to show up here so like let's
say I wanted to open up Explorer
focus on folders view that would open up
the sidebar here I could even hide the
status bar
toggle status bar visibility I could
hide the activity bar
and that's why it's so important that we
know what all the things are called
because I'm going to go through and hide
and show a lot of things based on how
we're working for that video
so the cool thing about the command
palette is that anything that you can
find in the commands up here like let's
say file open recent open folder edit
find in files replace in files and you
can see the keyboard shortcuts right
there
you can do from the command palette so
all the all these things here here here
here here all of it can be done in the
command palette and that makes a super
efficient because we don't leave the
keyboard
so I could even open up the terminal and
that'll be toggle terminal
anytime you want to hide or show
something it's usually under the toggle
command
and let's see we did git clone already
in one of these videos we did get push
and if you wanted to check you could
just type in git and then move your
mouse up here and scroll through all of
the commands that you can do thanks to
the command palette we could even open
up a new file
file new file right here
and we'll name it hello.js and then here
I can say command shift p snippet and I
can insert a snippet we can go down here
we'll save this for each Loop right here
and now we can say my array is called
items item
and console.log item
so that's really cool that we can use
the command palette to do Snippets we
can move things around we can say toggle
breadcrumbs right there and that hides
the breadcrumbs you could even toggle
the tabs
toggle tab visibility there
and now it only shows the single file
that's open
you won't see anything else but one file
you can do the minimap pretty much
everything here and there's going to be
a lot more work to be done thanks to the
command palette so in this course you'll
see me say command shift p or open your
command palette and that's a prompt to
open up your command palette and type in
something there so we'll open up
activity bar back we'll bring the status
bar back we'll bring the breadcrumbs
back
and finally we'll bring back the tabs
toggle tab visibility there we go so
we're back to normal
keyboard shortcuts are going to be a big
part of this course and the command
palette is a big part of that so stay
tuned you're going to hear that a lot
let's get used to it because it's going
to help you on your coding Journey a ton
the first thing that we're going to do
to make vs code look good is to install
themes
now themes are really cool that's the
first thing I reach for to understanding
how an editor works
and themes is a great segue into seeing
how vs code does extensions
so if I go to docs here and I go down to
user guide
the extension Marketplace
extensions are a way that you can extend
vs code's functionality through a
Marketplace of extensions and we are
going to do a lot with extensions we're
going to be adding on a theme in this
video we'll also be adding on icon
themes in this video
and there's going to be so many
extensions that we're going to install
to vs code
what we can do here is in the extensions
link right here this is the extensions
Marketplace
and you can actually type in theme
and see all of the themes that are
popular you can sort by relevance you
can sort by downloads all that good
stuff here
so you might be wondering okay how do I
install one of these themes let's click
on the winters coming Theme by John Papa
we can scroll down we can see a preview
of it that looks cool just blue color
we can go up here and click install
and we'll give this prompt and says hey
do you want to open vs code from this
website we can say yep open vs code
and now you'll see the extension here
where you can actually click install
but I want to show you a different way I
don't usually go to the website go to
the extension Marketplace from inside of
there I don't do that because we can do
all of that from the convenience of vs
code itself
down here on the side we have the
extensions
sidebar right here
so once I've clicked extensions we get a
list of all the popular extensions 26
934 ton
of extensions really strong and robust
Marketplace and community
so these are the popular ones I can type
in theme Here
and you can see the download 7.7 million
for the material icon theme atom1 dark
theme
and we can click these and the website
actually pops up right in here we can
see previews of them here here's winter
is coming that we just saw
so let's go ahead and install one of
these we'll click install for winter is
coming
and then we'll enable it
so that actually enabled it changes our
entire theme for vs code and it shows
right there in the command palette
so let's say we installed another one
GitHub theme right here one million
downloads let's install right there
cool there's a couple different ones
that we can choose from and if you
actually click down here you can see a
preview
of all these that dimmed one is really
nice light if you're feeling like a
light theme I personally have tried and
haven't been successful at switching
over
but what I want to talk about is these
are all the themes right
so the goal of this video is here's how
you install themes and let's talk about
how we can enable them and then we can
talk about finding really fun themes in
the future so let's go to our Explorer
and let's open up if you don't already
have a folder open or you haven't cloned
anything down from GitHub go ahead and
do that and then you can go up here to
file
open
or you can go into the command palette
command shift p open and I think it'll
be down here under file open and you can
see that command o right there so you
can do command o so there's a lot of
different ways we could open up a folder
so go ahead grab a folder get it open
here's index.js and here's what it looks
like with this theme
what we'll do is see how we can change
themes next and to do that handy dandy
command palette so I'll say command
shift p
and say theme
and you can change the preferences color
theme here so I'll click this and now
you get a whole list of all the built-in
ones and the ones we just installed
through our two extensions
and what's cool is we can actually
preview them just by pressing down
or up
and just click through all of these
there's tomorrow night blue super blue
solarize dark there's just red
monokai which I'm always a big fan of
and here are the GitHub themes we just
installed so feel free to look through
the extensions in the marketplace here
feel free to install them and then when
you want to install and change one and
enable one command shift p color theme
and press enter and then you can just
click through these and let's say you
wanted red and I'll press enter right
there let's actually stick to one that
I'll probably use on a day-to-day basis
currently I am using monokai Pro and
that's at https monica.pro but that is a
paid theme so I don't really want to
recommend it here just check it out
you're for yourself but a good one is
these GitHub dark ones the dimmed one I
like a lot so I'll keep that
next up what I want to do is icon themes
so we can change the overall theme for
this whole thing but we can also go into
extensions and type in icon theme
and here are all the icon themes I can
click here and this actually is going to
change out what we see in our Explorer
for the icons and if I go here that'll
replace these arrows they're kind of
boring but there are some js icons here
the little brackets here so I'll go back
into extensions
install
so we can click here enable
material icon theme
right there
and now if I go back to explore you see
the folders actually have icons now
instead of those arrows
and to do this you can also do this from
command palette command shift p icon
theme
enter and then you can click through and
see the preview over there as well and
we'll stick with material icon theme
that's actually what I use on a day to
day
all right so there's a lot in this video
but it sets the foundation for
everything we're gonna do we are able to
install extensions through the
extensions panel and we'll do a lot of
this we are able to change our theme
which is step one on having a good
looking vs code and we were able to
change out the icon theme so already we
look better than the default vs code
setup
so moving forward I didn't want this to
be about like hey here's the top 10
themes that I recommend this is more
about hey this is how you install themes
which are extensions this is how you
install icon themes and this is how you
switch them out
but from here the world is open to you
you can go over to Google and say best
vs code themes 2021
and all of these links are going to show
you some fantastic themes you can
install them you can try them out and
you can find one that fits perfectly for
what you like hey everybody this is
Chris Sev here today in this video I
have 20 vs code themes for you 10 which
are more of the popular themes you've
probably seen around and there are 10
lesser known themes which maybe you
haven't seen so let's get straight to it
we are in vs code we have the default
theme enabled right now really decent
theme it's got
dark
it's okay so let's start moving through
the best themes and we'll sort them by
number of installs or I guess you could
call that popularity the first one that
we're gonna have is if we go into our
Command palette with command shift p we
search for color theme we can search for
one dark Pro
and I believe this is probably the most
popular vs code theme most installed and
for good reason it the good looks it has
great colors everything kind of Pops a
little bit better if I scroll down you
can go to one dark flat where it's a
little bit less
prominent colors and there's darker
which gives it a bit of a darker
background it's a great theme but again
one of the most installed so if you want
something else maybe something a little
bit more unique
let's keep moving number two is Dracula
so I'll go to color theme Dracula
it has a purple tint to it very nice
theme very popular
um really unique in it actually exudes
Dracula and nighttime
the number three theme is let's go to
color theme atom one dark
very similar to one dark Pro I think
does great with the symbols and colors
of the symbols
scroll down does great with just markup
in general so very good theme again it
does look like one dark Pro and probably
a pretty common theme
so let's go to the next one we are going
to look at GitHub theme
these are GitHub inspired there's GitHub
dark but if GitHub pretty well you
probably are expecting the light version
and this look at that so bright it is
probably the light theme that I would
jump for if I wanted to go for a light
theme
very nice there's dark dimmed as well
and light default so definitely check
those out
good themes
the next one is by John Papa it is
winter is coming
this is a cool one because it gives a
blue tint and it's just fun overall if
we go to dark blue you can see that
there's a blue tint in the background
blue all over here my problem with this
is that some of the symbols aren't as
legible as the other themes we've seen
so far they don't pop like this export
default function next video it's all the
same color
so great theme if you want that blue hue
to it
next up is by Sarah drosner the theme is
called night owl
again very night inspired theme as its
name suggests it's
I think it inspired the
John Papa theme winter is coming that
came before it with that blue background
so there's not now light
a very good theme
really cool especially for night time
next up monokai Pro
this is one that I have been using for a
while let's install it I didn't have
that installed we'll enable it
monokai Pro
and the cool thing about monokai Pro is
that if I go to color theme monokai Pro
there are different filters as they all
had but there's a blue one octagon is
purple-ish spectrum is darker and
ristretto is a little bit of a brown
tint hard to tell but monokai Pro is a
paid font so just keep that in mind if
you are interested in it it is one of my
favorite fonts
next up is by Ahmad awais shades of
purple you've probably seen this around
very iconic very purple uh really fun
theme a little bit much on the purple
for me and again not too many
differentiators for most of the symbols
since they all are using this light blue
or the orange
so we'll move on from there we'll go to
West boss's theme Cobalt 2.
Cobalt 2 is very yellow blue themey I
like it again not the biggest difference
here is of the symbols so for me not my
go-to but fantastic theme definitely
check it out
and then 10th of the most popular vs
code themes is going to be material
theme
and I think I did that wrong color theme
let's go for material theme and there
are all sorts of different color styles
there's ocean darker lighter
pale night
so definitely check all those out I
think a lot of those are pretty similar
in my book aside from the background the
symbols which all the words they blend
in together so not my favorite there
alright so that is the 10 most popular
ones that you've probably seen around
the web but the next 10 maybe you
haven't seen and I'm actually my daily
driver is in this list of 10 for 10
lesser known vs code themes
so in this batch number one or number 11
overall is going to be pale night
very similar to the night themes in the
first 10
you get that purple you get that blue
cool here's synthwave which is number
12. I really like this one it's a little
bit too much of a pop on the blues for
me
the contrast is a little strong but
really fun with the colors the orange
the purple the red and the light blue
number 13 on this list is Nord
Nord
very nice muted theme if you want a
muted theme that's just
gets out of the way and gets you to
coding but for me again not too much
differentiation on these symbols so
let's keep moving
number 13 number 14 is color theme panda
so this one with that pink theme Panda
really cool colors here I dig it a
little bit strong on these symbols right
here with that light teal-ish but
overall I like the pop of color a little
bit more than the previous Nord so very
nice
next up number 15 is Tokyo night
again another night theme there's
actually a lot of night themes on this
list
so cool night theme again purple and
blue dark inspired
number 16 here is rain glow
a lot of different colors in Rain glow
let's see
so definitely click through the cool
thing about vs code is you get this live
check
theme
preview
overall pretty good colors I think a lot
of them don't really have the contrast
of the symbols again so let's keep
moving
all right this next one is my daily
driver so far and I really like it I've
been using it for about two weeks now
color theme is moonlight
and if you look at Moonlight 2 it's
muted it has that nighttime theme but I
do get a little bit of differentiation
on the symbols so you can see there's a
purple here instead of having all that
be the same color you get the orange the
green there's just enough
differentiation for me that I think it's
really easy to read the different values
so Moonlight too very nice the next one
is number 17 Horizon
so here's Horizon you get a different
color scheme than we've seen before
Less on the blue side more on this red
kind of maroon color
really nice with the purples good theme
next up is bearded theme
there's a few of these bearded void
Earth love the naming here altica
Oceanic
solarize so really good colors there
I like how they're a little bit more
muted except for this Vivid one
Arc eggplant that one's really nice
actually
AOL storm also really nice black and
gold
yeah Storm's not bad
I like that one maybe I'll move that one
and then the last one we have on the
list is a fun one it is going to be
called cyberpunk
and you definitely get that cyberpunk
feel you got that neon green you got
those purples and a little bit of that
pink in there and if you go to the
extension page they do a great job of
showing it off
especially with the borders you get on
that command palette with that green
let's try it out command palette oh we
don't get those oh that's intellisense
let's go see
there we go really nice
colors and borders there super fun
so there you have it there's 10 of the
most popular that you've seen before
probably and 10 of the Lesser known
themes and all together 20 fantastic vs
code themes I think I may switch to that
bearded theme eolstorm
Maybe
see you in the next one
while themes was the first extension
that we installed
fonts is the first setting that we're
gonna change so there's two big ways to
adjust vs code the first would be
extensions here in the extension sidebar
the next will be settings
so we're going to go into our fonts
settings and change out the font so
let's go here to our Explorer let's open
up a file so that we can get a nice file
to preview our font changes
so fonts is something I'm pretty
opinionated about I've gone through many
fonts and try to pick the best to my
liking so I have a couple of
recommendations and then I can show you
a list that I'm going to drop in the
description below where you can actually
click through pick the one that's best
for you and install it and I'll show you
how to do all of that in this video
so the two that I always like to
recommend if I go into Chrome here is
Cascadia code which is a free font by
Microsoft I'm personally a big fan of
kind of the shorter stouter sort of
coding fonts and these are all going to
be mono spaced fonts which means each
character takes up the same width as the
other characters and monospace fonts are
traditionally the best fonts for coding
so Cascadia code is one of my favorites
it's currently my daily driver
code is also another great free font if
you go down here they have a really cool
preview here and what they also show you
is what are called ligatures and some
people love these some people hate these
I personally really like them in my code
and I'll show you how to turn these on
in this video but ligatures is
essentially when you say like not equals
it creates a brand new icon based on
what you just typed and I'll show you
how that works
if you want the links are down below you
can download these from these GitHub
repos you can install them on your
computer and then you can go over to vs
code
and you might think okay so if we want
to change our font settings we would
probably just go into the command
palette just like Chris has said this
whole time
I'm sorry to say this is one of the few
times that you're not going to go into
extensions you're actually going to go
into settings so I'm going to do command
shift p type in settings and you can
open up the settings in a Json format or
the UI format and we'll do the UI format
and we can talk about how the Json Works
in a second
so here are our settings and this is the
UI version of it so what that means is
there's a really nice like little tab
sections over here where you can click
through and figure out which setting to
change
but also we can go up here to search
settings and we'll type in font
and family
so if I scroll up here font family
editor font family this is what's going
to change our font
so I can go in here and say Cascadia
code and the reason I put a quote around
it is because there's a space here so if
there's a space I like to just put the
quote around it just like vs code did
right here for Courier new
so as soon as you type that in you don't
even have to do anything like save or
click a button it just automatically
takes place you go back to index.js and
see the change here
so automatically you see the difference
here we can actually take this and drag
it out to the side and if you drag this
to the side you can see the Dual column
right here so I'll put that over there
and if I remove Cascadia code right
there I'll just cut that out
it immediately changes you can see the
change on the left and I know this isn't
as clean as the previewing themes was
but this is what we have in vs code for
changing fonts and settings so I'll
paste in Cascadia code again
and what I can do here is actually type
in fire code
I have that installed as well fire code
and see that change happen over there so
fire code and Cascadia code are pretty
similar Cascadia code I think is a
little bit chunkier
and then if we talk about my favorite
paid font that would be operator mono
and that is a paid font so I don't like
recommending it too much in these
courses
there is operator mono
so a little different definitely play
around with these you could even if you
wanted to here's Comic Sans
not the best for sure for coding but you
can do it
so definitely go through your list of
fonts and settings and see what you like
the best and here is a website that I
like to show off if you are looking for
the perfect coding font for yourself and
who isn't right this is a great website
by CSS tricks called coding fonts and
you can find it I'll put a link down
below coding Dash
fonts.css-tricks.com and you can click
through all of these great fonts
Cascadia code my favorite here's cost
ligatures italics variable and all of
these you can click through see which
one you like
and once you find one you like there's a
link here to download it find out how to
get it this one is paid let's see a
couple other favorites jetbrains mono I
see a lot of people liking lately
Mono Lisa is good where is that goofy
one comic code I think you like this one
comic code is Comic Sans in monospaced
format so it is technically good for
coding since it's monospaced if you like
that comic new great resource to click
around and find out which coding font
you like the best and then go get it
install it then you come back to vs code
and you can change your setting out here
under editor font family
I'll just put Cascadia code here
so I switch between Cascadia code and
operator mono a lot depending on the day
so those are fonts and that's how you
change them in the settings and just to
reiterate how you get to settings
command shift p settings and we'll click
the UI one
and then you search for font family and
I'll put these instructions down in the
description below
so there we go there's Cascadia code
right there but there's some other font
settings that I want to change and I'm
going to split this out to the right
again cool thing about vs code is you
can do panels side by side like this
so a couple things I want to talk about
for settings while we're already here in
fonts this is the next step to making
our vs code look really good is font
size line height and font ligatures so
these three things put together will
make this look way better
so font size I like to go to 16 for
myself
play around with what you feel is best
and then next up let's go to line height
so I'm just going to search for line
height
and the thing about line height isn't
really calculated off of the font size
so you can't do 1.5 times the font size
because look at that you actually have
to enter in a number so I personally
like my font size to be about 1.6 times
the font size sorry my line height to be
1.6 times the line height so we're going
to go 16 times 1.6 that'll be around 26
so let's say 26 right there
and it gives it some nice spacing right
there
so compare that to the zero that it was
by default everything gets crunched a
little bit more you can even bump that
up to 28 if you like so play around with
what you like right there
the next one I'd like to talk about is
ligatures now this is a make or break
thing if you don't like it don't turn
these on if you do like it give them a
try and use them in your code
so if I search for ligatures right here
the search in the settings is very
powerful so get used to it ligatures
editor font ligatures the way to turn
these on is you go to edit in
settings.json and this is the Json
version that I talked about earlier
so if I click editing settings.json all
of our settings actually is here in this
Json file so everything that happened
here in this UI version actually
translates to this Json object right
here
and I'm going to say true right here and
you get this nice autocomplete and we'll
talk about vs codes autocomplete
intellisense in a future video
so I'll turn that to true we have turned
font ligatures on so let's give it a try
const is equal let's say is equal to
hello is equal to hello
so it doesn't look like that really
changed anything right there
so actually I didn't save this file so
let's save that and immediately you saw
the equals change there so if I change
this to false and press save
you notice the change right there and if
I did not equal to
and I did true right here
there we go we get ligatures so if you
like them use them if you don't no
worries
the last setting we have for fonts that
is really important I think is right now
we have a font size right here
but if we wanted to change this we would
have to go over here and say font size
in our settings and change this right
here
but what we can do and this is something
that most people
don't really have turned on because it's
by default off I personally like to have
it is mouse Zoom
so Mass wheel Zoom right here you click
this on and then you can hold Ctrl and
zoom in and out with your mouse so you
can change the font size on the Fly
so Mouse wheel Zoom is a very helpful
setting to also have
so that was a lot in this video we have
covered fonts we have covered turning
fonts on using the settings and font
family we have covered going into
codepen and trying out a couple
different fonts for yourself
and we have covered a few of the font
settings like line height font size font
ligatures and mouse Zoom
so we are on our way to having a good
looking vs code and then soon we'll get
into the productive part of it where we
can get into our workflows
these are my favorite coding fonts and
to help us out here I have a coding Dash
fonts.css-tricks.com website which is a
microsite that CSS tricks created and I
think it does a fantastic job of
showcasing all of the coding fonts we
have access to
so if I go here you can see all of the
different fonts that are coding fonts
which are mono spaced fonts which means
every character is going to take up the
same amount of width so that it is
uniform lines
so let's get to it what are my favorite
coding fonts I've tried really all of
them and given them a shot but these are
my favorites so number one on my list
that I think is the best coding font out
there the downside is it is paid is
operator mono
so operator mono I love the funness of
it and for me I personally lean to the
shorter fonts not the kind of taller
fonts and a good medium size on the
width so they don't take up too much
space on their lines and I think
operator mono strikes that balance
perfectly and it also brings in a little
bit of Personality with characters like
the f I think looks really cool the T
has a good character and just overall
nice personality in this font
now there are a lot of fonts on this
list that are good middle of the road
fonts but these are my favorites that
I'm pointing out because they have
personality
so number two of my favorite coding
fonts which is a great alternative a
free alternative to cat operator mono is
Cascadia code
Cascadia code also takes that shorter
approach about the same on the widths a
little bit bolder
but a very fantastic coding font
number three on my list is the first
font that introduced me to ligatures and
ligatures are where you type in like
equals equals equals and it combines it
into one character you can see it right
here current theme equals dark
personally I like them not all people
like them so it depends on your workflow
but I like them so I can turn them on
and you can see over here on the right
side it says ligatures check italics
none
variable none so keep that in mind when
you're picking your coding font if you
want ligatures
and fire code is down here
a little bit taller than I'd like a
little bit taller than Cascadia code and
operator mono but it does come with
ligatures and fire a flot look at that
cursive on the comment really cool right
there it may not be your style but I
think it's really fun to look at and
just make sure we're aware of it if you
want to have a fun font
all right number four on this list is
inconsolata and I hope I said that right
it's a little bit thinner than the other
fonts and a lot older I believe and this
is my pretty much first coding font so
it has a special place in my heart and I
still think it looks fantastic compared
to operator mono Cascadia code a little
bit thinner which I like and about the
same Heights and widths
it was kind of hard to pick number five
on this list because the other fonts are
very similar to this and now looking at
it while I'm recording this video I'm
not sure it's my number fifth choice but
it does have good personality a little
bit thinner a little bit of like a serif
feel to it
but it is a cool font so if you like
this style of font definitely check it
out
number six seven and eight are kind of
the gimmick approach fonts here's Comet
code which is Comic Sans in code form
and here's comic new a little bit
thinner a little bit less tall and
here's comic Shands which actually looks
decent I think of all the three so if
you want to pick a Comic Sans type font
maybe you're using it for presentations
just a fun gimmick or if you want to try
as your daily driver comic Shands is a
good one
and honorable mentions these are the
ones that I think do really well but
they didn't make the top five because I
don't think they have enough personality
I think they are great fonts but
just didn't get into the top five so
these are going to be
consolas let me see consolas
another good font similar to Cascadia
code that I like PT mono
right here
a little bit bigger wider source code
Pro right here
San Francisco mono
and Roboto mono
those are my honorable mentions I think
those are great fonts if you want to
check them out and you might be
wondering okay well Chris they're
starting to kind of blend all in
together
I would definitely say give them a try
on your machine on a daily workflow try
to give it a day or so and see if you do
like it and switch between them on the
Fly
you'll notice that you'll start to get
your style like for me I have a shorter
and not as wide medium width type
characters that I like if you go and
start looking at the other ones like
lotion you'll see the big differences
in fonts and you're like okay well this
looks nothing like the other ones that
Chris pointed out that's because it's
not really my style or preference
there's Mona Lisa which I know a lot of
people like a little bit too wide for me
monoid which is way too tall and a
little bit too weird for myself
recursive also a great font but
definitely check out the site click
through see what you like Ubuntu Mano
Victor mono I know that
a lot of people just have different
preferences for different languages as
well so if you want to check these out
I'll put a link to this down below while
we're still here in the make vs code
look good section I want to pass on five
different vs code settings that I use to
make my vs code look a little bit
different than the default now these are
starting to get into a little bit of an
opinionated sort because of these are
the defaults that I like to use so
just check these out maybe you like them
maybe you don't it's all good if you
don't
let's get into it
the first one here is editor tab size
and you can see it right here or you can
start searching for it right here so tab
size I primarily work in JavaScript
these days so I default this to myself
but what's really cool about vs code is
that if you are in a project vs code can
actually detect the indentation so if
you're in a project that has spaces at
four for a tab size then it actually
just says okay I'll just keep using
before
so if you actually click editor detect
indentation that is by default on
and that goes to the setting we just
changed which is tab size and this also
goes to insert spaces
so should pressing tab actually insert
spaces right now vs code defaults to
true and I think that's a good default
to keep
detect indentation so if we go all the
way back to tab size right here
two is a good default for JavaScript and
that's pulling off of the JavaScript
style guides that you can follow Airbnb
is probably the most popular one the
Airbnb style guide I'll actually link to
down below if you want to check that out
but do whatever is best for your code
and for your language
another thing that's really cool about
how vs code handles settings in this UI
version if you change anything from the
default it actually highlights it so
that you always know what has been
changed from yours to the defaults
all right next up let's go to setting
number two that I want to talk about
that is going to be rulers so let's go
to rulers and this is something that you
have to edit in the Json file so I'll
click that
and it actually creates this array right
here
and I'm going to say 80.
so there we go I have 80 as a ruler and
let me show you what that is you can
actually see this is using the four
spaces indent and you can see it down
here spaces is four
and that's because it said oh the Json
file has four I'll just use the four so
that's good to see
so I'll put a ruler at 80 and let me
show you what that does I'm going to
bring settings back here and I'll go
back into my file now we have this line
right here at 80 characters
so if I start typing out and get to 80
characters right there
then it actually doesn't do anything
really it's just a visual guide that
says hey this line is past 80 characters
maybe it's getting a little long maybe
you want to see if you could break this
apart and that's just me personal style
guide I like having things less than 80
characters it makes code far more
readable look at that one a little bit
too long but overall if you keep code to
less than that 80 it'll be nice and
readable so I like to leave the ruler
maybe you can do a ruler at something
less I've seen people do rulers at 120.
anything's valid it's all up to you
another trick is if you are on a line
you can go down here you're on line 12
column 86 so you can actually see how
many characters you're at and if you
highlight some stuff you can see how
many characters you've selected down in
the status bar
fun little tip right there
okay so let's go back into our settings
that was setting number two setting
number three is render indent guides
and this one is on by default so just
make sure it's on what it does
essentially is that it every indent has
this line right here so if you think
that's a little bit too busy you just go
over here turn that off render indent
guides and go here and now look how
clean your code has gotten
so personally I think it's helpful
especially for longer files where
everything is spaced a little bit far
away like you don't know where this main
goes to
but if you have the Indian guide on by
default you go here you can click it and
you can notice where this is aligned to
so that's again all preference
appearance wise turning it off
definitely makes it look a little bit
cleaner
the next one I'm going to bring settings
back to the side right there is word
wrap so this is setting number four word
wrap is not diff editor we're going down
to editor word wrap we can turn this on
and notice how it actually brought this
down into one line so that it doesn't
expand beyond the column right there
and this is again personal preference by
default it's off so your you can scroll
to the side like this or you can have it
on just depends on what you like I
personally just leave it on
and on top of this you can actually say
word wrap at column right here and this
is going to take this setting which is
set to 80 so word wrap column is 80. so
if you go here it actually breaks on the
80 ruler
so another really fun one to have
and speaking of fun I am actually going
to set this back to on speaking of fun I
want to show you one of the maybe most
useless but most fun of the visual
settings here's our cursor I just made
it giant let's go to cursor blinking
so this is setting number five cursor
blinking is blank by default and if you
click here you can see it just blinking
I can go to smooth and click back over
and you see how it changes just a little
bit how the cursor blinks
and phase is pretty similar to smooth
actually
but this is the fun one and maybe if
you're doing a conference talk or a
tutorial or something like that and you
want to show off hit it expand and you
give this fun cursor maybe a little
annoying but super fun either way and
solid just doesn't blink at all
so me personally I do smooth or phase
I'll keep smooth
there we go so it has a fade I think
phase has more of a fade in actually
there we go so we'll keep phase for that
all right so that wraps up the five
settings I think you should take a look
at for appearances
let's keep moving along in the course
so this section is called get to know vs
code if you already know the vs code UI
then feel free to skip this section but
there are a lot of little hidden things
around the vs code UI because there are
so many features packed in that you have
seen a button before a million times but
maybe you don't know exactly what all
the little things do the side panels
terminal the problems panel all these
little things are fantastic when you add
them together to make vs code these are
all of the base features the
foundational features that make vs code
workflows and everything that we're
going to do fantastic so I highly
recommend checking these videos out
check up outline on the sidebar there if
you do think you know most of the vs
code UI you can feel free to jump ahead
to my favorite section the keyboard
shortcut section but this is also a
fantastic refresher or a fantastic
introduction into getting to know vs
code's UI and starting to learn all the
features that we can put together to
make ourselves more productive
in vs code there are probably two really
big places where we're going to spend
most of our time the first is the editor
which is this big area right here where
you'll be writing all of your amazing
code bug free of course and over here on
the sidebar is the Explorer
so if I open up the Explorer into our
sidebar
you'll see I'm starting off with zero
folders zero files in here we can start
off by showing how we can get a folder
into vs code and then working with that
we already talked about cloning a repo
you can click here and clone a repo that
you have you may need to log in with
GitHub which we will talk about later in
this course there is also an open folder
if you want to just bring in a local
folder
I'm going to start us off from scratch
I'm going to go over to our other course
beginnerwebdev.com this is our free
course for getting started with
JavaScript
here's the GitHub repo and I'll put this
down in the description below the link
to this so you can go code right here
and click download zip and we're going
to use this for this video
so now that I've downloaded that zip
file it's going to be on my desktop
that's where I put all my downloads I'm
going to open it up and now here we are
this folder right here
so there are a couple different ways to
open this in vs code one you can just
take the folder drag it in and that
would open it in vs code
another way is there's a couple prompts
right here one is open folder here one
is open right here another is up here
file open
another is command o and another is the
command palette of course command shift
p file open
and that's down here
so any number of ways you can open
a folder let's go ahead and click this
one
and it is probably going to change based
on what scenario you're in sometimes I
do file open sometimes I do command o
but either way they're all good so let's
go into our desktop right here and I'll
open up this folder
and click open
and for that course there's just a bunch
of HTML files with some JavaScript in
them and from here we will talk about
using the Explorer on the side here
so let's close out getting started the
first thing of the Explorer that I want
to talk about is just creating new files
and new folders so here you can create a
new file right there and say hello.html
you can also create a new folder where
we can say
components
the cool thing about vs code is you can
actually just take this grab click drag
it all the way up into the components
folder and it'll say hey are you sure
you want to move hello HTML into
components you can say move and if you
want to remove this prompt you can say
do not ask me again I personally leave
it on because I've accidentally dragged
and dropped some folders and files and
forgot where they went so I'll leave it
on
there is this refresh in case you change
something outside of vs code and you
want the file to change here it's
especially helpful for images let's say
you drag an image into the folder and
you say well where are you just click
refresh and that'll work
this button is really helpful as well I
use it quite often actually so whenever
there's like a lot of folders a lot of
things open in your larger projects and
you want to just compress and get back
to zero you just click this it'll
collapse everything and just get you
back to a clean State that's it for
those buttons up there next up I want to
talk about right clicking and going into
the context menu here you can do new
file new folder reveal in finder which
is a good way to kind of just get the
folder in finder or in Windows Explorer
and that'll find it there you can also
open an integrated terminal so this will
start the terminal in this folder right
here and then from here you can do LS
you can do any of your stuff that you
need from the terminal
and we'll talk more on that in the
terminal workflow video there's so much
functionality here you can write open
folder settings remove folder from
workspace add folder to workspace so
these are workspace settings that we'll
talk about in the workspace workflow
video
find in folder is really helpful if you
wanted to say like I just want to search
in components you could say find in
folder and we'll talk about that in the
find and search feature video
a lot of features that we will break
down in multiple videos
so now that we've talked about what I
think are the visual settings in
Explorer let's talk about the things
that are kind of hidden that are cool
features there's this dot dot right here
where you can click you can see open
editors
and you can click that and there we get
this little section called open editor
so if I called in hello world and opened
that up you would see Hello World here
and you would also see it under open
editors and I can go here to built-in
objects I can go here to pricing
calculator and it would show and I would
double click to keep them open right
there and right there
okay so let's close out some of these
files and the next thing I want to do is
go here and say outline so outline is a
really really cool feature in Explorer
so let's say I open up this file
built-in objects
and we have here our outline here's the
HTML and you can click it and it
navigates directly to that in your file
you can click the title right here it
goes there and if you go down you can
see there's a script tag I can click
first and it actually shows the
JavaScript variables that are right here
what's cool about this too is the
outline right here is kind of the
breadcrumbs and outline and it also
shows up here in your editor there's
script right here and you can click
there you can go to the head of the
document and click here go to the body
and you can open up the body so there's
a lot of different ways to navigate vs
code and it's up to you to find your
favorite way to navigate
another good setting here in the outline
section is to click this Dot and say
follow cursor so now wherever I go up
here it'll actually highlight the title
highlight the head highlight the style
tag right here in the body and all that
good stuff with the Explorer there is
the outline and there's the files I want
to talk about one extension for the
Explorer we'll go into extensions
and it's called Advanced new file
so it won't be this first one that has
50k downloads it'll be the second one
that has 163k downloads I'll click
install there
and once that's installed you can scroll
down here read up on how it's used I'm
going to close this actually go back
into Explorer
and let's say I wanted a new file in
components normally I'll have to click
components click this new file right
here and then I would get a new file
Advanced view file is cool because we
can do everything from the command
palette we don't have to leave our
keyboard
I can say command shift p to open up the
command palette you can say Advanced new
file
and I'll click enter there and now we
can say okay what folder do you want to
create a new file in let's do components
and it'll do this fuzzy search so if you
start typing it'll
filter down the results I'll press enter
and then it says okay well what file
name do you want in that folder I'll say
goodbye dot HTML
and it'll open it up for you so you can
start typing right away
events you file very helpful extension
for the Explorer so that you can get up
and running with new files as quickly as
possible
I encourage you to click this drop down
figure out which settings you like open
editors outline whatever you like over
there or if you just like to turn things
off and turn that off and turn that off
and keep it just to your files
that's also totally valid figure out
what's best for you just know that these
are all the options available to you
we just talked about the Explorer over
in the sidebar which is probably the
second most important part of vs code
the number one most important part is
right here right in the middle the
editor and we are going to talk about a
couple settings and a couple features of
the editor and we'll definitely be
working with this way more throughout
this course but these are ones I want
you to be aware of for moving forward
to start off I am going to open the
sidebar and there's a whole section of
this course based on keyboard shortcuts
but I'm going to sprinkle them in here
and there because I think they're so
important to productivity I'm going to
open the sidebar with command B
and let's open up maybe this operator's
one right here
I'm going to close the sidebar command B
I want to start off with feature number
one is breadcrumbs which we talked about
in the previous video you can click here
click this drop down see everything
that's going on inside of this file all
the way down to script even see the
variables inside of there
so that's breadcrumbs really helpful to
have right there here is the mini map
which is good to click and drag around I
actually use this a lot
and what is fun productivity tip is
let's say I have a really big file which
I try not to but sometimes it happens
what you can do here is and I know this
isn't the prettiest thing but you can
actually maybe do some stuff like this
and what I'll do here is I'll just
replace all of these with like equal
signs
and I will take this line right here and
put it above and below some HTML
comments or JavaScript comments whatever
they be
so right here now you can see in the
minimap that there's a section right
there where it's big and a giant HTML
comment and really what that is for me
is a way to say hey in the minimap oh
that's where a new section starts that's
where a new section starts so it's all
preference I know this is a jarring
tactic but for me it works definitely
check with the people you're working
with on your team if they like this sort
of thing but the minimap helps us do
that
all right the next thing I want to talk
about which is a really fun tactic is
side by side editing and I use this very
often so if I go back into Explorer
right here I can actually click this
open it up
and the easiest way to get side-by-side
editing is two different ways one you
can click the tab drag it over and you
can see the Highlight here you can
highlight to the right and drop it and
it'll split the vs code side by side
another thing you can do is drag it back
over
I can save this little button right here
we'll click it and go side by side and
it actually opens up both so if I
actually edit one getting started with
JavaScript exclamation exclamation
exclamation notice how it edits both
left and right so it's still the same
file even though it's technically open
in both spots but what you can do here
is scroll down so you can like reference
something down here while you're typing
up at the top of the file
okay so I'll drop that
another way to open up side by side
editing is to option click any of these
files so I'll option click there and it
goes side or I can double click and then
drag or I can double click and then
click this button right here
but we're not only limited to side by
side editing you can actually take this
and drag it to the bottom
right there so now you have top and
bottom which can be helpful
what I can do also is this button right
here if I hold the option button and
hover it now it splits up and down
vertically so you can do that vs code is
so great at giving us so many options so
I'm trying to surface as many of the
options as possible to you and feel free
to not use all of them feel free to use
some of them it all depends on how you
think your workflow would work best
how you can be most productive
so that's all the ways to get different
splits really cool here is you can
actually split this out to the side and
then now we have editor groups so I can
have this group open I can have this
group open and if I go open up another
file notice how it adds to this group I
can just drag that over into this group
and vice versa
very helpful there
another helpful tip is editor groups you
can actually do a structured layout here
if you go to view editor layout you can
even do a two by two grid right here and
then start dragging things up and down I
don't know I don't use this myself very
much but it could be helpful
so let's close all these out
and of course all of these things can be
done with the command palette so you can
do command shift p to open up the
command palette and you can say split
editor and you can do down right left so
I'll do right right there
and you can even do split two by two
let's see if I can find it two by two
there we go grid editor layout two by
two
and there we go
all right so that's how we can get split
editors editor groups the one setting I
want to talk about for the editor and I
just closed everything is
this enable preview setting and I'll
talk about this in a second but when you
open a file in vs code it doesn't
actually open the file it opens a
preview of the file
now some of you may like this I did not
like it when I got in the vs code I
still don't like it so I disable it and
I'll show you how so if you click a file
notice how here it's italicized the file
name which means it's a preview it's not
open yet
so for me I click it I want it open but
by default vs code says well you opened
it but it's just a preview so if you
click to another file it opens up the
other file in the same tab so it's not
like you're opening two tabs you're just
opening previews of multiple files so
there's really no tabs open
so to actually keep this and open the
file you double click right here or you
start editing the file so I can click
here and notice italicize as soon as I
say down here something like hi then it
turns non-italicized and I'm actually
editing the file
if you like the preview way where you
actually opens up a file and then if you
click away it closes a file
then by all means keep that setting for
me I don't really like it so I'm going
to go into our settings command comma
I'm going to go enable preview
and this will be workbench editor enable
preview I turn mine off
so now whenever I let's close all of
these command W let's open up our
sidebar with command B I can click and
notice how it's not italicized it's open
and I can just open as many as I want
so that's personal preference
the last thing that I want to talk about
in this video is talking about our
startup state
when we open up vs code we get this
brand new getting started link right
here and we don't usually need this and
I I don't actually really use this page
the welcome page so to check off this
welcome page so that you don't see it
again on Startup you can click this
button right here show welcome page on
Startup that removes it what do we
actually see when we open up vs code now
let's close vs code and reopen it
we should see not the welcome page we
just see a blank state so there's
nothing new there
we can customize this let's go into our
settings command comma
and we'll say startup editor
and the startup editor is none because
we unchecked that welcome page box if
you click here you can see that welcome
page is the default you can do readme
new Untitled file welcome page in empty
workbench I like doing new Untitled file
and the other thing to this so let's
close out vs code let's reopen it
now when we have a new Untitled file it
says select language to get started
start typing to dismiss or don't show
this again so you can actually click
this which is really cool it's like a
button inside of your text
or you can select the language which
actually opens up this button down here
plain text you can choose the language
that this file is based on that little
drop down there and you can also change
it by command shift p and saying
language mode and you can change this to
markdown
so I usually like markdown for my new
files I use it a lot when I'm writing
notes and I'll do any sort of notes
outlines that I need to do maybe my
to-do list for the day
we can also change the setting by going
to command comma and doing default
language
and then down here default language you
just type in markdown and now markdown
will always be the file type that is
opened when you do a new file so if I do
new file right there I just double
tapped it right there it opens up a
markdown file or if I open up a brand
new vs code that will be a markdown file
as well and for me I like this it works
well for my workflow I do a lot of
markdown writing when I'm taking notes
or writing a new article for you if you
want to do JavaScript or whatever else
you do that would be files default
language but now when we open up vs code
from scratch we get a new file we don't
see that welcome page anymore and we get
a markdown file that we can work in
all right so I hope that was a helpful
video there's a lot to do with the
editor and split editing is very helpful
we'll be working a lot more with the
editor in the rest of this course
this video is about a feature called
intellisense and before we get into it I
kind of want to start with a question
what is the difference between a text
editor and an IDE or in other words an
integrated
integrated development
environment
versus a text editor and let me zoom in
here
and I will actually use the zoom scroll
that we learned about
so a text editor is going to be a text
editor but what is the difference
between editing text and having an IDE
or an integrated development environment
so to me the difference is having all of
the features on top of a text editor
because right now we just used vs code
as a text editor
but now we get all of these fun things
like a file explorer like search and
replace like git and Source control in
here debugging extensions all of these
things you wouldn't find in a normal
text editor this is more stuff that you
would find in an IDE
so as far as things go text editor is
something like text edit that you would
find on Mac and let's just like create a
new document this would be a text editor
not the fanciest thing ever right
and this would kind of be the equivalent
of maybe notepad in the windows side of
things
so let me close that
and IDE is really cool because as coders
we get some special features like
intellisense out of vs code and
intellisense isn't a vs code specific
thing there are other Ides like the
tools from jetbrains like webstorm but
intellisense is really a feature that is
giving what is called code completion
it's saying when I start typing can my
IDE help me out to know what I need to
type next
and the cool thing about vs code is that
it totally does so intellisense is a
feature that gives a couple things like
code completion and we'll see that in a
second and you kind of already see it
happening parameter info
Quick Info
member lists and a lot more features but
I will put a link down to the vs code
intellisense docs definitely check those
out but instead of just reading through
the docs let's actually build something
on our own
I'm going to delete this file don't save
that go into my file explorer right here
command B to open up the sidebar here
and I'm going to go new file
and let's go for just test.js so now we
have a Javascript file and out of the
box vs code has intellisense for
JavaScript files typescript files Json
HTML CSS SAS and less and also there are
extensions that can give vs code some
more power to do other languages like
PHP like Ruby like python
and I'll drop links down below for all
that stuff
so let's give this a try let's say we
start typing out some JavaScript const
person is equal to and let's make it an
object name is Chris
and let's say age is 32 and I'm 32 at
this time of writing
so let's go down here and let's see
intellisense in action immediately if I
say person
notice how it says oh hey you probably
are wanting person so cons person press
that little button there and now we'll
see this I I am pretty zoomed in because
of this video and recording so you
probably will be able to see the whole
thing on your computer
so now I can say person
and I'll press Dot
and notice how we get age name and it
says age is a number and if I go down
here and press down name is a string so
you can actually see both of the
properties on this object and that's
intellisense for you so I'll say age
right there
so that's really cool we get vs code to
tell us a little bit more about this
object
and if I actually let's say we had to
find this object way up there and we
were down in our file and we were like
okay well I need the person Dot and you
say oh I forgot about what was in that
object you can say oh name I need
person.name
so that's really cool as well
that is the way that intellisense can
kind of Auto hint at what is going on
let's say I even had a function function
say message
and let's say alert a message here
and then I went down all the way into
the bottom of my file or I wanted to use
this somewhere else I could say and
that's a function so it says hey I'm a
function and you'll see that little like
purple Cube thingy
and it says message is any
okay so that's pretty helpful I can say
saily and then it says message is any so
now you know the parameters that are
part of this function so that's
intellisense
intellisense Triggers on these trigger
keys so if I did this and I opened up
these parentheses right here it would
trigger and show what's going on but if
I clicked out of it and clicked into it
it would not trigger so the way to
trigger intellisense is to do control
spacebar
and now wherever you are intellisense
will try to come in and say oh well did
you want this message is any so that
works out that's how we activate
intellisense
the next thing I want to show about
intellisense is that we can add a little
bit more info so let's say the save
function had a message that it wants
right say message I can right click here
and I can go to definition and it kind
of Scrolls to the top there
that's also a really cool feature of vs
code that it can know where the function
is that you're calling and go to the
definition of it and I did that by going
down here and saying right click go to
definition and you can also
command see that highlight and click and
it'll go to the definition as well so
command click will get you all the way
up to wherever it is even if it's in
another file
let's say I wanted to add a little bit
more to this and say okay let's add a JS
doc let's go like this JS dot comment
press enter that was intellisense also
and it knows hey we already had a
message in this function so we're going
to say hey what do you want that to be
I'll say that's a string
so now if I go down here to where we
defined it or started using it I can say
right here
open that up and it says message is now
a string so
intellisense is actually telling us what
type it is
and there's a lot more ways that
intellisense can help us out this is
only scratching the surface and we're
going to get a lot into it
during this whole course
the best way to be productive is to let
vs code help us out like why are we
typing all of this code if vs code can
just say hey this is what it is let me
autofill it for you you don't need to do
all of the typing
intellisense is also smart enough to
know the types of our variables so let's
say I had person.name which is a string
I can do a DOT on here and it knows all
of these string Methods that are on
javascript's string object and I can go
like let's say two
uppercase
and I can do that
and that would go and change that all to
uppercase intellisense does a lot for us
and we just need to learn how to make
sure that we look for it so that we can
help intellisense help us
moving forward in this course we are
going to be adding extensions that can
enhance and extend intellisense itself
and we just need to know that we are
going to be working with a lot of
intellisense and you should on a daily
basis look to intellisense to help you
speed up and be more productive
the next essential feature that I want
to talk about in vs code is find and
replace
now this sounds like the most boring
feature I'm sure but it actually is
extremely powerful
to start us off I have the same file
that we had in the last video and it's
just test.js I have a function here I
added this JS doc comment and we have
this param string is message and our
function here
so let's say I said say hi there
let's copy this line down a couple times
and I'll show you how we do that in
keyboard shortcuts in the keyboard
shortcuts section of this course which
is going to be fantastic in my probably
favored section
so there are three ways to search in vs
code so this first one I'll show you is
inline and I'll just do command f and
that'll pop it up right here also you
can do command shift p to open up your
command palette and do find right here
and scroll down to find right there
now I can type in say
and if you press enter a bunch of times
it'll cycle through all of them so
notice how this one is highlighted down
here if I press enter it'll go to the
top and if I keep pressing enter it'll
go and cycle through them all
so that's how we can find in vs code you
can see there's six of six there are
some options here for match case so you
can say only uppercase or the case has
to be the exact same there's match whole
word and there's regular expression if
you know how to use those I personally
still don't
but this arrow down here
is going to let us toggle replace mode
and what I can do here is
say instead of say I'll say speak and
I'll press enter
and notice I can go and cycle through
and say okay replace this one right here
so this button says replace and this
plugin on the right says replace all
so I can press this right here and it'll
say speak a message now and I can just
keep pressing enter enter enter so I'll
undo these command z z z z z
and if I just press replace all right
here check that out it replaced all of
them all the way down
so that's really helpful of a feature
we can command F right here go through
the list all in there or if we wanted a
little bit more power we could open up
our sidebar and click this search icon
right here and I can say search let's
search for say and the power of this
over here versus the one that's in line
is the inline one is only searching the
current file and this one will actually
search across all the files in your
project
so by default this files to include will
pretty much be everything in your
project
files to exclude you can say don't
search certain folders so let's say you
didn't want to search for a components
folder you would say components
don't search anywhere underneath that
components folder and you can use these
Globs to say what you want to vs code
the other cool thing to note about files
to exclude is that the node modules
folder if you're in a JavaScript project
some git folders are already excluded
you don't have to actually explicitly
write them in and you can see that by
going into your settings by going to
command comma
and do search exclude
and down here search exclude it
automatically removes node modules power
components these git files are excluded
as well
so that's really helpful
the other thing you can do is go into
your Explorer right here and say I
wanted to search inside of this image
folder you could right click in here and
say find in folder
so really I just want to get you all the
different ways that you can open up find
and replace so that you can use each one
when your situation needs it so I'll do
find in folder and it opens up the
search panel right here and it
automatically fills the files to include
right there
so that's essentially what find in
folder does
so we can actually click this right here
files to include we won't do that
anymore we can click this down and say
speak and notice how it'll go down here
and kind of show you what will be
replaced for all the way down and you
can do this replace all button and it'll
do it across all the files that you have
the third way that we can do a search is
this plus right here to this little
Document Plus adding new search editor
from view I can click that it opens up
this big thing and I can do say
just like we did earlier but it gives
you a little bit more context about the
file that it's in
so that's the third way I personally
don't really use this way I usually use
the sidebar right here a lot and I'll
use the inside here in line one with
command f as well
a fun trick which I will show you in the
keyboard shortcuts section is let's say
I did command f and I typed in say so
now there's one two three four five six
I can actually press option enter now
and it highlights them all with the
multi-cursor editing thanks to vs code
and I can say something right there so I
can type in multiple places thanks to
find and replace in vs code and the
multi-cursor editing so that's a really
fun trick we're gonna do a whole video
on multi-cursor editing next up I want
to show you a really cool feature of vs
code vs code is an IDE it's smarter than
a text editor and because it can do a
little bit smarter stuff we can go down
here and let's say we use this way down
in a file and we can right click on say
and we have a list of things here go to
definition is one and we've used this
before we click it and it goes to the
file where we actually defined the
function
let's go down let's do this again let's
go right click if you didn't want to go
to the actual definition of it you could
go down here and say find all references
so now it opens up this references panel
on the sidebar and you can see all the
places you can click through and go to
each section
we have all of these references and we
see where the save function has been
used
what we can do also is right click here
and say rename symbol
and we can write in here say message
and now check this out vs code knows all
the times that we've actually used this
function and if I press enter here it
will go ahead and replace all of them
all the way down so this will work
across multiple files as well
another cool thing here we can do in the
context menu is right click say message
and here is go to definition references
rename symbol there's also this peak
thing right here that is really cool we
can click Peak go to Peak definition and
check this out we now see the definition
of it inline down below the actual place
that we were so we didn't jump around
files or up different lines we just said
hey can I peek at what the definition
looks like
and you can even edit in here and you
can say Okay alert message I don't want
to do that let's just console.log the
message here alerts a little invasive
so now that looks good you can close
this right here and if I go up here it
changed so when you peek at something
you can actually even edit that file in
that Peak
there is some really really powerful
stuff with how vs code can find and
replace and refactor our code so
something as boring as find and replace
is actually refactoring code all the way
across our entire project
I just want you to be aware of all the
different ways we can find and replace
things with rename symbol go to
definition find all references find
implementation and then classic find and
search a lot of really powerful stuff
even though it may seem a little simple
we touched on something in the previous
episode which I think is really cool but
I didn't really get to talk about it
enough and I've been using it a lot more
lately so I definitely want to touch on
refactoring a little bit more
let's say I have here the repo for the
website the better Dev website and I
have a file called get airtable posts
air table posts right here
and this is how we get all of the
content for this website from airtable
which is our database CMS
so here I have export async function get
airtable posts and this is a typescript
file but what I really want to talk
about is the ability to say okay well
get airtable posts there's only one
place we're getting posts from so maybe
I want to rename this to get posts
instead of get airtable posts
so you may think okay well let's go here
I'll highlight this
and I'm going to do a find all so I'll
do command shift f
and that finds all of the uses of this
and here is let's see here is where we
do the import here's where we actually
use it cons post is equal to await get
airtable posts
and then over here so it's used in a
bunch of different places so I would
have to click one by one to go do the
updates
the cool thing about this is that I
could go here right click
find all references
and now we get all the files where it's
actually used
which is very similar to the find all
but find all finds all of the times that
you use the word which also includes get
airtable hosts
so notice that this is a comment it's
not an actual reference it's not usable
code
command shift F will find it where are
we slug index posts right there so it
finds it in the comments
and then down here if I do find all
references
it won't find that comment so that's why
that is a big difference that's why it's
an important difference
the other thing we have here is right
click we can do
find all implementations
so the only time that we ever actually
implement it where we Define the
function itself is this one spot in
airtable posts
so if you were in the other file you
could do find implementation and then
you could find where that file was
created
another thing we can do is right click
and do change all occurrences
where it immediately highlights it all I
don't think it does multiple files
though
all right so now the big one that I
wanted to talk about is rename symbol so
refactoring in vs code has a lot of
different features this is probably the
easiest one because I think it helps the
most when you need to rename functions
or variables whatever you got to do
rename symbol here and right here it
just pops up and I can say get posts is
now what I want to call this thing press
enter and it changes across the entire
file system
so now if I go into my git panel right
here
see all the changes I see that it is
updated here
I see that down here see this little
green area on the sidebar I can go down
here and it's updated there as well get
Airy table posts to get posts
in the other files it's also updated
so I actually use this rename symbol a
lot I'll go here rename symbol shortcut
for that is F2
error table posts we'll bring it back
and there we go
rename simple and the refactoring tools
in vs code are very powerful that's what
changes from just a text editor over to
a stronger IDE an IDE has features like
this
keep it in mind when you need to do a
big rename instead of just doing find
all and replace all go ahead and use
rename symbol
one of the big reasons why vs code has
grown in such popularity so quickly is
its extension Marketplace
the extension Marketplace allows us to
customize vs code to however we as
individuals code and it helps us become
more productive for our specific use
cases
I want to talk quickly about a little
bit of how the extensions work and a
little bit of what we can do with the
extensions I know we touched on this a
little bit in the videos earlier vs code
has done a great job at making
extensions easy to use
here we have the extension Marketplace
we can scroll down see what's trending
we can see the most popular extensions
here python C eslint prettier which
we'll talk about later live server which
we'll talk about later in the course
all of these great extensions we can add
to our own vs code
we can add them through the website
right here
marketplace.visualstudio.com and we can
click install which actually just opens
up vs code you can say open vs code
right there
I'll click cancel I usually don't really
search in the marketplace myself I go
straight to vs code itself
to the extensions tab right here in the
sidebar and that is command shift X to
open that up
so far we have these one two three four
extensions installed here are some
recommended extensions that we can also
install we'll talk a lot more about
extensions later in this course
but really what I want to do is just
show off that you can search for things
like prettier
once we click install right here you can
see the extension install you can see it
over here it'll open up the docs and all
that good stuff that you can read
through down here
definitely read through each of the docs
for each extension that you're looking
to install
I can close that go into my extensions
if I needed to uninstall this
let's say I didn't have that typed in
and we had all of our installed
extensions right here you can see this
drop down right here we have five
installed I can go down to prettier
click the settings thing right here and
click uninstall
that'll say reload required so we'll go
ahead and reload it
so that's installing and uninstalling
extensions
another thing we can do is say we have a
project here this is getting started
with JavaScript so if we had a python
extension installed
and let's go ahead and install this one
always be sure to read the number of
downloads it has it's important to know
if it's the popular one you're looking
for or if it's
name the same but not the popular one
I'll click install there
installing go ahead do your thing and
then once that installs I can go and
close this out
so let's say we are in this JavaScript
project and we have this python
extension installed in this pylance one
also we don't want these python
extensions working in this JavaScript
project
rule of thumb the more extensions that
we have the slower vs code is going to
get
now vs code is very good at staying
performant but it's always good to say
let's not install any extensions that we
don't need for a project
instead of uninstalling these we can
actually just go to this settings right
here and say disable for the workspace
or disable across all of our projects
for this workspace this instance of vs
code will say this is a JavaScript we
don't need python so we'll disable that
and notice it disabled one and two
does Jupiter one I don't know where that
came from it seems like the python one
installed it let's disable that one as
well
and now this vs code workspace for this
JavaScript project does not have any
python extensions enabled
the next thing I want to talk about is
something really fun if I go into my
Explorer right here let's say I am
working on this project and I have a
couple other people working on this
project as well
to get it synced up I want everybody to
have the certain extensions that I'm
using maybe I want them to have prettier
so they can Auto format their code so we
are all on the same page
you can actually tell vs code to
recommend extensions to anybody working
in the same project now this is a really
cool feature you can do command shift p
to open up the command palette right
there and say recommended extensions
so this will configure the recommended
extensions I'll click that
and now vs code has opened up a DOT vs
code folder with a new extensions.json
file
and let me see if I can zoom in a little
bit it's a little small there
and to add to this we have to go over
here to this recommendations array and
start adding here
so the way to do that is if I go into
extensions and let's say I wanted
prettier
you would click on prettier itself
and I'm going to close the sidebar with
command B and this is what you want
right here espnp dot prettier Dash vs
code so I'll copy that
go into
extensions.json and recommended right
there
now that this is in the recommendations
in this
extensions.json file I can close this
whole project and let's say we give this
project to somebody else let's say they
git clone it they download it whatever
they do and they bring it into their vs
code so I'll reopen vs code
and let's make sure this folder is
opened I might have to reopen it
so I can click open folder here or I can
just drag and drop it in
and now once it's open on another
person's computer and vs code says oh
there's this recommendations it'll do
this pop-up down here and says do you
want to install the recommended
extensions for this repo so this is
really great for when you're working on
projects with a big team or even just a
small team right you can show
recommendations or you can click install
I'll click install there and it
automatically goes ahead and installs it
and you'll see that it went to the
extension sidebar panel here and it did
the at recommended
so workspace recommendations are right
there other recommendations uh we don't
need those but it's really good to see
that just with this one file we can say
that all the people on our team are
going to be on the same vs code page
that's it for extensions we've installed
uninstalled checked out the extension
Marketplace we have been able to disable
per workspace and we're able to
recommend our friends and other coders
the extensions that we want them to use
the next feature I want to talk about
which is essential to using vs code
especially when you have multiple
computers is settings sync we've already
changed a few settings we've already
changed a few extensions here in our vs
code setup
we don't really want to redo this when
we go over to another computer that we
own right maybe we have a work computer
and we also have a personal computer
vs codes solve this problem for us we
just go into this little icon down here
with this person face we click here and
go sign in to sync settings
you have the option of Microsoft or
GitHub will go sign in with GitHub
that'll open us up here all you have to
do is Click continue after you've logged
in with GitHub now it'll say hey vs code
wants to open this link can we do that
yep we'll say allow this extension to
open this URI yes go ahead and with that
anytime we sign into vs code across any
different computer we are going to have
our settings and extensions synced all
the way across in this video we'll be
talking about one of the most often used
features of vs code but sometimes I see
people that just don't take advantage of
them so I want you to be aware that
Snippets are a big part of vs code's
workflows
here I'll open up a new file and you can
do this by clicking command n
or you can also if I close that with
command W just double click right here
and it'll open up a new file
Snippets are really useful because it
basically just takes a ton of code that
you have to write often and shortens it
down to a couple characters so that it
expands whatever you're typing for
instance if we were in a Javascript file
and I went down here and to the status
bar and clicked select language mode you
can click JavaScript right here
and I type in a for Loop and I can type
4 you can see that intellisense came in
and said hey maybe you want these things
and you can click this four right here
for the for Loop and look at this it
made a giant for Loop of stuff that I
usually had to write by hand but now it
just does it for me and I can actually
type and say let index that makes sense
and I'll press tab
and now that goes over to the next thing
and I can say items and that will be
enough to take that over and I can
change this to item
so all in all a snippet was able to help
us write all of this code just by typing
in four
fo clicking down a couple times and then
pressing enter
another way that you can activate a
snippet using intellisense is fo and
just press Tab and that will auto
complete whatever is highlighted and
again fo click down a couple times and
then do Tab and now we have a different
sort of for Loop
so Snippets are very powerful and
especially when they are shown To Us by
intellisense
so let me delete all of this the other
ways we can activate a snippet is if I
did command shift p with the command
palette and did snippet I can do insert
snippet click that and now you can do
your search in here so there's the for
Loop there are some other things like
this do while we can scroll down and see
all the other things let's do a
set interval
so I did the set interval and let's say
we want it at 1000 milliseconds I can
press tab which are called tab stops in
Snippets
and now I can write all of my code here
the cool thing about Snippets is that
they have those tab stops where it says
hey here's some code that you may want
to write but also if you press tab here
are the relevant places you probably
want to customize for yourself
I highly recommend command shift p to
open up the command palette insert
snippet right there
click enter and just scroll down and see
what is built into vs code there's a lot
in there
but what also is cool is that extensions
are able to extend how many Snippets we
have
so if I go into my extensions panel
right here and I do at category and let
me actually just type this in from
scratch at
and if you just type in at Snippets
you'll see this autocomplete bin
category Snippets and I can click that
and you'll notice there are some
extensions that have Snippets so these
are just larger language style packages
that also have Snippets there are some
packages sorry extensions that do have
just Snippets so here's the es6 code
Snippets one I can click that
it'll open it up and if I scroll down
you should be able to see these Snippets
that are in this package it tells you
what languages it will open Snippets in
I can scroll down imp does this nice
import which is really helpful IMD does
it when it's destructured of an import
so we're going to talk about this more
in the JavaScript workflows video but
here I'm just going to go ahead and
install it and enable it
that's great so there's our QR for
require and all of these good Snippets
to add to ourselves
now the thing about this is that it can
be really hard to remember which snippet
that you want
so I would say read through the docs get
familiar with the ones that you think
you'll use the most for me imp for sure
Takes the Cake for imports
we have IMD
for import destructoring and I can type
that into say react and I can do like
use State like that
and I press tab to jump between the two
areas from this right side to this left
side
and if you don't know what snippet you
need you can do command shift p insert
snippet and just do import
and notice how this autocomplete stuff
is going to help you out with the ones
that you want I didn't even know IMA
exists what is that oh import as Alias
gotcha
so I can say react use State I probably
wouldn't use it in this case but
go state
command palette is a really good friend
to this for Snippets so that's how we
can do that
the last part of this video is I want to
teach you how to build your own custom
Snippets this is really helpful there's
a couple different things that you could
need for yourself that maybe are not in
certain specific snippet packages
so for us to start a new snippet I'll do
command shift p and do Snippets
and you can see here preferences
configure user Snippets so we'll press
that right there
and now this can be a new Global
Snippets file you can say a file
specific to a language like JavaScript
typescript or typescript react whatever
you need I'm going to go and say Global
Snippets file so this will activate in
pretty much all of the files we have
and I'll just name this Chris Snippets I
guess
all right so place your Global Snippets
here
each snippet is defined under a snippet
name and has a scope prefix body so this
is a good example for the snippet that
you can use so I'll actually copy this
right here
and actually I'll uncomment this out
because it's already in this big object
that we need so command forward slash
will uncomment
and I'll delete that right there
so this is print to console scope is
Javascript or typescript prefix prefix
is the trigger word that you're going to
use so here is log
you're going to write out the word log
and then the body is going to be
console.log and then dollar sign 2 is
where you're going to tab stop over to
and you get a description so let's run
through what this means prefix is what
we're going to type body is what's going
to get inserted and then the tab stops
where we're going to fill in information
is this dollar sign one and dollar sign
2. and the way you can do multiple lines
is you do an array like that so let's go
check this out in our application we
have a Javascript file here if I go here
and type in log you can see print to
console and that's the one we just
created so I'll click that you see hi
there I am typing at first position
and then if I press tab here it'll jump
over to dollar sign two and I can keep
on my Merry way and command forward
slash to comment that out
so if I go back over here printer
console is what's going to show in the
description
scope is here prefix is here body is
what gets inserted and description if I
go over here command shift p insert
snippet log
log output to console so this is the
description that shows but when you're
in the file itself it shows the actual
name of the snippet
we can also add a default value for this
if I remove these strings right here
and I did a bracket around the one like
this and I did my object and I can do
the same for this too
and say
right
more
so now anything inside of this brackets
on the right side of this colon will be
the default value so let's say I go over
here to our Javascript file I type in
log
print to console now my object I can say
whatever my object is that I'm console
logging maybe it's data press Tab and
then I can keep on my Merry way
so that's how we can add default values
to Snippets
Snippets are really really powerful
writing your own is very helpful you
might not need to though because of the
great extensions in the extension
Marketplace
I guess the hardest part about using
Snippets is knowing which Snippets exist
so that does take a little bit of work
up front to go read out the docs and
make sure you do command shift p insert
snippet and kind of read through
everything in there
this next feature I want to talk about
is something I love absolutely love
working with and I use it on a daily
basis it's called Emmett now that might
sound like a weird name for a tool but
Emmett is a very cool tool to let us
write better HTML and CSS even faster
than we ever thought possible
so Emmett I'm on Emmett's website the
cool thing about Emmett is that it's
available in many editors so it's in vs
code you can even use it inside of a
code pen so here I am inside of a code
pen and if I look at the emit cheat
sheet so if you want to get good at
Emmett definitely check out the cheat
sheet it helps us do all of the fancy
emit things
let me go here into codepen and I'll
demonstrate here and then we'll go into
vs code and we'll demonstrate there
if I wanted to write some HTML I would
say div Let's do an H2 and say hi there
H2 there P tag and say let's get started
a button Maybe
go now
and we'll close that div
so that's the hero image or a hero
section to a website let's talk about
how we can do the same thing with Emmett
and this follows closely along with the
Snippets video that came before this
it's basically writing a ton of Code by
writing less
to do that I'm going to say div
and then do this Arrow so that's saying
inside of this div there's going to be
an H2 and the text in the H2 is going to
say hi there
and then next to the H2 I'm going to
have a P tag and it's going to say let's
get started
and then next to that I'll have a button
and it's going to say go now
and all I have to do now is press Tab
and that will auto complete all of that
thanks to Emmett and you got that nice
kind of preview inside of codepen
and that's Emmett the other cool things
we can do with Emit and I know I'm
working in vs code but this is a code
pin the syntax is the exact same from
code bin to vs code
so you can actually type all of this
that I'm typing in vs code
I can do like a UL inside of that An Li
we can say times five of those and now
there's five list items inside of those
in a tag
and inside of those say text
there we go right there in addition to
that we can do classes and IDs you can
say div and say hero and then inside of
that hero I'm going to have a list of P
tags so let's say p
and say item
and inside of that I am a
paragraph
but what's cool about Emmett is we can
actually do a little bit more we can say
I am paragraph number and put a dollar
sign there and then we'll say times 10
and notice how you have 10 paragraphs
one two three four five all the way down
and you can even put the dollar sign on
the class name itself
and press Tab and that will autocomplete
all of that there
so Emmett is a fantastic tool you can
use this to write react code HTML view
code whatever you're doing and there's a
handy dandy cheat sheet that I'm going
to put a link to down in the description
below
and I don't want to spend too much time
on Emmett here in this course because
it's such a big topic I actually love
Emmett so much that I went ahead and
made a free Emmett course called faster
with Emmett and you can find that at
faster with emmett.com
completely free teaches you all the
fancy things about Emmett and you can
see how to use Emmett with HTML react
View and even CSS
so if we go back into vs code we open up
a new file it won't really work in a
markdown file we can say div
hello doesn't really work right we would
have to say click this right here and
let's go into an HTML file
and I can delete that now and I can say
div
dot HTML and see this abbreviation is
already started if I click this drop
down it'll show the abbreviation right
there
and that will actually be like an H2
header
and the text is going to be whoa
and then plus a P tag and we'll call
that
content
and inside of that I'll say imv content
so a little bit different of a UI than
codepen had but we get the preview here
just the same we are able to press Tab
and see all of our code get written out
thanks to Emmett inside of vs code
definitely keep in mind Emmett and
Snippets but really all all of these
features are going to hook into the vs
code's intellisense features all of that
was intellisense
and notice how intellisense is able to
hint at all of these things for us so
intellisense is just showing its value
over and over again in this course
this essential feature is a small one
and you might not need it so maybe I
shouldn't have called it an essential
feature but I use it often so I think
it's worth knowing that vs code actually
has a command line interface it has a
CLI
so this is actually really useful when
you're moving around a couple different
projects and you use your terminal a lot
and I'm not talking about the terminal
that's built into vs code just yet but
we will talk about that later in the
workflows videos
the one built into vs code lives right
here with control tilde and it's in the
panels down here I can close that but if
you're working in something like item or
terminal or Powershell whatever you have
there is a way to add some vs code
functionality to your terminal
so let's say I have a couple different
projects here I have the spacebar app I
have the better Dev site I have the
getting started with JavaScript folder I
have all of these different folders in
here how do I go ahead and open them up
in vs code
well as we've seen there are a couple
different ways we could go down here
open vs code do command o and open
different folders
another cool way is we can skip a step
or we go open vs code and then open a
folder in there we can go in here and
say code spacebar
so this code CLI tool right here this
command
will let us open whatever folder we
wanted to open which in this case is
spacebar I'll click enter
and now vs code opens up with that
folder
and everything in the Explorer right
there and you can see the install it
recommended extensions that we've seen
before but all of that stuff is there
so how do we get this cool tool for the
code and then we can open up whatever
project we have if we go into vs code
command shift p this is how we install
the code CLI tools
we're going to type install code command
in path
and what this does is it actually
installs the CLI tools
code successfully installed in path and
definitely look through the docs I'm
going to add a link to the docs down
below just to make sure that you get
your installation correct
and if you go back to your terminal here
and you may have to close and reopen if
you added a new tool to your path I
already have it installed so I'll go
here and say code dash dash help
and I'm a little zoomed in for this
video but you can see the different
options that we have but now you can use
the word code
to open up whatever folder you wanted
the better Dev website and I'll press
tab to auto complete that press enter
and that opens it up in vs code
so not an essential tool but very
helpful especially if you work in the
command line a lot
definitely give it an install by going
into your command palette and doing
install command to path
we are going to start the HTML and CSS
workflow with a couple features and a
couple settings
let's talk about the built-in features
of vs code
there are the emit feature that we're
going to talk about which we have talked
about I just think it's so important
when working with HTML in vs code that I
want to talk on some of my favorite
features here
we're going to talk about code folding
which is very helpful when you have
really large files and when you need
organization help
we're going to talk about the built-in
Color Picker which is a nice convenience
and we'll talk about CSS class
definition hovers
those are the four features that are
built into vs code that I really like to
point out
and the settings that I like to change
out for vs code HTML and CSS are Auto
closing tags these are an interesting
thing that some people have specific
preferences for so I want to point them
out
linked editing
wrap attributes as well
those are the things we're going to do
in this video as far as features and
settings goes and the next video we will
handle extensions
let's get right into it
we have vs code right here I'm going to
open up a brand new file with command n
and as we said it before our default
language is markdown but I want to work
with some HTML so down here in the
status bar I can click that and type in
HTML
or I can do command shift p language
mode and I'll change language mode to
HTML
and now that we're in HTML Emmett can
take over and say okay now it is my turn
to give you Auto completion for whatever
you want to type in here
for Emmett to start a brand new document
you can do HTML colon 5 which is the
emit abbreviation you see here that
gives you a whole doctype HTML head body
and then we start typing here
if I press tab here it'll go ahead and
auto complete all that stuff or a really
fun one if you're starting a new HTML
file with Emmett is just press
exclamation mark and that's the same
exact thing gives you the brand new HTML
file
I'll go down here and let's do a div
inside of that let's do an H2 plus a P
tag
and I'll press tab there
and we'll say title goes here
actually we can be smarter about this
let's actually write something out via's
code is awesome
and then down here in the P tag this is
really cool stuff to make us productive
one of the first features I like to
point out about Emmett is that if you
have a large HTML file if I click into
one of these divs
maybe the opening div or the closing div
you can do command shift p to open up
the command palette you can say matching
pair
and it'll actually go to the ending div
right there and this works for the H2 as
well let's go to this end of H2 I'll do
the same thing go to matching pair
and it goes to the start of it so if you
are having trouble finding where all of
your opening and closing tags are use
that matching pair
another really good one is let's say I
wanted to wrap all this in a header tag
so if I did this I would have to go
header right here go down a couple times
and add in a header right there
but vs code and Emmett give us a
stronger way to do this if I highlight
all of this right here you can do
command shift p wrap with abbreviation
I can type in header I can even add a
class called site Dash header
and I'll press enter and that will add
it and wrap everything I just
highlighted with that
what's even cooler about this is I had
to manually highlight right there if I
didn't want to do that there is a
feature called balance outward with
Emmett where I could do command shift p
if I'm inside of this we can say outward
and that will emit balance outward and
it will highlight everything and if I
did it again command shift p and notice
recently used is at the very top I can
press enter again it just keeps
highlighting up and up the chain
this is cool if I start even in this P
tag I try balance outward it'll do that
one more time it'll get the P tags one
more time it'll get everything inside
the divs
divs header header
and then we can even do the wrap with
abbreviation there and maybe wrap this
in a main tag or another div and give it
like a container class
there we go
so those are really fun and useful emit
features right there
next up let's talk about code folding
code folding is built right into vs code
really helpful when you have large HTML
files over here on the left you can see
these arrows if you click them it will
fold that specific div if you click that
it'll fold that
so a really fun visual feature to help
you organize and maybe work on certain
sections of your code
another way to activate this is if I'm
on this div I can do option command
and the opening bracket
to collapse it and the closing bracket
to open it back up and if I keep doing
this it'll just keep going up the chain
and if I go down here and expand that
out
I could do that with the arrows as well
so a feature to keep in mind with vs
code is code folding
next up really fun feature of vs code
really helpful for when you're working
with CSS is if I had a style here and
let's give it a background color and
notice intellisense is working thanks to
vs code here I'll do background color
we get even more intellisense and color
choices right here but I'm going to go
with hashtag cuckoo it's my default go
to uh random hex color
so we get a Color Picker here we can see
the color and if you hover it you can
actually go through and pick a new color
and it'll insert the hex value
right there
so that works in inline Styles if you go
up to the head of your document create a
style right here and I'll use emit to
create the style tag I can do container
background
color
and let's do that right there
it also works within style tags it also
works within CSS files you can hover and
get your nice Color Picker
the next feature I want to talk about is
the CSS class definition hovers if I
hover over this right here it shows you
the specificity it says element is class
is container right there
this is helpful if you have a couple
nested CSS classes maybe you're using
SAS or less if I had this Main and
container and now I hover this the rule
is actually saying oh you're going to
have a main element here and then down
below inside of that nested under main
you're going to have this class of
container
so this works
for many
classes and I know you probably wouldn't
want to have this spinning nested
classes
but it does it anyway and it shows you
what that hierarchy looks like
a little helpful feature when you're
working with CSS
next up let's talk about the three
settings that we had that we lined up
earlier
we are going to talk about Auto closing
tags
let's say over here if I go ahead and
type in the div here and I close that
div
vs code will say okay you wanted the
closing div right there I'll close it
for you
this isn't my personal preferred
Behavior I know a lot of people like
this I personally don't I personally
prefer to
type in the closing bracket and then it
auto completes it if I do the Open
Bracket and then forward slash then it
auto closes it that kind of signifies to
me that I am asking for the closing tag
so if you don't like Auto closing tags
that are built into vs code go into
settings Auto closing tags right there
and you can disable it for HTML and
JavaScript and typescript
again personal preference I don't really
like it I
I personally prefer when it does the
autocomplete intellisense kind of helper
right there and it says hey is this what
you wanted and then you can go in here
and press enter and it'll do it for you
the next setting to talk about is auto
updating tags
if I go up here to this header tag and I
said oh I actually just want that to be
a normal div I would have to go find the
closing tag that corresponds to it and
say div
vs code has a setting where both of
these can link so if you change one the
other changes
I'll go into settings and say linked
editing
we'll turn that on
and now if I go into my HTML file notice
how it's highlighted I can do command D
to select it and say header
and it updates both this and the closing
tag
the final setting we are going to talk
about is wrapping attributes
so if I go here and I say command shift
p and I format this document
you'll notice that a lot of it gets
formatted but I want to talk about
elements where they have a lot of
properties on them so if I go here I
create an a tag
let's have href let's have a class is
going to be a couple different things
High I am looking forward to
learning more vs code and I'm just
trying to get a super long class here
let's go ahead here and add a title as
well
here we go title is my link and then
down here go
and
learn more
so I'll go ahead and format this format
document
and notice how it keeps everything on
one line
I personally prefer my formatting to
break these properties onto multiple
different lines we can go into settings
and say wrap attributes
HTML format wrap attributes is set to
auto you can go ahead and change that to
force
so I go over here and I'll do format
again command shift p format
and notice how it brought href class and
title down to their own lines
all right that's a little bit better but
we can do maybe better than this on our
formatting
we'll be talking a lot more on auto
formatting Auto saving and how we can
get formatting to be a really big part
of our productive workflow in the auto
format workflow videos
all right that's going to wrap it up for
HTML CSS features and settings next up
is extensions
we have talked about workflow and
features and settings let's start
talking about extensions for HTML and
CSS
the extensions we are going to talk
about in this video are color highlight
CSS Peak HTML and tag labels
code spell check and HTML CSS support so
these are the ones I think are pretty
close to essential for HTML and CSS
development they all make HTML and CSS
development pretty quick
the first one here is we get this nice
little icon for the color right there
and we get this Color Picker we can
extend this a little bit further I'm
going to open up extensions with command
shift X
let's search for color highlight
and what this does is it highlights web
colors in your editor so I can install
this
and enable it right there
let's go back to our HTML file and now
we get even more of a color show on this
file if I scroll down you should see
that cuckoo one is down there as well
well not cuckoo anymore
there we go
so color highlight is a nice one to have
let's make this section A little bit
more robust let's say we have an
external style sheet because usually we
will have an external style sheet when
we're working with CSS right we're not
going to do inline Styles or have a
style tag in our file
so let's take this call out I'm going to
cut that out right here and I'm going to
delete that and I'm going to put all of
this into a brand new file I'm going to
go into command shift p new file
I'm going to do it from the workspace
root which is just the forward slash
there and we're going to say style.css
and we'll paste that in there
save that with command s
now notice this created a brand new file
if I wanted to check I could do command
shift e to open up the Explorer
and I'll do command B to close the
sidebar again
if we go back to index.html let's make
sure that we link this so I'm going to
press link which is an abbreviation and
we'll do colon CSS
and you can see what Emmett is going to
give us Rel style sheet hrefstyle.css
perfect
I'll press enter
and that is exactly what we needed
vs code even knows how to link it so if
you did option click you could follow
this to open up that file
I'll go back into our HTML file
if we scroll down here there's something
that's bothering me though if I right
click this and say go to definition it
says no definition found for this call
out function class and you might be
thinking well vs code should be smart
enough to know that right
what we can do is add an extension to
add in this feature and this one we're
going to add is called CSS Peak to open
up our extensions I'll do CSS Peak
you can install this and what it does is
it allows peaking and go to definition
for IDs and class strings
so if I go back here it should know if I
right click this and say go to
definition it'll open up the style.css
file it knows where it's defined and it
can take us there
if we go back to the HTML file if I
hover over it and say right click Peak
Peak definition
it now shows right underneath this
callout so we haven't left the HTML file
it shows hey this is the definition of
this call out and I can actually change
this to 20 and press save in there and
it saves over here
so if I close that go back to style.css
check it out 20 pixels is right there
so CSS Peak is really helpful at knowing
the classes that are in your project
the next extension is going to be a HTML
extension so if I go to my index.html if
I had a large HTML file there can be a
lot of divs inside of a large HTML file
so let's say div times 10 and I'll press
tab to auto complete that let's say we
have a bunch of divs and we weren't
really sure where everything ended there
could be a lot of content in all of
these there's a really handy extension
that we can use that actually tells us
which div ends where so if I did command
shift X to open up our extensions panel
right there I'll say HTML and tag labels
now if we install this right here
and we go back to our HTML file
nothing really shows just yet because
everything is pretty easy to read so
once we actually click here let's say we
enter into this call out I'll command
click to get multi-cursor and I'll press
enter a bunch of times once we get off
screen and you can know that the parent
to this isn't anywhere close to it that
extension actually says hey this ends
the call out class div right here
really helpful when you get really large
files for HTML you just want to know
what each div ends
the next one we'll talk about is one
that can help us solve things like this
if you have HTML you usually have a lot
of content inside of your HTML
let's say it's copy it's giant
paragraphs it's marketing text if I open
up our extensions panel with command
shift X
let's search for code spell checker
code spell checker this one that has 2.7
million let's install it
it will go ahead and highlight any text
that it deems not spelled correctly so
that is one of them that is not a common
word and let's say I spelled common
wrong then it would highlight there so
very helpful when you're typing a lot of
text and just an easy one to help you
find your typos the final extension is
the big HTML and CSS one if I go into
our extensions panel in the sidebar I
will search for HTML CSS support
and this is the big HTML CSS extension
to use install right here and what this
does is it actually gives us nice
intellisense features to know about IDs
classes embedded style sheets and even
external style sheets so what that means
is if I go into our HTML right here
scroll up let's delete this if I
activated intellisense with control
spacebar it says hey you have a class
called call out maybe you want to use
that
so if I go over here click that
that was an easy way to know the classes
that were in my project you can imagine
this can be very helpful when you have a
giant list of classes
the other really cool thing about this
extension is that it can handle external
style sheets
so if I right click this and I say close
to the right I'll just close all of
those windows tabs we don't need them
Save Right There
let's go ahead and go into our settings
command comma
if I did CSS style sheets
right here it has to be done in
settings.json and I'll show you why in a
second if you click here it builds out
an array for us
CSS style sheets I'm going to paste in
the CDN version of Tailwind
so there is a style sheet right there
and now if we go back over here that
extension will go and look at that file
and say okay I know all of the classes
inside of Tailwind now so I can press
spacebar here and I can do control
spacebar to activate intellisense I
could do background red 500 and notice
how it gave me autocomplete for all of
the things inside of the Tailwind CSS
style sheet
you can do this for any CSS framework if
you have a bootstrap project if you have
a Bulma project Foundation all that good
stuff you just say in your settings
these are the style sheets I want to
look at and you can do multiple with
comma and all of those
so multiple like that because it's an
array in there
but HTML CSS will go ahead find them all
and look through and give you this nice
intellisense autocomplete here
all right that's going to wrap it up for
the HTML CSS workflow there's a lot to
unpack in this video I hope that was
helpful and we're going to be doing the
same setup for all the other workflows
in this video we will be talking about
the node and npm workflow and this is a
really important workflow because it
spans any JavaScript that you're going
to do inside of vs code if it has a
package.json you're going to be using
npm and therefore this is going to span
JavaScript react node nextjs all of that
stuff is this video
so let's talk about the extensions we
were going to use in this video we're
going to use npm which is an amazing
extension all on its own we're going to
use the git ignore extension
npm intellisense extension
version lens
and import cost
all of these I think are fantastic
extensions to use when you're working
with node and npm so let's get started
here we go let's go into extensions and
the first one we'll go into is npm
and this is the 3.9 mil one that we want
we'll install
and let me show you what this does for
us normally if you have a brand new file
project right here I would go into my
terminal control utility and say npm
init and say yes and that would create a
brand new package.json and I can start
working with a node project
but here
I think a really great workflow to have
here is to try to use the command
palette as much as possible if we can
move things into the command palette all
the better we save more time because we
don't have to open up the terminal type
into there we can just do command shift
p
npm and you can see all of the tools
that are part of this package right here
and we can run init
so it actually opens up the terminal
still but we got to initialize it from
the command palette so we'll say yeah
yep enter entry point is index.js enter
and we'll just keep pressing enter all
the way across is this okay yes and then
I can close the terminal Ctrl tilde
and we have our package.json
so that one wasn't the best example of
it because we still had to go into our
terminal to do stuff
what I can do next though is Let's do an
install
what I can do next is let's say we
wanted to install a package here I would
open up my terminal command K to clear
that out and I could say npm install
let's say Express
so now we have node modules and a
package lock.json what you can do here
is just delete this right here
move to trash delete this one as well
move to trash is we can do command shift
p
npm
install and now we can install
dependencies from there I use this a lot
when I open up a brand new project I get
clone a project from GitHub first thing
I'll do is npm install
next up let's say we had a package
script let's say there's a test script
right here let's have start and we'll
just say node server.js
and let's create a server.js right here
we don't really do anything here but
once we save that we can command shift p
npm run
and you can run init audit build script
is what we want
so let's run script and we can run these
scripts so it automatically pulls the
scripts out of our package.json and you
can see it will run the start right here
and it goes ahead and runs nodeserver.js
so a lot of the time I will get clone
with Git clone right here and then I'll
go ahead and npm install dependencies
and then I'll go ahead and npm run a
script
and just like that I have my entire
project running with three command
palette commands
the second extension we have is git
ignore command shift X to open up our
extensions I'll say git ignore right
here
we'll install this for 1 million
installs
one million and one now
and from here
if we open up our Explorer node modules
is going to be committed to our GitHub
repo we definitely do not want that
since it's a giant folder
we want to add a git ignore so normally
you would do got dot get ignore file but
here I can do git ignore
and just add a git ignore
and then it will pull from GitHub the
defaults and we can type in node right
here and that will go ahead and create a
DOT get ignore based on node projects
and it will go ahead and node modules
will be somewhere down here there we go
thanks to that we can add a gig ignore
with the git ignore package
the third extension we'll talk about is
npm intellisense
now this is a small one but it gives you
some good functionality especially when
you're doing requires
you can do require and it will auto
complete the packages that are in your
project so I'll go back to my server.js
command P to open up files server.js
while I could type out the entire
require statement right here a cool
thing you can do with the npm
intellisense package is command shift p
type in intellisense and we can import a
module right from here
and it pulls the ones in from our
package.json we'll say Express is the
one we want
and we can say Express right here it
gives you the destructured version so
you can pull out like anything you want
to destructure but we'll leave that
there
the next thing we can do is extension
number four is version lens
with version lens
it's not the most popular package that
is a lot of installs but not the most
popular we can go into our package.json
and we have our dependencies here so
let's say there's Express let me add a
couple more let me just add random ones
npm install react react Dom let's type
in next
let's go for low Dash
and now that we have these packages
installed right here
version lens is a package that gives us
a nice little V button on the top right
of our package.json we can click that
and it starts initializing and it goes
and grabs the latest version of each of
our packages
so if I change the react over to let's
say 16.9.0
it'll say okay that's fine 16.14 is what
comes in but latest is 1702 so I can
actually click this and it updates those
so you can quickly look at your entire
package.json and see what's outdated and
click a couple buttons and update
everything
again you would have to npm install
after you updated the numbers but then
you'd be good to go
and when you're done using it just press
the V again so you turn that off and
you're back to a normal package.json
the last extension of this video is
going to be import cost
and I'll go ahead and install that and
we'll go ahead and enable it now the
cool thing about import cost if I open
up a brand new file let's go into create
a new file we'll just call it app.js
I can import react from react
it will automatically calculate the size
of this dependency
so when you start using third-party
packages you can see the size of what
you're going to ship to your user
gzipped this is only three kilobytes
import react Dom from react Dom
but should be a little bit larger if it
calculates that there we go 39.4
kilobytes gzipped
import cost is a really good extension
just to have that knowledge of what
you're shipping to your users smaller
bundle sizes equals faster apps
all right those are some great node and
npm extensions moving forward we're
going to do a lot more JavaScript and
we'll see more JavaScript extensions and
workflows let's keep moving forward
this video is all about the JavaScript
workflow now I think this might be the
biggest video in the course along with
the accompanying video right after this
JavaScript extensions
JavaScript is such a big part of vs code
that a lot of the features are built
around a lot of JavaScript things so
this is going to be a really fun one
let's talk about the built-in features
of vs code that are going to be in this
video
we'll do a little bit more intellisense
intellisense is just so important we
can't ignore it jsdoc very important
also helps us out with intellisense
Auto Imports
a byproduct of intellisense code
navigation and renaming also
intellisense
code actions on Save and update Imports
on move
all of these features once you start
working them into your workflows will
make you a more productive JavaScript
developer
all right here I have a new folder with
just a blank app.js let's start seeing
how some things work out
we've already seen how intellisense
Works a little bit if we did cons to
button is equal to document Dot
I can start typing in something like
query selector and you'll notice that if
I close that out we have query selector
and we have options for what we can do
as far as parameters that are passed
into query selector all or query
selector all that good stuff right there
so intellisense is always present always
helping us out and there are a lot of
extensions that hook into intellisense
that you've seen so far
something I want to do is show off a
little bit more of how our code uses
intellisense
let's write out a function called add
and we'll say a b here it will return a
plus b
foreign
what we can do here is go down and use
add
and if we expand this right here it says
function add a is any B is any and it
returns any so you might not be using a
lot of these type features but they are
very helpful and I'll show you how to
use them
by adding in a JS Dock which is a
comment above a JavaScript function that
shows a little bit about what that
function does you type in forward slash
star star and we get the snippet right
here of adding in a JS doc comment
you can press enter or tab to
autocomplete
and now it read our function said hey
there's two params in here and it's
going to return something
so let's fill this out the first one is
going to be a number
I'll press Tab and we'll say the first
number to add
I'll press tab again and this will also
be a number
Within These brackets we're going to add
the type of what the parameter is it
could be string number Boolean here it's
number the second number to add
we are going to return a number
and I'm going to type in add
two numbers together as the title
so with this JS doc comment vs code can
read all through this read the function
itself and give us even more
intellisense when I say add
and check that out all of the stuff that
we just wrote out is now in the
intellisense so it's add two numbers
together first number to add second
number returns a number
and all of that is right there really
nice so we say let's do like hi
like that
and it won't really show an error yet
we're going to install an extension in
the next video that will help out and
show errors here so that we can be even
more productive
moving forward a lot of the things we're
going to do is catch errors early which
is really nice so that we don't have to
go to our browser find the error come
back try to debug it's all helped out
right inside of vs code
let's make our example a little bit more
robust let's add a new file we'll call
this add.js that'll be our helper
function and I'll move this whole thing
from here
into here and I'll say export default
let's go ahead and add a new one let's
say this is called people.js and I'll
say cons people and I'll just make it an
array of one person
export default people
the cool thing about this now is we have
a feature called Auto Import so if I
wanted to come in here and say add
the cool thing about intellisense is
that it knows all of the files that we
have in our workspace it knows all these
symbols or functions variables
everything inside of those files so I
can go in here and say add
and you'll notice it brought in all the
intellisense and it says Auto Import
from dot add so that's the file right
next to us I'll click enter right there
and it brought in the Auto Import really
nice
so I'll say one two right there
we can even bring in people
and it knows to bring in the const
people is the array of objects
it can Auto Import that as well I'll
click that and it auto imported
thanks to intellisense knowing the
symbols around our files we can do a
couple things like command T which is
going to search symbols across all files
and I can say add
and that'll open up the ad.js file right
there or people
I've been using command T to open
symbols a lot more often recently
another thing is if you're already in a
file you could do command shift o which
will search for symbols in this file
only so command T is symbols across your
workspace command shift o is symbols in
your current file
so if I come back to app.js command
shift o no symbols in there because
we're just using a function we haven't
declared any variables or functions
one other thing that we can do is right
click Source action and we can say
organize Imports
and if you have a lot of imports it will
organize them and it will remove any
unused Imports
more on that we could go into our
settings code actions on Save
we can force vs code to organize our
Imports on save so we don't have to
manually do that this goes hand in hand
with that auto format video that we just
did edit settings this is going to be an
object and I definitely recommend using
the docs because it's hard to tell what
to write here
but I did control spacebar and
intellisense showed what we could write
organize Imports is what we want and we
want that to be true
so that will happen on Save and we never
have to look at it again it will remove
any unused Imports as well
the last cool thing about vs code's
JavaScript features that I want to point
out is updating Imports on move
so let's say right here I have dot add
and I have dot people the files that are
pulled from right here I can add a new
folder and we can say helpers
and let's drag add.js into the helpers
folder and it says hey are you sure you
want to move ad.js into helpers
yes move that over there
and then here's the fun part do we
update the Imports for ad.js yes or you
can always automatically update Imports
which is what I have set to because
whenever I move my files I would love my
imports to be updated as well
and notice how it changed that to slash
helper slash ad we'll do it with people
also
and we'll move that there the reason I
don't have don't ask me again is because
I just want to be sure if I'm moving
files sometimes I've accidentally moved
files and I didn't know that I did so
this is a good way for me to know hey
you're moving a file
and there we go update on the import
all of those are children of the
intellisense features having vs code
know all of the symbols all the
functions variables in our workspace
lets it do all of these really fun
features
definitely take a look into more of the
intellisense features I have a link down
to the JavaScript docs down below
and as you work you're going to get a
lot more nice prompts from vs code to
help you out with your JavaScript
let's start talking about JavaScript
extensions we've seen all of the
Fantastic built-in features of
JavaScript in vs code
but there are ways that we can extend vs
code's functionality through extensions
the first extension we'll talk about is
one that I think is important enough to
get its own video and that'll be eslint
now eslint is a tool that will help us
find and see problems or confusions with
our own code so it doesn't just catch
errors it catches things that could be
confusing when we write our code
to demonstrate this if I go over to vs
code and I create const message is equal
to hi there
and I try to reassign this variable I
shouldn't be able to because it's a
const and const means there is no
reassignment for this thing I say
message is equal to new message
vs code doesn't catch this error it
doesn't say hey this is a problem we're
actually only going to see this problem
when we go run our code in Chrome
a tool that we can use to catch problems
or confusions early is eslint
eslint is a linter that will go ahead
and find problems with our code and tell
us about them so I'll go ahead and
install that
but there are a couple extra things that
we need to do for setup here one we need
to have the eslint package installed
either in the workspace we're in or
globally
since we want a brand new package
installed the eslint package I'm going
to go ahead and open up my Explorer we
want a package.json and we want some
node modules
to do this I can do npm in knit
dash dash yes to create a brand new
package.json and then I am going to
install npm install for development
eslint
now I'm installing this locally for this
workspace you may want to install it
globally that's one other option for me
I personally prefer to have it in the
workspace so that when somebody else
downloads this project they can npm
install and eslint will be added because
it'll be right here underneath Dev
dependencies
if I installed it globally and it wasn't
in this list then other people wouldn't
really know that I was using eslint
all right so that's step one is getting
the eslint package step two is creating
an eslint RC configuration file
to do that we can use the package itself
command shift p and say eslint
and we can say create eslint
configuration
and now down here we get some nice
prompts we say hey do you want eslint to
check syntax check syntax and find
problems or check syntax find problems
and enforce code Style
for me enforcing code style is a job
before prettier I like how prettier does
that job so I'm going to tell eslint
just check syntax and find problems
we'll be using JavaScript modules here
for this project we won't have react or
view so I'll just say none of these
for this project we won't be using
typescript either eslint can lint and
check typescript code for errors
and our code is going to run in the
browser
we'll format this as a JavaScript file
it's all good for all three versions and
now we get a brand new eslin rc.js what
happens here is eslint brings in what's
called eslint recommended and it brings
in all of these rules of how our code
should be formatted and notice I already
installed eslint and I brought in eslint
RC and now there's an error over here
there's problems over here on app.js
there's two errors
so I can actually click over there and
it says a highlighted squiggly line
underneath the message if I hover it
says Hey message is a constant message
is assigned a value but never used so
that's problem number one so let's try
to use it console.log message
but there's still a problem here and
notice how the error went down from two
to one there's still another problem
hover that message is a constant I
shouldn't be able to reassign it so
let's change this to a let
and therefore there are no problems
anymore
so if I go back to this eslintrc.js I'm
not sure what that error is
maybe converted that's all good this is
what eslint did by default so we'll
leave it eslint recommended let me show
you the rules that this brings along for
enforcing code Styles if I go to the
eslint.org website find and fix problems
in your JavaScript code you can go to
user guide and down here under rules we
can click rules
check mark right here says if extends
eslint recommended is added then
everything with a check mark is the
rules that eslint will check for in our
project
so you can scroll through and find all
of these things there's a ton of other
rules and it's fun to go read through
these and see what is not recommended
JavaScript
we can scroll down no import assign all
this good stuff right here but now that
we have this eslint RC eslint we'll
check for all of these things and not
just for us it'll be for anyone else
that comes into this project and tries
to use this as well
another thing that eslint does for us is
if I said function say hello and I said
message or person
what it would do here is return
let's say hi person
and right here we have a defined but
never used that's a good error to show
off that hey you're defining code that
you're not even using but check this out
I can console.log right here
and say hi
it will actually also error out this
code and say unreachable code because
you already did a return and you're not
even going to get to this part of the
code so let's go ahead and see This
little light bulb right here we can
click that it says remove unreachable
code
and you can just remove it you can fix
those problems
once you get to a larger project there
is going to be a lot of errors in your
code potentially so one way we can look
at all of the problems is we can open up
command shift M which is the problems
tab underneath next to our terminal and
see all of the problems across our
project
you can even go through each one click
the light bulb and see if there's a fix
for them
so to show that off let me go back here
and return that unreachable code
console.log
hi unreachable code right here
I can click that and remove unreachable
code
eslan does a great job at showing fixes
for everything that we could do but I
want to show you something else which
may be a little extreme I don't do it
myself but it's good to know if you do
command comma go into your settings we
saw this setting in the last video just
do code actions on Save we can edit in
settings.json and see how there's this
already intellisense giving a source.fix
all
you can set that to true
so source.fix all is going to say
anytime you save I'm going to go ahead
and run these es lint fixes and just do
it for you
now I don't use it myself
I like seeing the eslint stuff and
fixing it so that I can see that the
problems I created but if you like the
idea of just having your problems go
away then go ahead and do that I click
save right there and that unreachable
code was just removed
eslint is a great tool all you had to do
is one install the package to install
the npm install eslint and step three
was create your eslint
RC and with those three steps you are
good to find the errors in your code
look at that there's already five here
because of this
let's start moving forward and looking
at other extensions we can use for
JavaScript
let's talk about some more JavaScript
extensions
we have a few more here we have
JavaScript es6 code Snippets which is
really helpful it has a lot of great
Snippets that we can use for our
JavaScript
path intellisense very helpful in
grabbing and importing different files
across our entire project
turbo console log which is a really
quick way to get console logs which I do
a lot actually JavaScript booster which
is some fun JavaScript helpers
and those are the ones that we're going
to talk about in this video
let's jump right into it
first off let's install JavaScript es6
code Snippets
es6 code Snippets
now you may see a lot of JavaScript
snippet packages definitely look through
them and see which one you like best but
this is a popular one for a reason if I
click into it
and I scroll down here you can see all
of the files that are
supported.js.ts jsx TSX
htmln.view
if we scroll down these are all the
Snippets that we can use so imp I use a
lot IMD I also use a lot there are some
really great ones for console logs for
eaches definitely look through and see
which ones you think you can add to your
workflow
I'll go ahead and install this
and we'll go into our app.js
to see everything that we can do you can
do command shift p
snip it
insert snippet here
and we can just scroll through and let's
say we need an import right here
you can imp Imports entire module
statement there's IMD which is import a
portion we'll do imp which is the full
import I can say react from react like
that
and to show off that again I'm going to
do imp
and you can press enter or tab to
autocomplete and the first thing you get
is the right side so the package name
that you import from that'll be react
you press Tab and you get the module
name and you can fill that out there and
then press Tab and you're back at the
end of the line here's IMD a really
popular one that I use as well and
that's import destructure you can see
the preview of it over on the left here
I'll press enter
and we can say react and we would get
use State from here and that would be
destructured like that
look through that package and see what
you find is best CLG is the last one
that I want to point out I use this one
a lot for console.log
the next extension we're going to
install is path intellisense
path intellisense
is a great tool 5.1 million installs if
we scroll down here we get some nice
autocomplete for
looking through our file system as soon
as we go and create a path
install here
enable
if I go to my app.js we have helpers add
and people let's say I wanted to do an
import so I would do IM p
and as soon as I do dot forward it
notices that I want a path and it says
Hey here are all the folders in your
path so I can print helpers
and then I pick slash and then it goes
ahead and says hey here are all the
other files that you want and I'll just
click add we don't need that dot JS here
and we'll do add from there
so another helpful path intellisense
extension
next up is Turbo console log
and go for the one that has the most
285k right there I'll install
you can activate turbo console log by
doing control alt and L and what that
does is a really quick console log
before I showed you you could do CLG and
that would create a console log and then
you would have to type in what you
wanted a console.log here you highlight
the word and then you do Ctrl alt L on
Mac it'll be Ctrl option l
and it gets you a console log but it
doesn't just do a console log it
actually gives you a nice Emoji it tells
you what file you're in it tells you
line and it gives you context into what
your console.logging so this is really
helpful if you have a few all across
your project you can actually see what
you're logging pretty nicely
the last extension here is Javascript
booster
190k I'll install that
JavaScript booster is a great way to
refactor a lot of our code vs code has
refactoring built in but I found
JavaScript booster to be very helpful
for these really tiny tasks like you see
here it was able to change to an arrow
function forward ref just random things
so let's see if I had a function hello
and I said return hello like that
you could click on this and now you get
this little light bulb in the top left
you click that and you say convert to
Arrow function so JavaScript booster
will put nice helpers in this light bulb
drop down convert to Arrow function and
there we go
unless I said VAR message
is equal to this is cool
I'm on this line I get this nice light
bulb convert to const and that one works
just nicely
let's say I had const well I already
have message so let's go ahead and use
message here I can click here and you
can see convert to let split into
declaration and initialization I don't
want either of those click into the
string and now the light bulb actually
changes and says hey do you want a
template string here and I can say yes
and that changes that to a template
string
I recommend looking through JavaScript
boosters docs there's a lot that it can
do for us for instance here's an if
statement if true then let's say return
hi
else return Buy
I can click This little light bulb see
what it does and I can replace this
entire thing with a ternary
and return true question mark high or
buy
really helpful small thing but it does
help with productivity because it cuts
out a little bit of manual editing
all right those are the JavaScript
extensions I wanted to point out there
aren't many because there are so many
great JavaScript features already built
into vs code so these are the ones that
I think are really helpful the rest are
really good but JavaScript by itself in
vs code is already really fantastic
moving forward from JavaScript let's
talk about using react in vs code now a
lot of the JavaScript stuff we've talked
about as far as workflows extensions
settings a lot of that is going to apply
to the react workflow but in addition to
that we have two extensions one is going
to be simple react Snippets which adds
even more Snippets that are really react
specific
and again we're going to talk about
JavaScript booster because it adds such
functionality to react and we also have
a couple workflow things to talk through
to start us off I am going to start with
a brand new react project so what I'm
going to do is open up my terminal with
controlled npx create react app
I'm going to say sample react app
we'll let that run create a brand new
create react App application
we have our new react app I'm going to
open this up in the same vs code window
with code sample react app
and I'm going to say Dash R to reuse the
current vs code window
that went ahead opened it back up in vs
code I'll go into my source folder we
have app.js and this is going to be the
start to our entire react application
I'm going to click right here and I'm
going to say balance outward
and that's an emit shorthand to expand
and select everything and I'm going to
say balance outward again to select even
more and let's remove all that hi
so the first thing that happened here is
when I typed in the div it automatically
closed the div
now we talked about this in one of the
previous videos I'm personally not a fan
of this I like closing my syntaxes
myself
so to turn this off we're going to go
into settings
and we'll say Auto closing
tags
we can turn this off for HTML JavaScript
and typescript so I'll turn that off
there and I'll turn them off all the way
across actually
and now when we type in div
we can close it ourselves and notice
intellisense still says hey you probably
want to close that div that you just
opened and I can press enter or tab to
finish that
the other cool thing about this is let's
say I had a component we'll say new file
right here I'll say components slash
hello world dot Js
I'll do export default function hello
world
return
div hi world
if I go into my app.js the cool thing
about vs code is that it already has all
that intellisense it knows all about our
files that are in our project if I start
typing in hello world
notice it'll say Auto Import from this
components slash hello world I can press
enter and it will automatically go ahead
and import that for me
let's talk a little bit about props and
types and intellisense here in a react
app
let's delete all this and now I have our
hello world right here
let's go ahead and give ourselves a prop
of message
and this is going to be a string let's
say we wanted this to be a string and
right here I'm just going to write in
message so we actually use it
over in app.js if I go here and say
message it says message can be any
so that doesn't really help me if I'm
using a component where I don't know
what the props are message could be any
or I don't know if it's a string a
Boolean a number
there's a way we can add some
intellisense to this
we can go ahead and install a package
called prop types
so I'll go into my terminal npm I prop
Dash types
and this prop types package is going to
give us a way to add the types to our
props exactly what it sounds like so if
I go here and I go to and say Hello
World dot prop types
is equal to
message is going to be prop types
dot string
and we need to import this prop types
project right here I'm going to say
import prop types from prop types
and this is the recommended package from
the react docs to add in typings to your
react projects if you are using
JavaScript if you're using typescript
you can just go ahead and say message is
string right here which is one way to do
it but we aren't using typescript right
now so we have to do this ourselves with
the prop types package
and then here you can't export default
right there you have to export default
down below export default hello world
now with a setup like this for our react
components we should be able to go into
app.js and say message
and check that out it is a string
and also there's a question mark because
it's not required the prop types package
is a great way to add extra intellisense
to our react components
something else I want to talk about when
using react is Emmett is a really big
tool when I'm working with my templating
languages
so let me delete this whole thing right
here I don't need that anymore let's say
I wanted a div Dot
hello.world and that's going to be two
classes or I could say is blue
notice that M doesn't work here normally
in an HTML file I would get my auto
intellisense and then I could tab over
and build out my template Emmett here
doesn't understand this Javascript file
as a templating language it usually
works in HTML
to get Emma to work in a Javascript file
we have to say hey Emmett please go work
in JavaScript and react I can go into my
settings and say include languages
and notice this is already recommended
it says Hey JavaScript JavaScript react
is the thing we want to do and if you're
in a view file view HTML set to HTML
so I'm going to go here and say
JavaScript
JavaScript react
and I'll click ok
now we can go into our app.js let's try
the scan div dot is blue
we get our emit abbreviation here I can
click here press enter or I can press
Tab and we get our syntax Auto completed
thanks to Emmett
foreign
let's talk about the two extensions we
had we had simple react Snippets
this one for one million installs I
actually prefer simpler react Snippets
to this es7 react Redux graphql react
native Snippets one I know it's more
popular but click through each one
scroll down and read through the
Snippets that are added
and see which ones you like see all of
these I think these the reason I don't
like them is they overlap a lot with the
JavaScript es6 code Snippets package
which I also have installed
but it looks like a lot of the overlap
happens so maybe you just want to
install this not the JavaScript es61
I think the JavaScript es61 plus the
simple react Snippets one go hand in
hand really well
and these are more react specific so IMR
right here is import react imrc import
reactant component down here there are
use effect and set State type stuff
let's scroll down even further class
components
let's see use effect Hook is right there
so all of these really helpful to have
I'm going to head install
back to our hello world and let's say I
wanted to use effect
uef
use effect I can press enter and there
we go I could go up here and when in
doubt with what the snippet shorthand is
remember you can always do command shift
p
insert snippet
and I can type in state and this is the
one we want USF declare a new state
variable using the state hook
I can click here
and we can say set let's say count
and as soon as I press tab the cool
thing about this extension is it will
auto capitalize that c right there press
tab there we go set count and count and
then I can set a default right there
press Tab and we are off to the races
really helpful there another cool thing
to do is with our Auto Import we can
Auto Import this use state
right now this would break because we
had to go in here and import use state
from react
we can skip that by going here and the
way that we can get vs code to auto
complete something is we just delete
this last character press e and it says
oh hey you want use State let me Auto
Import that from react for you so I can
click that and we get that line
anytime you need to do an Auto Import
you can do two things one you can delete
the last character press it and see if
vs code gives you that answer or you can
go to it and do control spacebar to
activate intellisense and you get that
Auto Import from react you can click
that right there
next up I want to talk about JavaScript
booster
this is an extension that we talked
about in the previous videos JavaScript
booster
but I think there are some really cool
features when you talk about react and
JavaScript booster we just talked about
it as far as JavaScript but here we'll
talk about it with react
there's some cool stuff you can do here
but if you scroll down
to code actions down here under
functions
here we go jsx TSX and react
there are some really nice helpers here
especially these three that I use a lot
wrap value with the brackets for jsx
remove the jsx brackets
collapse expand and empty tag
wrap function into use callback I don't
use it as much but it is helpful
and especially these up here for
converting
strings to template strings
so I wanted to show off a little bit of
this workflow let's go to app.js
let's say I had a function called alert
and in here you would have the message
that you would pass through we will
return a div with the message
now let's say I had a class name here
class name is equal to and then I could
just style it as I want is alert or
something like that
let's say I wanted to pass in a color
through this so I said color is right
here well over here I would have to pass
this color in through the class name so
I would have to do some fancy stuff I
would click down here and I would go
over here change this out like that
change this to a template string and
then I would finally pass in the color
as an es6 template variable
JavaScript booster lets us do a little
bit quicker on that task it gives us
this nice little light bulb which is vs
code's refactoring
I can click this wrap value with the
brackets all right let's go ahead and do
that and that wraps it still keeps it as
a string
I can click it again and it says replace
with template string there we go
and just like that we're able to change
out a couple things just by pressing the
light bulb there for a couple times
some other fun things that I can do is
let's say we had a function handle
change and that'll be an e
if you are clicking into this function
you can see the light bulb pop up we can
click this removed unused declaration
which is vs code trying to fix this
because we have eslint installed we have
convert to Arrow function which is a
nice helper one that comes from
JavaScript booster is we can wrap into
use callback hook
so I don't use that too often but when I
do need it it is a pain to have to write
that and then you can click here control
spacebar to get your Auto Import for the
use callback import click that and check
it out all the way at the top
so JavaScript booster is a nice way to
get a little bit more productivity out
of vs code
there's a lot of small things like that
that add up like that Auto Import we
just did like everything else we've seen
in this course you could even click over
here click this and if you ever need to
you can wrap component in react.memo
and then we don't want this right here
right we want to import react.memo from
react there we go
and now we have Memo from react
so JavaScript booster a small thing to
add on but overall all of the JavaScript
stuff we've talked about in the previous
videos plus a few more react Snippets
and extensions are really helpful for
building out a great react workflow
this video is all about view workflow
and the interesting thing about this is
that so much of it is already installed
in one extension so we'll talk about
that we have extensions we're going to
use the PowerHouse called Vitor and it's
such a Powerhouse in the view world that
if you use the view CLI to create a
brand new view project Vita is the
recommended extension
next up we'll do view vs code Snippets
which is by Sarah drazner some really
nice Snippets in there and we'll look at
the vs code extension pack which is also
by Sarah drasner it just has a bunch of
extensions that you should look at
all right so here we are we will create
a brand new view project we'll say view
create
sample view app
I'll press enter we need to make sure we
have a preset we'll go ahead and go with
view three
foreign let that run
and while that's running I want to take
a detour and go and look at the vs code
extension pack
the vs code extension pack is an
extension pack that has one two a bunch
of vs code extensions and the ones to
look out for especially for view
specific ones is veter view Snippets the
rest aren't really view specific and
we've talked about them in some of our
other videos there's prettier formatting
toggle is really nice bracket pair
colorizer
and the other ones but these two are the
view specific ones so let's take a look
Vita and view Snippets
I'll look at vtor itself
a lot of great functionality built into
viter and I hope I'm saying that right
we have syntax highlighting semantic
highlighting Snippets Emmett all of the
things that in react we had to install
maybe a couple different extensions here
in the view world there's just a single
extension to rule them all
Vita even has its own website if you go
to the repository here and you click on
the website here it has a full website
for what it can get you it has a quick
start it has a guide that can go through
all of the different features syntax
highlighting semantic highlighting
snippet
and this isn't really to add extra
Snippets this is to say that vs code
will look at what the language is if
you're using a single file view
component and it'll say oh if you're in
the template tag we probably want HTML
Snippets if you are in the script tag
you probably want typescript or
JavaScript Snippets
so it's just a way that vs code can
inject certain Snippets into a certain
area
there's formatting there's intellisense
all this great stuff just from one
single extension
and then if we go look at the view vs
code Snippets we scroll down we can see
all of the Snippets that are added here
really helpful stuff
especially when you talk about your
templating for V4 v-model all that good
stuff there
script tags are down here
all very helpful when you're working
with Vue
let's jump back into our app right here
let's make sure we open this up code
sample view app
and we'll say Dash R to use the window
and I'll go here source
app.view
notice that without veter there is no
syntax highlighting nothing is fancy
about this setup right here and if you
look down here a brand new View
application will say hey the recommended
extension do you want to install them we
can say show recommendations and it's
veter that's the single recommendation
here
we'll go ahead and install
come back over to our app.view
and already we have functionality here
for our application
Vita is looking for a tsconfig or JS
config that's all good we don't really
need that because Vitor works right out
of the box
notice that hello world is right here
and if I open up this hello world
component and if I option click it it
will open up this right here
props message is a string
so this by saying props is a message
string we can already get that
intellisense thanks to veter so if I go
over here and I type in hello world
vs code will show me the component
itself it'll give me the dash delimited
version of it but I actually like using
the
Capital case what do you call that
Pascal case
and you see a message it'll say message
is a string
the interesting thing here is it tries
to bind it
hi there
but we don't run it bound we would just
add it as a string
so that's one thing to keep an eye out
for
a couple other things that Vitor gives
us is we can use our emit stuff inside
of here so we can say div
dot hello and I can tab that over I get
my Emin
we can go down here and we can say
methods
and I can do an object we can say do
something
and then in here I can do an if
statement
and we get the normal Snippets that we
would expect if we were in a JavaScript
file but since this is a single file
view component and we are in the script
section that if statement will work it
won't work however in the template
section
check that out if we're in the template
section it gives us a different set of
Snippets which is an iframe in this case
Vita is really cool because you just
have to install the single extension and
it gives you a ton out of the box next
up let's go look at view Snippets
syntax highlighting for view we don't
need this one because vitar already has
it view three Snippets and view vs code
Snippets I'm going to install this one
although we could look at that view
three one and see which one you like
better
and if we scroll down actually let's go
into our app.view let's go down here
we'll delete a couple things
let's go over here
and say V methods
and check that out we can automatically
get methods and the first method in
there I'll click that we can do a couple
other things let's type in insert
snippet
let's see View
and we have a bunch of stuff v-ref view
watch maybe we wanted a lifecycle method
like mounted
we can say V3 on mounted like that I
think that would be the different style
though if you were using view 3
but that's not the one we want so let's
say
snippet mounted
on before Mount V3 V before Mount
v-mounted this is the one we want so
this is the view 2 version there is the
V3 version if you were using the V3
functional way of doing things for this
we'll just use the mounted method right
on the export default object
so with viter and the view Snippets
package I think those two together are
already such a great starter for any
view workflow
definitely give both a try and just look
through the docs and see which parts are
going to work for your workflow
this video is all about a Tailwind
workflow and settings and extensions and
I am a really big fan of Tailwind I even
have a full-size course at
beginnertailwind.com
let's get started and see how great vs
code and Tailwind can work together
the extensions we'll talk about are
Tailwind CSS intellisense which is the
big one the absolute important one that
you need to have installed Tailwind docs
I also think this is really important to
have
and headwind we'll talk about if you
need this or if you maybe might like it
to start us off I have a brand new
next.js application nothing happened to
it except for npx create next app
so I'm gonna go out of order here and
we're going to talk about Tailwind Docs
the first extension will install this
one
and all this extension does is extend
the command palette so that while we're
here we can do command shift p
Tailwind docs and notice you can go to
any part of the docs from within vs code
and you can click things like let's say
we need the installation
I could press enter right here and it
would open up the Tailwind docs right
inside of my Chrome browser and I didn't
have to go searching for it Googling for
it it all just happened from the command
palette
I'll go ahead and click next.js and
let's just walk through installing
Tailwind into a next JS application
I'll go down here we'll copy this whole
line right here for the npm install
I'll open up my terminal control tilde
paste that in press enter
I'll come down here and PX Tailwind CSS
init Dash p which that Dash P gives you
our post css.config paste that in there
go down here we want this purge right
here so we'll copy that switch over
close our terminal with control
tildility command P to open up our
tailwind config.js
and let's go ahead and replace this
purge line right here
we'll save that switch back over I think
we're pretty close to done we have to
open up app.js and include the import
so we'll copy that switch over command p
app.js
delete that paste that in
switch back over include Tailwind in
your CSS we have that done already and
we're done
all right so let's open up index.js now
and this is our home page let's go over
here let's expand outward and delete
everything so we'll say emit balance
outward
and that highlights everything in there
I can do it again to highlight
everything there and we'll say div hi
there
we'll delete all of those lines
and here we go we have a brand new
next.js Tailwind app and we can start
using Tailwind from within here
this gets into extension number two if I
wanted to use some Tailwind classes
let's say class name is equal to let's
say Min height is screen
we can do Flex item Center justify
Center
and let's go for background and I'm kind
of forgetting what the colors are in
Tailwind wouldn't it be nice if vs
code's intellisense helped us out and
said hey these are all the colors you
can use these are the shades from 100
200 300 all the way up you can use
well the extension Tailwind CSS
Intel sense
can help us out with that
we can click install here
enable it
and the requirements for enabling this
is that in our Explorer command shift e
we have to have a tailwind.config.js
and I highly recommend scrolling down
here going through some recommended
settings down here recommended vs code
settings I have heard that there are
cases where you should look through the
settings just in case things don't work
for you
but hopefully they do on first try let's
go back here
and let's see if intellisense can help
us out now sometimes you may need to
reload your vs codes let's give it a
shot control spacebar to bring up
intellisense and here we are we have all
of the colors that we can use for
Tailwind inside of vs code
let's say I wanted the green
and check it out now it goes and narrows
down our search to the greens and I can
say four
and check this out I don't even need to
write out Dash 400 I did Green four and
you can press enter right there
the other cool thing is we get this nice
color icon right here and we can hover
over this and see what CSS properties
are going to take place here
let's say I wanted opacity we could say
maybe five
and drop that down to 75 press enter
and if I hover it we get opacity 0.75
this is really helpful the hover feature
especially when you get to text large or
text extra large
I'm not entirely sure what those
translate to sometimes so I hover over
it and it says that's around 20 pixels
and line height around 28 pixels and
same for text large 18 pixels and 28
pixels so that helps out really nicely
you don't have to go to the docs or
anything like that to see what the
numbers are
the intellisense extension is even good
at doing responsive and those prefixes
so if I did Excel
it tells you hey the medium query will
be for minimum width 1280 pixels and
then you can do colon and then you can
auto fill in whatever else you need
let's do text to excel the last
extension we'll talk about today is
called headwind and this is a very
opinionated thing you may want to use it
you may not want to use it what it does
is it will sort your classes in your
class name right here so if I install
this
close that out go back over here if I
did command shift p to open up our
Command palette and I typed in headwind
you can see sort Tailwind CSS classes I
can press enter there and notice how it
moved everything around
it's an opinionated thing it looks like
it does positioning first and then it
does background stuff and then it gets
into the inside box stuff so like font
opacity so it looks like it works from
the outside in which is kind of how I
like to work as well
give it a shot and see if you like it if
you are pretty opinionated on how you
like your Styles organized then stick
with what you know but I did say in the
previous video that I am a big fan of
Auto formatting with prettier and maybe
I should give this a bigger shot because
when I start working with a couple other
people on a Tailwind project it is nice
to have a standardized way to sort our
Tailwind classes
another thing we can do with headwind is
go into our settings type in headwind
and down here we can set up our sort
order
we can also run on Save
by default this is turned on you can
turn that off and you can do it manually
if you want with command shift p and the
command palette
but all in all Tailwind CSS intellisense
tailwindocks and headwind are three
great Tailwind extensions to improve
your Tailwind workflow inside of vs code
in this video we'll be talking about the
markdown flow now markdown is something
that I write often our entirebetter.dev
blog is written in markdown in the MDX
flavor
and vs code has a lot of great built-in
markdown features
in addition to the features we're going
to talk about some extensions which are
marked down preview GitHub styling which
gets you GitHub styling in the previews
markdown all-in-one which is the big
extension to know about and then
markdown lint to help catch any errors
in your markdown
to start us off I have a brand new
next.js application the next JS part
isn't the important part what is is I
wanted a readme right here
so here is our readme file that you can
browse through read as if you normally
would and then if you wanted to view
this you would probably have to go to
the GitHub repo to see what it looked
like in the readme
one way we can use a preview in vs code
is this nice little button up here
there's like this little icon right here
you can click that and you get a preview
on the right side
and if I scroll it also scrolls with me
so if I start deleting things like this
entire line right here I can delete that
and immediately it drops from the
preview
that's a really nice feature to have
another really cool feature to have if I
open up the sidebar right here
right now I only have the file explorer
I can right click up here up next to
where it says Explorer and now we get
some options for panels I can click
outline and here you can see getting
started learn more Deploy on versel you
can click to each one in your readme
and this works if you have other things
like an H3 let's go here H3 doing
something cool
and you can build out a whole outline so
you can quickly navigate through your
entire markdown readme just like that
some settings that we talked about
earlier is that number one we want our
startup editor
to be a new Untitled file so that's when
we start vs code up we'll have a brand
new file that looks like this
and the other thing that we can do is
files default language
and that will be markdown
we talked about that in one of the
earlier videos and the reason for this
is a lot of times if I open up vs code I
want to just write some notes so I'll
just write some notes
some notes maybe I'll create a to-do
list right here to do this
and then a bunch of things to do two to
do three
and when I'm done I can X those out just
like you would in markdown
so those are the built-in features that
I like a lot let's start talking about
extensions
if I open this up as a preview I can do
command shift p to preview
you can open preview you can open
preview to the side which is what we
just did and there's also open locked
preview to the side
and what locked preview does is if you
click around the different markdown
files the locked file the locked preview
on the right will always stay I'll just
click open preview to the side
and now we get this let's go look at our
first extension which is markdown
preview GitHub styling
let's go for this one that has 428k
right here
or 21k and what this does is it turns
the markdown into a GitHub style
markdown so you can see this is like the
default mark down here
I can go back to my file explorer open
up that readme again
and then let's open up this preview with
the command palette this time command
shift p open preview to the side
and this I know it doesn't have that
white background I think that's because
of the theme that we're using but it
does change to be GitHub styled markdown
and I can prove this let's go into our
extensions we can mark down preview
GitHub style you can click this and
disable it for a second
and notice that things change a little
bit over here here's our code block
let's go back and enable this
and our code block changes a little bit
so the extension is working although we
don't get that nice white background
maybe it depends on the theme
the second extension we'll talk about is
the big one markdown all in one
I can install this
and we get some great features like
keyboard shortcuts table of contents
list editing and a couple other ones but
let's start looking at it from here
so let's say I wanted a list item number
one
I can press enter here and it
automatically creates the next list item
press enter Tab and it even gets to a
nested list item
so that's really nice there
we can have a couple other things like
if I had a link copied I can command see
that normally if I wanted to create a
link like right here I would have to do
that do this right here and then paste
in the link right there
what I can do instead is just highlight
it with markdown all in one and just
paste and it automatically creates the
link which is really really helpful
there
something else to note is
you get some nice path intellisense
inside of your markdown files with
markdown all in one
another thing to note is if I have a
to-do list right here to do item one and
we'll create a bunch more if I press
enter it creates another to do item two
what you can do here is option C and
automatically complete these
so that's a nice keyboard shortcut to
have not the most important thing but
nice to have
another feature that this extension
provides us is if I go over here and set
table of contents
I could do command shift p to open up
the command palette table of contents
you can create a table of contents here
and there we go it automatically created
the links to each of the sections inside
of this markdown file it will also auto
update whenever you save the file
so let's say I deleted getting started
and I
saved it there we go getting started is
removed
and the last extension we're going to
talk about here is markdown lint
markdown lint this is a great extension
to lint our markdown to find any errors
or recommendations of how we can write
markdown better
if you scroll down here there are some
great rules on what is going to be
applied through markdown lint there's a
lot like unordered list indentation
there's a couple for like not having
many single H1 so multiple top level
headings in the same document is
something you don't want to have
let's go here and check that out this is
already highlighted let's see what the
problem is with this one
first line
in a file should be a top level heading
okay let's go over here we'll create
this H1 and say welcome
there's a problem here no empty links
that's an empty link let's just delete
that right there let's actually delete
this whole table of contents
let's see what else if there was no
spacing between these two highlight that
and it would say there should be a
surrounding blank lines around the
headings you can actually fix that
yourself or click the little refactor
button and fix this violation
and it would give you the space
what else is in here it looks like our
markdown file is good now not bad
so with previews on the side here the
GitHub style extension the markdown
all-in-one extension and markdown lint
vs code turns out to be a great markdown
editor
in this video we'll talk about laravel
workflow and extensions
and mostly we'll be talking about
extensions
laravel is such a great ecosystem and it
shows in the number of extensions that
vs code has
the first ones we have are in PHP
intellifents
now vs code out of the box doesn't have
the greatest PHP intellisense most of
its intellisense works really great for
JavaScript but not the best for PHP
so we'll look at this package that adds
a little bit stronger intellisense
we'll look at PHP fmt which is PHP
formatting
laravel extra intellisense which is even
more Intel sense for laravel specific
things like views routes
laravel blade Snippets which are just
some nice Snippets to have and laravel
blade spacer which is a convenience
extension I have a laravel project here
and notice that if I'm in this file this
is just app http
a controllers controller.php
if I'm in here and I wanted to look at
the symbols normally if I was in a
JavaScript file I could go to the
outline right here and see symbols I
don't have any right here I could do
command shift o to look at symbols as
well I don't have any there
let's go ahead and install PHP
intellifents
now there is another extension for PHP
intellisense I think that the
intellifins one works probably the best
out of all of them it gives code
completion and intellisense it can find
definitions and symbols it adds
everything that we'd expect from an
intellisense in vs code
I'll hit enable here
and if we go to our controller now
one thing to note is we have to make
sure that we have PHP installed
PHP Dash V right here I'm on 802.
what I can do now is command shift o and
notice that I have my symbols starting
to show so I can click controller go
there I can hover over these it shows
where it's coming from and I can option
click and go open that file
so already we're able to link a couple
different PHP features all around our
app start syncing things up if I go to
web.php I can do route right here and
notice I'm getting all of the things
that are in my project that I can do I
can click route right here
colon colon and I can get all of my
really nice intellisense that is
expected if I type in get right here you
can see it says hey you want the URI and
then the action which could be an array
string callable or null
so just by installing PHP intellifents
we get exactly what we'd expect out of
PHP and vs code
next up let's talk about formatting
let's say I press enter a couple times
here and I did command shift p
format document
we would get this sort of formatting
maybe you don't like how PHP
intellifents formats things we can go
ahead and install PHP fmt which is a
popular PHP formatter
install that
I can go back to this file
format document
we'll see hey there are multiple PHP
formatters which one do you want to use
I'll click configure and we'll use PHP
fmt
so it didn't look like it changed much
there if I did this a couple times
format document again it would change as
well so it looks like formatting for
that route was pretty much the same but
when you get into these files right here
you may notice a difference so just
choose what you like best as far as
formatter goes
the third extension we'll look at is
laravel extra intellisense
I'll click install here and let's go
look at what this does
if I go down we get route names and
Route parameters for auto completion we
get configs and they have a pretty nice
GIF here
foreign
so let's say that we went into our
routes again web.php we could have this
route view here and let's call it name
and we'll say welcome
we can go into a blade file now if I go
here and I go into resources views and
let's just do with welcome.blade
I can go over here and say
route
and notice how it brought up all of the
routes from our project
so PHP intellifents gives us PHP
intellisense but this laravel extra
intellisense package gives us stuff
about our specific laravel project as
far as names there's that welcome route
we just created I can click that and
We're Off to the Races
now the problem here is we have a blade
file but check it out there's no syntax
highlighting here so let's go here and
let's type in laravel Blade
there is laravel blade and laravel blade
Snippets
I'm going to go ahead and install the
Snippets package even though it doesn't
sound like it has syntax highlighting it
does have syntax highlighting support so
we're going to install one package to do
syntax highlight and Snippets instead of
just installing this single package that
does just syntax highlighting and
formatting
and this one also has 1.3 million
installs so we'll do this one
we'll go back to our file and already we
see some nice syntax highlighting there
we also get some nice Snippets so I can
do insert snip it
and you can look at all of the blade
features it is prefixed with that b
colon so if you did B colon you could
search through all of the blade things
that come with this let's do csrf right
there that's a nice one to have let's
see what else you could do at four
there's at four for each let's do a four
each
and then you could say product
as product sorry I did that wrong it
should be products as product and you
could tab through and do all that stuff
there
really nice extension to have and the
last one we'll talk about is laravel
blade spacer which is a convenience
feature where you install this and as
soon as you start typing it'll just add
spaces in between your brackets just a
small thing that I like personally it
kind of drives me crazy when there's no
spaces between these
let's say we also had a problem with a
product and let's remove these
laravel blade spacer only works when you
first create the thing so let's say we
wanted to format this I could do command
shift p format document
but there is no blade files formatter so
I'll go here and we can install laravel
blade formatter
and we'll come back to our blade file
let's do a format here
and there we go so we get a lot of
changes but we get our spacing back so
we can have this Auto format for the
project and it makes it really nice
across different team members
and laravel's eco
laravel's ecosystem is fantastic so
there's even more projects around it
like Alpine like Livewire and there are
tools like Alpine
there's alpine.js intellisense here
there's Live Wire
language support that you can install
that does great for Livewire projects
there's Tailwind CSS intellisense which
I believe came out of the
molaravelle ecosystem
so there is no shortage of great laravel
extensions laravel ecosystem again is so
fantastic really love to see it
all right we have made it to the
workflows section of this course and
this is going to be the really fun part
because this is where we get to be very
productive we get to be very real world
so the way we're going to run this is we
are going to go through separate
workflows for each specific task that
you'll be doing in vs code
so what I mean by that is we'll have a
workflow for let's say JavaScript we'll
have a workflow videos for react or
we'll have workflow videos from markdown
maybe if you have git and GitHub if you
are using npm there's all sorts of
workflows that we can make productive in
vs code
but before we jump into that I want to
talk about some visual upgrades to vs
code and I want to make our vs code look
a little bit better we're here so why
not make a really really good looking
setup
thank you
all right so the way this is going to
work is I will have three settings to
talk about for you in this video we're
gonna do render indent guides we're
going to do line height and we'll also
do breadcrumbs
and as we get further into this course
I'm going to get a little bit more
opinionated on my personal setup and how
I think productivity works best in vs
code but as always I'll give you the
options and show you my workflow and
process to see if you like these certain
settings if not please feel free to use
your own discretion and whatever you
think is best for your setup
and after settings we're going to talk
about one extension in this video and
that'll be adding on a theme called one
dark Pro which I think is really nice
and really clean
so let's go into our vs code here we
have a pretty decent looking vs code but
I think we can do a little bit better
if we opened up a file here if we did
Dom events right here
we have vs code it looks pretty decent
but I want to talk about cleaning this
up a little bit because I personally
don't use all of the things in the UI
so let's start with indent guides indent
guides can be very helpful but I try not
to indent more than maybe three or four
levels deep so I don't think indent
guides are too useful let's go ahead and
disable that we're going to open our
settings with command comma
we'll search for indent guides
and we'll just turn that off right there
now if we go back to vs code a little
bit cleaner
and you don't get the indent guides and
you can still kind of see what's going
on here and if you hover over one and
click into any of your elements you'll
see the ending element anyway
so it's good to see
that connection there so for me indent
guides are something you can forgo if
you have a project that doesn't indent
too many times
the next setting we'll talk about is
line height so I'll open up and go to
line height
this is personal preference I increase
this to about 38 maybe more sometimes
but what that does is increase the line
height in between all of these so if you
look there's this big section right here
a little bit more spacing than when I
had it at lower settings so if I move
this over to the right and I'll drag
this to the right panel
and let's actually increase vs code
I'll search for line height again
let's set this to 32 right there
and notice how it gets a little bit
shrunk it gets a little bit tighter 28
right there
let's go for zero
so there you go I personally like to put
it at 38.
good spacing not too much spacing
the third setting to talk about is
breadcrumbs and I'll go here
and we can do this change right inside
of vs code
here are the breadcrumbs if you find
these useful please go ahead and keep
these I personally use the keyboard
shortcuts to move around my files so I
don't really like the breadcrumbs I'm
going to go command shift p
red crumbs and we want toggle
breadcrumbs
and one that I didn't talk about in the
slides that we had earlier is that I
will always go in and toggle the
activity bar the status bar the mini map
and the tab bar on the fly so throughout
the workflows you're going to see me
doing that change command shift p
activity bar and it'll be toggle
mini map
status bar
and tab bar I don't do this one as much
it just limits it down to one tab only
but
that's something to keep in mind
but usually I'll try to code really
clean and we have a minimalist workflow
video that we're going to talk about a
lot of this stuff but notice that I will
just keep toggling things on and off
throughout this course command shift p
let's bring the activity bar the status
bar and the mini map back
all right and the last part to this is
let's add in one more theme I think this
is a good theme but I'm not really sure
I like the lines let's open up the
extension panel command shift X right
there
I'm going to search for one dark Pro
and I think this is a really clean theme
we'll go for the one with 3.8 million
installs I'll click install here
and we'll set it notice how to open the
command palette I'll just click it right
there and it's turned on
so if I hide the sidebar hide that
notice that here we are it looks a
little bit cleaner than it did with the
other theme there's not any like lines
or Borders or anything so this is a
really really nice theme to get a clean
coding environment
all right that's going to wrap it up for
our visual upgrades and let's get
started and move into our workflows
let's start moving into the workflows
section of this video there's going to
be workflows that are essential there's
going to be productive workflows and
there's going to be
let's start moving towards the workflows
section of this video
to get us started I want to talk about
the setup for these sections so we have
up till now installed a couple
extensions we've done a few different
settings at the beginning of every
workflow video I'm going to reset back
to this state
and the reason for this is that if there
are no new extensions that carry over
from video to video each workflow is its
own compartmentalized video so you can
go into each workflow knowing that all
of these settings and extensions in that
video will be valid for that workflow
and this is really helpful too because
in the future let's say uh we find some
new settings or new extensions I can
always re-record that specific workflow
and not have to mess around with any of
the other workflows so I'm trying to
make this as extensible and long living
as possible
to start us off what extensions are we
going to have installed at the beginning
of every video command shift X will have
advanced new file GitHub theme material
icon theme and one dark Pro and really
we don't even need GitHub theme since
we're using one dark Pro right here so
I'm actually going to go ahead and
uninstall that
so now we have one two three extensions
let's talk about the settings we can go
into our settings with command comma
and over here under this dot dot you can
say show modified settings and that will
show you only the settings that we have
modified ourselves
so these are the ones that we've done in
all of the videos up until now an easier
way I think to see the modified settings
is command shift p and we'll say
settings Json
and this is going to be all of the
settings that we have set ourselves I'm
going to put all of this in the
description down below so you can always
just copy it paste it in here and vs
code will take all of these settings as
the default
so you can see that we have our theme
Here we have font size here where is
line height it should be here as well
there's line height
breadcrumbs is false
multi-cursor modifier I've changed zoom
level we have default language for new
files startup editor is a new Untitled
file word wrap rulers tab size all that
good stuff and what's cool too is if you
go into the settings Json and not the
settings like UI version if you click on
any one of these let's say breadcrumbs
enabled there's little settings button
right here where you can edit and you
can actually say true or false and vs
code knows what the valid answers for
that question are right there true or
false
there we go
so these are the settings I'll paste
them down below but that's it that's the
start to every video that we're going to
make in these workflows is these
settings three extensions and every
single time I'm going to reset for each
workflow
alright super exciting stuff let's get
into the workflows
in this video I'll be talking about a
minimalist workflow
and I know in the past videos we've
talked about hiding the activity bar at
the status bar the minimap but I want to
take this a step further I want to take
this to a more minimalist approach and I
want to talk about the benefits of it
so if you're coming from the world of
Vim or editors like that
they excel at hiding everything away
from you so that you focus on exactly
what you need to focus on
editor like vs code comes with all the
bells and whistles but with that it
comes with distractions
so the minimalist workflow that means if
I want to get to a file I'm not going to
use my mouse to click around I'm going
to deliberately say oh I want to go to
my package.json I'm going to do command
p
type in package.json and go straight to
it and check this out very minimalist no
activity bar no status bar minimap not
even line numbers which we can talk
about I'll show you the setting but you
can keep it for yourself if you don't
like it or you do like it
and here we are so we are moving like we
would in a Vim style editor where
everything we want to do is very
deliberate
we're not just clicking around a UI
because there's lots of buttons there
are no buttons If I wanted to open the
readme now I would open up the readme
and check that out even the top there
are no extra tabs so you are focused on
one specific task and nothing else
so I want to show you some settings I
think I have 11 for you here that you
can mix and match to create your own
specific minimalist workflow you don't
have to take all of them you don't have
to take any of them really but I just
want to show you them so that you're
aware of them
and then after we talk about the
settings I want to talk about two
features that I think are really cool
so let's go into our vs code here and we
have our activity bar we have our status
bar let's open up package.json let's go
here there's package.json we have our
line numbers we have our code folding we
have our mini map we have all the things
that vs code comes with
but I want to talk about hiding some of
these things so that we can get to that
minimalist workflow we just saw
so to start us off I'm going to go into
settings command comma
and we can do all of this in settings
I'm going to do render indent guides
which we already removed in the previous
video so I'll remove them here
and now we go back and the indent guides
are gone
I have a lot of settings to show you
though so I don't really want to go one
by one in the UI I want to go command
shift p let's go for the settings Json
settings Json
and I am going to increase the size of
my vs code and this is an easy way to
change out settings and see what's going
on so I'll split this right over here
and I'll drag this over
so now here are our settings
and here is the package Json I'll leave
this up so we can see and I'll actually
zoom out it's getting a little cramped
here
so the cool thing about this is that as
we change this settings.json file and
I'll put all of these settings down
below so you can copy and paste them
into your own setup we are going to see
the changes take place as soon as we
save the file so let's go here I'm going
to copy this one from my cook for my
notes here and I'm going to paste this
in
activitybar.visible is false I'm going
to click save and you'll see the
activity bar hide
there we go
so that's activity bar visible and I'm
just going to keep pasting these in and
talk through them and then you can go
down below until the notes of this video
copy them and paste them into your own
settings file you can also use the
visual UI settings and kind of Click
through there
let's hide the status bar as well I'm
going to paste that in and you know that
we can also do this through the command
line with command shift p and say status
bar
but not all of these are found in the
command palette so that's why I'm doing
this this way
minimap enabled let's remove the minimap
and these are all the basic UI main UI
stuff
and the last one here is open editor so
if I open up my settings right here and
I open up a couple more files there we
go you can see that over here we have
open editors it shows you group one has
package.json which is this left side
here you see group 2 has these four
files which is this right side right
here I personally don't like open
editors myself I don't really use it so
you can right click here Hide open
editors or you can be more explicit and
in your settings you can just set it to
zero right here and I'll go back to my
settings
I'm going to right click close to the
right and this will close all those
and I'll paste that in right there
perfect so now onto tabs which is all of
this right here and this is the
package.json let's go open a couple more
so we can see I'll open git ignore open
the readme
each of them is up there so let's do
tabs
stuff here
and I have three settings for this let's
go for show icons
and this will remove the icon that you
see right there and I'll paste that in
click save
and there we go a little more minimalist
this I'm on the fence about I like the
icons myself if you don't and you want
to go more minimalist go ahead and
remove them
and if you hover each tab has a close
button this little X right here
if you don't like that if you sometimes
accidentally hit it you can turn that
off as well and that is tab close button
and I'll paste that right here
and the ultimate minimalist tab setting
is just turning off tabs so you only see
the current tab that you're on you see
here there's package Json get ignore
readme I'll just turn off show tabs to
false I'll click save and now there's
only one per side so I can still see
them open
I can click here I can go to each one
but if I close one with command W it'll
open up the one behind it so they're
still there you just don't see the tabs
next section is gutter stuff
and the gutter is this left section
right here with all of our stuff
and if I was in a JavaScript file let's
go for index.js
if I was here you could see the debugger
buttons right here you can set
breakpoints and the code folding and the
line numbers are here we can disable all
three of those things with this section
right here so I can turn off line
numbers
with line numbers is set to off
and this is personal preference if you
like it if you don't
choose your own idea there but even with
line numbers off and you leave this
gutter it gives a nice clean effect
glyph margin gets rid of that debugger
section right there with the Red Dot so
I'll turn off glyph margin
and it brings it all the way to the left
and the last part here is there is code
folding with that section right there
you can just turn off code folding for
the entire editor
if you have never used it
and now that bumps it all the way to the
left I personally like it when there's a
little bit more margin
those are the settings to go for the
minimalist approach the main UI stuff
the tab stuff the gutter stuff and now
we've hidden so much stuff in our UI and
we can command W there and now if I want
to get to a certain file I need to know
exactly what file I want to go to I'm
not just clicking around the UI I just
go to okay I need the index.js
and if I'm here I say oh I don't really
need that anymore I'm going to go to the
app.js right there
and we can even use more keyboard
shortcuts where we say go to
and we can go to a symbol
in editor and that's command shift o and
now we can see oh there's default right
there so I'll go to let's go to this URL
and I'll press enter and that jumps all
the way down there so by using command p
and saying oh let's go to index
I want this a better Dev footer right
there
and then I'm going to command shift o
I'll find all the symbols in there and I
can navigate to anything I need and look
how quick that was I didn't have to
click around I just knew that I wanted
this file and then I'm going to open up
the symbols I'll look through those and
type in there
so this is an approach you'd probably
see closer to the Vim side of things
where everything is hidden and you are
very deliberate about where you're going
if you are not a fan of this I'm going
to hide all of this go back into my
settings Json and let's just delete all
of these settings right here
I'll delete press save
and we're back to normal
if you aren't a fan of that but you do
want the minimalist approach every once
in a while you can do command shift p
there is centered mode
toggle centered layout and now we get
centered layout where the left and the
right are margin over there and padding
and we can type in piece up and down the
middle here
but what we can also do is let's turn
off centered layout and I'm doing this
all through the command palette
let's open up the readme again
is Zen mode
so if you turn on Zen mode all of the
stuff that we just did in settings
pretty much happens there's no line
numbers there's no status bar activity
bar and you get this nice Zen mode
really focused writing
and you can still go ahead and open
files like you would index better Dev
footer
and type as you need to
if you do it through settings or if you
do it through Zen mode in centered mode
just know there are tons of options to
get whatever UI that you like for your
vs code
this video is about the terminal and the
terminal built into vs code specifically
this is something that I thought I would
never use I was a big fan of using this
is iterm
and I was a big fan of using iterm or an
external terminal and I never thought I
would start using the built-in vs code
terminal but that is exactly what
happened
and to get to the terminal you can do
control tilde and that will open up the
terminal right here down at the bottom
for you
and you can do whatever you need to from
here you can npm install
anything you think you could do from the
normal terminal outside you could do in
here
so I wanted to talk about the workflow
here how we can start using it and from
here we can learn the control utility
keyboard shortcut and never have to
leave vs code and go back over to
another terminal
so let's close this out we don't need
this anymore from here we can open it
with control tilty again and let's see
some quick ones that we can do we can go
over here right now I'm using zsh
you can split the terminal
and now you can see two zsh is right
here
and by default they're going to open up
in the folder for where you are already
in your vs code project
so my project I'm currently in the
productive vs code site which is the
GitHub repo for the site that sells this
course and you can check out that GitHub
repo it's totally open you can see how I
built the main website but here you can
go ahead over here and close
and you can also split editors to the
right so you can have that another way
to do that
you could press add Right Here and Now
check this out we have groups so if I
had this group which was split and this
one right here this one is a whole other
group
and you might be wondering well Chris
what's the benefit of doing something
like this over here I could have npm run
Dev this is a next JS website so I could
have this running it'll start on
localhost 3000
and then I can do all of the stuff I
need to over here let's say I need to do
npm installs let's say I needed to run
other commands
we can do that all in another group
another cool thing we can do with the vs
code terminal is you can press this
little button right here and it will
increase the size so you can have your
terminal full screen in case you need to
see the entire list maybe you need to
list out some routes if you're using
laravel maybe you need to do some tests
in here
close that another button we can press
here is you can move into editor area
and I just right clicked that there
and that brings it into its own little
tab where you can keep that open up
other tabs and this will always be
running right there
so that's beneficial if you need the
extra real estate space
on top of just moving around adding tabs
and all that good stuff let's delete a
couple of these
let's go into our settings and let me
show you type in terminal
there's a couple cool things we can do
here
so one I think the terminal default font
size is a little too small so just go
terminal font
and we can increase to let's say 16.
and the terminal font line height
a terminal line height I think can also
get increased to maybe about 1.5
let's go check it out now a little bit
larger
LS right here and there's a little bit
more spacing between the lines
a little bit easier to read That's all
preference please play around with that
to see what you like
foreign
the next small trick I want to show you
is if you are in your terminal you can
LS we can go ahead and clear this by
typing in clear and pressing enter
or a quick shortcut to clear everything
out is command K and I believe that
works on Mac I'm not entirely sure on
the Windows side so it may or may not
work over there
the next trick I want to show you is if
you have a long running process that you
need to keep checking let's say you're
running some logs and you want to keep
opening and closing to check the logs
you don't have to do that you can just
right click here and move panel to the
right
and now if you have something long
running npm run Dev
well it's broken here but if you have it
running you can just leave it here and
code over here
let's say I was in my pages index.js we
could do all of our work in here and as
we're working this would continually run
and you can see everything over there
and when you're done right click over
here move panel to bottom and you're
back in business
the last setting I want to show you is
if you are on Windows or if you have
some special setup for your terminal is
go over here just type in terminal
and scroll down you have OS X exec or
Windows exec so here on OS X I'm using
terminal.app on Windows it's using
command so if you wanted to use let's
say WSL you could just type in WSL and
that would work for Windows subsystem
for Linux
but just be aware that you can change
out whatever you need here
all right so just get used to that
control tilde and start using the
built-in terminal I think you'll find
that once you don't have to leave vs
code and you see the benefits of vs code
that's staying inside of it provide I
think you'll start to use it a little
bit more just like I have
this video is all about using git and
GitHub from within vs code
and Microsoft owns vs code Microsoft
owns GitHub it makes sense that they
would be intertwined really well
we even have a git panel over here on
the side in the sidebar
so Source control we can open a folder
clone a repo but right now I just have
this folder over here and I'll just drag
it into vs code
do I trust the authors of these files
yes I do I made them so here we are
brand new file let's go ahead and say
index.html
foreign
we have a brand new pretty much website
right here
I can go over here close this out and
let's start working with the get
workflow
Step One is we should be able to create
a repo from within here
now normally you might open up the
terminal and say git init
and start there and then you would add
your git remote for your remote origin
or over here you can just open up the
git panel and we see initialize repo or
publish to GitHub
and publish to GitHub actually
initializes the repo for us
so let's initialize the repo first
and now we can see that if we make any
changes we can have it in our source
control panel
so that's really nice to have over here
we don't really see it but if I open up
the terminal and did an lsal you can see
a new DOT get folder right here which is
what holds all of the get information we
have
next up now that we have a repo
we should probably be able to git add
and get commit to it so we can stage
changes and also commit changes
so if I go over here the normal way we
would do this is git add Dash a or git
add period to add our files
that way we can stage them and once
they're staged we can get commit with a
message my first files
now I'm not going to do either of those
you can do these in the terminal but I
want to show you a cooler way which is
the way that I use exclusively these
days and I use it all from the git panel
step one here is I can stage these
changes so I can press this plus right
here
and it goes up there
next up I can commit so I can say my
first file
and then over here I can say this check
mark right here which is going to commit
and now we have a commit done
let's go ahead and change that file
again let's go into the index.html let's
do exclamation mark for the Emmett
shorthand for a full HTML page
and I will go see in this icon right
here says hey there's some more changes
here there's actually one change
so I can click that
and this is what I really like about the
git panel this is a way that I can view
the changes that have been made and keep
them or change them or delete them if I
need to
I can click each file here and you can
see oh on the left this is what it used
to be and on the right these are the
things that got added
so if I do like these changes I can go
ahead and Stage it by pressing plus you
can see it under staged changes now
or if I don't like it I can just go over
here and unstage it using the little
minus button and say no I don't really
want to keep that I'm going to undo this
specific change so I can undo a single
file or you can undo multiple files with
this button right here but I'll do the
single
do you want to discard changes
index.html yes I do
this is really helpful when you have
multiple files let's go ahead and create
a couple more files let's say style.css
let's say magic.js
and let's go over here we have two
changes I'm going to add this one and
add this one and say adding JS and CSS
I can press the little check mark here
or a shortcut here for a keyboard
shortcut is to do command enter and that
will stage and commit
let's say we have some changes we want
to make here so I have magic.js let's
add in some stuff console.log hi
everyone
and let's add some Styles over here for
body let's say background is cuckoo
and I'll save that
so now we have two changes but let's say
for your team you only want to be able
to commit certain things and you want to
be very specific about your commits I
can do a plus right here for just the
Styles I can say adding some base styles
I'll press command enter to commit just
that change and now I can change and go
ahead and Stage the JavaScript and
Commit This and saying adding starting
Js
and the cool thing about that is you are
able to
cherry pick
and the cool thing about doing it this
way is that you'll be able to revert
each specific commit by itself so you're
not lumping a bunch of features into one
commit
I think the source control panel makes
it really easy to pick
the changes that you want per commit
once we're ready to go we can command
shift p push
and we can get push
and it says no remotes configured yet I
can add a remote
and we can add a remote from GitHub
and this is where it gets fun you get to
sign in with GitHub so that all the
things that are happening in your vs
code can get pushed up to your GitHub
account
I'll go ahead and allow and what I see
here is a login button right here
authorize Visual Studio code to access
GitHub I will continue here
continue here
open Visual Studio code
allow an extension to open this URI look
at all this authentication stuff
and once I press OK it starts searching
for all of my GitHub repos up there and
you can pick the specific one that you
want to push to
if you don't want any of those and you
want to say Okay I want a brand new
folder you can go to github.com create a
brand new repo and then use that as your
remote
what I'll do here is I'm just going to
go here
RM rf.dit get folder
and so we don't have a git folder now
if we go back here and click refresh
cancel that we can initialize repo or
publish date to GitHub so if I publish
to GitHub
you can pick private or public repo and
it'll just use the name of the folder
that you're currently in
you can go ahead and do that but what
I'll do next is show you what it looks
like to clone repos that are already
existing from GitHub
while we have vs code open I'll do
command shift p clone
and we have git clone right here
clone from GitHub and since we're
already authenticated it'll know to go
grab our repos
we can go down here and say HTML CSS
website course I'll click this one right
here
and you can pick where you want this to
go I'll put this in my Batcave folder
select repo
it will clone it and you can open it in
the current window open in a new window
or add to your workspace I'm going to
open it in the current window
do I trust authors of these files yes I
do I can just trust everything in this
Batcave folder since I already know that
this is my folder
and now we have a repo we have our
source control working and it's pointed
directly to that GitHub repo
so let's go make some changes right here
I'm going to say let's change out this
HTML
my awesome website let's change this to
my super awesome website
and once it's saved we can go over here
see this index.html and here's a
shortcut too instead of staging it and
then committing it
if you go here and just say changing
something small and you did command
enter here it would stage and commit so
you don't have to actually press the
plus if anything under changes you press
command enter it will automatically go
ahead stage and commit
there are no stage changes to commit
would you like to stage and commit and I
always say always for this one
you can do it specifically one by one or
I just say always because I know that
when I'm doing that command enter all of
those changes want to take place
all right so if you don't want to do the
push to GitHub through the command
palette I want to show you another way
command shift p get push is right here
what you can also do is down in the
status bar there's this little button
right here where it shows you all of the
commits that have to go up and all the
commits that you have to pull down so we
have one locally that needs to go up to
GitHub
if I click this
and we'll say this action will push and
pull commits to and from the origin
Master Branch I'll say okay
you could click OK don't show again if
you want to go that route
and that will push all that up to GitHub
next up let's talk about branches
branches are easy to do from within vs
code command shift p branch
and you can create Branch delete merge
publish all that good stuff I'm going to
create branch
and this will automatically create a
branch from your current Branch if you
can also do create Branch from if you
wanted to Branch off of some other
Branch but right here I'll do create
branch and we'll call this test
and now check this out in the bottom we
are in the test Branch so I can command
shift p check out
two
and you can see the list of branches you
have master and test locally here you
have origin head origin Master as well
it's cool because we can use the command
palette to do all of our git commands we
can clone we can push we can pull we can
commit we can stage
and we can check out branches we don't
need to do all of it from the command
line git Branch or anything like that we
don't have to do that here
and I want to show you another shortcut
down in the status bar you can click on
the branch name right here and you get
that same command palette prompt where
you can actually click over to the
branch that you want
all right so that looks good there let
me show you a couple settings that I
think you should change out I'll go
command comma if we did git right here
and we scroll down custom data all this
stuff the one I want actually is default
directory
and right here edit in settings.json
we can enter in the default directory
where we want all of the cloning to
happen
so if I actually went here I don't want
this folder I'm going to go up one this
is my Batcave folder here I'll say PWD
which is path for the working directory
and this is my folder right here slash
users slash Chris slash documents slash
Batcave
so now whenever you do a git clone it
will automatically go into that folder
it won't have to ask you the prompt for
which folder do you want it'll just go
right there
another setting to check out is get
fetch
autofetch when set to True commits will
automatically be fetched from the
default remote
and we can set this to true and what
happens is it'll periodically go check
the remote and say oh are there commits
I need to pull down are there any new
branches I need to be aware of and then
you'll see that down here you'll see oh
you need one to pull down or one to push
up
and I'll just set that to true
all right there's a lot of really cool
git features in here and we've barely
scratched the surface if you go into the
get panel you press the dot dot dot
right here you can see all of the pretty
much features that we can do with get
inside of vs code
there is a lot more that we can do
though and the next video will cover
even more of git and GitHub because
there are some fantastic extensions that
we can use to enhance even further the
experience of using Source control
inside of vs code
next up let's talk about git extensions
for get extensions we will be talking
about five different ones
we are going to work with Git history
get blame
get link
get indicators which is one of my
favorites
and the big git extension for vs code
git lens
so to start us off let's go down the
list we'll go and start with Git history
if I search for git history in my
extensions panel
we see git history here
we can scroll down we can see the
history of a file we can search the
history view previous copy it's pretty
much what you'd expect when it's called
git history I'll go ahead and install
this
and now if I go into my Explorer go to
this index.html file
and I open up git history with the
command palette command shift p
history
we can view file history even view line
but I'll go ahead and do this right here
and now in here we can see if I zoom out
all of the different commits and what
happened for each commit
so that one right there we can view
we can go back to this one right here we
can view all of these that happened
and we can also go and dig deeper into
that
a useful extension if you need to view
your history often
next up let's go for git blame
and this is a fun one especially if
you're working in a team if you click
install here
on index.html you can see the blame
right here blame Chris EV three days ago
is when this change was made
so that just adds a nice little status
bar thing where you can see what's going
on and you can see the extension there
and the commit
next up is git link
for get link if you search for get link
no space in there you click install
it's a small one that I use pretty often
actually you'll click enable here
if you are in a file that corresponds to
a GitHub repo or any git repo you can
right click and now your context menu
will have a little button right here go
to online Link or copy online Link
so if I click go to online Link from
there what we'll see is it goes directly
to the GitHub repo and the file and the
line that you wanted
this is very helpful when you're in a
file and you just need to get to the
GitHub repo this is one really quick way
to do it
next up we are going to be using git
indicators and this is a really good one
I think very small feature but very
helpful so what I like to do is let's
say we
let's go into our body have made changes
here and I'll click save
now notice there's a little icon here
under the get panel the get icon that
shows you that something has changed
but oftentimes we talk about it a lot in
this course I like hiding pretty much
everything in vs code so if I wanted to
command shift p hide the activity bar
there's no real way to see that a file
has changed and that's how I see whether
or not I should go to my git panel look
at what files have changed
so the cool thing about this git
indicators extension is that it can show
you all of those status counters in your
status bar so I'll click install here
and I go ahead and enable it
if I go to a file that is part of the
GitHub repo you can see down below that
there is one file changed with four
insertions
so now I just have to look at my status
bar to know whether or not to go into
the git panel with command shift G right
here and now I can completely hide the
activity bar I no longer need it
so that's a small one for me just for
the ability to hide the activity bar
we'll bring the activity bar back
and the next one is the big extension
for vs code and git
let's go into our extensions panel
command shift X
get lens and it's so big it's already
showing up even if I search for git
indicators
so I'll go ahead and click into it let's
go look at what it does it is a ton of
features built into one vs code
extension
here are some of the features we have
revision navigation current line blame
which is an interesting one that I'll
show off authorship code lens status bar
blame so that little status bar icon
that we had for that other feature right
here is also included in git lens and
really get lens is a feature that brings
in two of these extensions so we no
longer need get blame I can uninstall
this one
and get history we can uninstall this
one
and get indicators in gitlink can stay
I'll go ahead and reload to make sure
that those are uninstalled and we have
git lens
let's search for git lens again
and I'll click into it I'll go ahead and
install here
and with that let's close out that and
we are here check this out you can see
who committed each specific line and
every time you click into a line it has
this little annotation on the right
there
a little excessive I think especially if
you aren't on a really big team but you
can hover it you can see the commit you
can see when it happened you can click
on this to get the commit ID all that
good stuff
we also have get blame in the status bar
just like the other extension but we get
a little bit more the reason I showed
off get blame is because maybe you just
want that one feature that's a great
extension to get the one feature you
don't need the full git lens extension
for all of these things
another feature from git lens is now we
have these little icons in the top right
here you can click this back button and
start to see the revisions from the
previous commits so these are the things
we changed in this new commit
press back this was the previous change
and you can go forward all the way as
well
so git lens gives you a lot of
flexibility for moving around your files
and seeing what's going on
another benefit to git lens is if I go
to my git Source control panel we now
have all these new little tabs there's
file history
where you can see the commits from this
view there's branches
there's remotes
let's scroll down a little further there
are stashes this is a good one
especially if you use the get stash
feature a lot
tags search and compare but we get some
even more functionality out of our
source control panel thanks to git lens
you can also view your previous git
commits
all right those are some good extensions
to add extra functionality to vs code
let's keep moving forward
this video is all about working in
multiple projects
if we have multiple projects and what I
really mean by that is multiple folders
or multiple GitHub repos
so here I am in vs code I already have a
folder in here for my site
but let's say we wanted to expand this
site a little bit more we have our front
end which is under my site but let's say
we have a new folder we'll call it my
API
now vs code has a cool feature built in
called workspaces where I can go up here
file
and there is add folder to workspace we
can open a workspace or we can save a
workspace
or really I can just take this my API
drag it in here
and it says do you want to copy my API
or add my API as a folder to the
workspace I'll add it to this workspace
do you trust authors of the files in
this folder yes I do
and now we can see two folders one right
here for HTML CSS website course and one
for my API
and if I wanted to I could add my site
as well I think I got the wrong folder
there but let's go ahead and add it
add folder to workspace there we go
so now we have three different folders
in this workspace and a workspace is
really just vs code's way of saying
multiple folders in a project
so I can open up index.html here
I can open up this index.html and notice
how it has the folder or project name
right next to the file name so I don't
get confused at which one is which and I
can close my open editors there
now the cool thing about this is if you
have two git repos let's say I went into
here and this has already been changed
you can see these get indicators right
here
and if I go into this other index.html
file and say exclamation mark enter
there and I'll save
so I have saved this file but it doesn't
look like there have been any changes in
the git panel and I think that's because
this my site doesn't have a git folder
so it's not really get Source controlled
to do this I could open up my terminal
right click right here go to open in
integrated terminal so that opens up
this specific folder for my site and I
can do ls-al
and I don't see a git folder right here
so I'll say git init
and now that I've initialized a new git
repo we can see there are four changes
over here
and you can see which ones are changed
these are green because they're brand
new files this is yellow because it's
been changed
so if I go over here now check this out
we can see changes and we can see my
site so we can see the separation
between the two projects in the source
control panel
and you can start working with each one
separately so if you have an API in the
back end and a front-end folder and you
have it all in one workspace that is
very helpful to have
by default vs code will keep this as an
Untitled workspace or you could go up
here a file and save workspace as so
that you can keep opening the workspace
right here under open workspace
so that's helpful especially if you're
using multiple projects if you don't
want to jump into a mono repo setup you
can use the workspace feature here
I'll go ahead and remove everything let
me remove this one remove folder from
workspace
and I'll remove my API remove folder
from workspace
so all we're left with is one folder and
the git panel only shows that folder
to close out this workspace all I have
to do is close the vs code window and it
says do you want to save your workspace
configuration I'll click don't save
let's go ahead and open vs code again
and let's start talking about extensions
for working with multiple projects
the first extension I want to talk about
is called project manager
if I go over here let's install it
project manager
this is a great way to switch between
different projects
if you remember me opening up my Batcave
folder you notice there's probably 10
different projects in there let's go
over to vs code and I'll do command o to
open a folder and I'll go into my back
here folder I'll do productive vs code
site and I'll click open
now this vs code is this folder right
here so it's all the things for the
website for this course
but let's say I wanted to switch
projects
so the cool thing we can do with the
project manager extensions I can do
command shift p
save project
and now project manager will save this
project and we can name it and we'll
name it productive vs code site which is
just the folder name I'll press enter
now let's say we opened up a different
project let's go back one
to the Batcave folder let's say we
wanted to open up the HTML CSS website
course
I'll click open
now we've opened up this folder in vs
code I'll do command shift p save
project and I'll save it as the folder
name
all right so now that we have two
projects saved there are a couple
different ways to activate project
manager the first way is I can click the
folder icon right here in the status bar
I can click that and it'll open up the
list of projects that I can switch to
so if I click on productive vs code site
it'll switch to that project
that makes it really quick since I don't
have to do command o and then find the
folder in finder I can just do it right
from this button right here
and we can use the command shift p
command palette to list projects
and that's project manager list projects
to open I'll click that and now we get
the list of projects
the other way we can open projects is
the folder icon in our sidebar now we
have favorites right here which are the
two that we just created or there's this
handy dandy git panel right here
so if you have a bunch of folders that
are git Source controlled which every
single project in my Batcave folder is
you can just say hey project manager go
look in that folder and always look in
that folder for any git repos that I can
pull in so I'll go to open settings
right here
foreign
actually went so let's go for base
folders
for project manager
[Music]
and let's see any base folders nope we
want git base folder so let's add an
item right here
I'm going to paste in my folder
structure which is going to be users
slash Chris slash documents slash
Batcave
so any git repos in this folder
please go ahead and open for us and look
at that immediately it went ahead and
said oh there are 11 projects that are
get Source controlled in this folder
so now instead of manually saving it as
a favorite up here I can just go ahead
and say oh here's the better Dev website
let's click that
and also there's this right here which
still pulls up the git repos and our
favorite ones we created manually
so that's a great extension to have
especially when you work with multiple
git repos which I'm sure we all do
the second extension that I want to talk
about when working with multiple
projects is called peacock and we
already have it working here I have it
on this site you can see the green
around on the title bar the activity bar
and the status bar
and the way we do that is with an
extension called Peacock let me go and
search for peacock
this is the one by John Papa I'll click
install right here
and we'll click enable
to work with peacock you have to do
command shift p
search for peacock and you have to add
the recommended favorites so once you
click that it'll go ahead and add them
to your settings
and now if I'm in this project I can
command shift p and say peacock
change to a favorite color
if I change to a favorite color I can go
down the list and change this project to
any of these colors
let's go for react blue or maybe
something different
alright so now we have something
different there's actually a button down
here in the status bar
where we can copy the hex value and the
way that peacock works is it saves it
into a DOT vs code folder under
settings.json
under color customizations
so peacock is a tool that helps you
create this object
but vs code can read this object without
needing the peacock extension itself
with these two extensions we have
the project manager extension where we
can switch this out let's go over to the
productive vs code site again
and since this is a vs code site
let's change out the color for purple so
obviously peacock
change to a favorite color let's go for
I believe something different was pretty
on the purple side
my orange is fun let's just do orange
so now when we switch projects or when
we have multiple projects open for
instance let me do command shift n I'll
open up another vs code instance
and I'll do
option command p
to switch projects I'll do better Dev
site
so now when you have multiple projects
open you can really see the difference
when you have one being orange one being
purple and if you were using Mac you
could quickly switch between the two
like this
all right those are two great extensions
to work with multiple projects
definitely work with workspaces as well
but vs code makes it really nice to work
with multiple projects and be able to
differentiate between the two
in this video we're going to talk about
the autosave and auto format workflow
now I have to preface this with before I
use these two settings for about a week
I absolutely hated both of these
settings so there may be a learning
curve or a time of adjustment for when
you try these out
and feel free to not try these out if
they don't feel like you're a cup of tea
so let's go and see why you would do an
auto save and auto format workflow
one you're removing time to format and
you might be wondering I like formatting
it my way and I agree that's how I used
to think but now with the style guides
that tools like prettier which is the
tool that we're going to use in this
video
with the style guides out there it
enforces a set of styles across your
entire team across yourself and all your
projects
it removes milliseconds of thought every
single time you need to save or you need
to format and that all adds up
one of my favorite books on web design
is don't make me think by Steve Krug and
the big process of it is saying if I
don't have to think about it then why
make a user think about it like put the
login button in the top right not in the
top left
it's just easier for a user to
automatically do something instead of
having to manually think about it
you get to focus on code don't focus on
saving formatting all that stuff and you
enforce Styles across your entire Team
without even thinking about it everybody
just automatically has the same styles
so here to demonstrate both of these I
have a brand new react application and
if you don't know react don't worry it's
not what this video is about
but here I have a react app and normally
I would have to update this entire app
let's delete all of that and let's say
hi everyone
and now I have to command s to save this
file and then we see this updated in the
right
let's go to our settings and turn auto
save on
files auto save we'll set that to after
a delay
so that doesn't save every character
change it actually saves after you stop
typing and I think 1000 is a little too
short so I changed mine to 1500
that'll be 15 milliseconds 1500
milliseconds after you stop typing will
it auto save
so now if I'm over here I don't have to
think about it this is really cool and I
just wait and all of a sudden everything
on the right is updated
and then I can keep typing
a sign that I have found that I like
this setting is that when I go to my
other computer or somebody else's
computer that doesn't have auto save on
I find it frustrating and that means
that I really like autosave because it's
simplified and made my workflow a little
bit faster
again I encourage you to try it out just
for maybe a week you might hate it at
first I know I did but it is fantastic
next up let's talk about formatting and
auto formatting when we talk about
formatting let's say I had this on this
line right here and I did command shift
p format
nothing would work because we don't have
a formatter that knows how to format
this react component if I open up a new
file change the language mode to
JavaScript
and let's say const people is equal to
let's say an object his name is Chris
now let's format this weirdly
we'll say name is cap
we'll say name is Auto
now let's format this we'll say format
document from the command palette
and there we go it all formats it a
little weird still so I have to go in
here and format it myself
but there is a built-in vs code
formatter
and there's an even better one we can
install as an extension so I'm going to
go to extensions
prettier is the tool that we're going to
use and this is pretty standard I would
say across the industry a lot of people
are using prettier you can see there's
14.1 million installs on this already
we'll install that
and let's go back over here and let's
undo let's make sure everything's all
weird again I'll say command shift p
format document
and it says hey there's multiple
formatters there's the built-in vs code
one and there's the prettier one that
you just installed which one do you want
to use I'll configure
and say let's use prettier this one
right here
and now it formats it like that
which is probably not what we wanted
it's a little weird but let's see what
happens if I add in maybe a couple more
people
and let's command shift p format
document right here
and there we go so I think what happened
I'm super zoomed in is it said hey these
objects don't really pass along 80
characters it's not 80 characters long
so let's put it all on one line but as
soon as you get to multiple we'll give
you multiple lines
the cool thing about this though is that
we don't have to think about it so if I
go to app.js and I just did format right
here
it did everything on one line if I said
let's put a P tag around this thing
let's go over here and close this P tag
and I did format
there we go
now the problem here is that I have to
press format manually every single time
what happens if I push this code up to
my teammates up to my GitHub repo and I
didn't remember to format
the cool thing here is let's go here and
say format on Save
and we can format on Save
you can also change it to the entire
file or only modifications of the file
definitely pick which one works best I
usually just do file
we have format on Save and then the
other one I want to talk about is
default formatter
I'm just going to set this to prettier
it's all the way down here
for default formatter
and now that that's ready to go we can
start typing in let's say we wanted a
span tag and said Hi and then behind
that we went to the span tag and said
goodbye
and then over here let's do that
it's going to save which didn't force
the format and I'm going to command s to
force the format so that's one way to
force the save and force the format
because on autosave it doesn't
automatically format which is
interesting but I like it because let's
say we're just doing some updates like
this and we save and it works but when
we want to format and just do command s
so you still have that workflow where
you're doing command s to format it and
you still have that auto save for the
quick hot reload over here on the react
app
all right I definitely recommend giving
both of those a shot I know you're
probably thinking Chris I don't need
those and you might be right but
just give them a shot see what happens
and of the two I would recommend that
auto format is the more important one
because you still have to do command s
to get the formatting done but it
definitely helps when you're working on
multiple projects multiple teams you
just have to not format things which is
really nice
this workflow is called the preview your
work workflow
in this one we're going to talk about
two different extensions the first one
being live server
and the second being browser preview
both super helpful extensions and it's
good to know when to use each one
let's go over here I'm going to open up
my terminal
let's make a brand new file new folder
actually let's go make directory
let's call it working
and I'm going to open this working
folder in this vs code window that I
have open I'm going to say code working
and I'm going to say Dash R to reuse the
current window that I'm in
so there we go we open up the brand new
folder right inside of vs code I'm going
to open up a new file called index.html
now this first one is live server so
we'll type in Live server
I'll click install here
it launches a development local server
with live reload features for static and
dynamic pages I find it really helpful
when I'm working with projects where
it's just HTML and CSS where usually I
use these to prototype
if you have a react app or a view app or
anything that has its own built-in live
reload you don't really need this tool
so it's more for the tools that don't
already have your servers built in
so the way this works is if you have an
HTML file it'll load up your file and
folder over here
and if I go here shortcuts to stop
everything is in the status bar so you
can see in the status bar here we have
go live
and you can also right click on an HTML
file over here and say open with live
server
there we go so let's go back to our
index.html let's make sure we have some
code I'll do exclamation mark which is
the emit expansion abbreviation for a
full HTML Dock and I'll just say hey
there
now let's click on go live
it'll start and here we are we are in
127 localhost 5500 slash index.html and
now now if I change things here
it automatically changes over here
so thanks to live server it's already
built up a way to automatically update
our server when our files changes really
nice especially with just HTML or maybe
a PHP server
the next extension to talk about is
browser preview
[Music]
I'll go ahead and install this
right now you see the setup is a Chrome
browser off to the right here and we
have vs code right here well this
extension puts vs code a browser right
on the right side super super cool right
there
so to get started we go browser view
open preview and that will be from the
command palette so I'm going to go back
to our index.html Command shift p
browser preview
and let's say show browser preview
here we go and now we have browser
preview over here we don't even need
that Chrome browser that we had open and
let's make sure we go to the right place
let's go
127.0.0.1 5500 index.html
and now we have live server running we
have our browser previewing here
will
things still change
and there we are everything is working
all inside of vs code we can expand this
and check this out everything is inside
of vs code now we don't need to jump
between vs code and chrome everything's
in here
the last setting I want to talk about is
when we opened up browser preview it
went to the visual studio code website
we don't really want that we usually
want it to go to localhost 3300 or
localhost 3000 wherever we're developing
I'll open up our settings type in
browser preview
and down here under Start URL you can
change this out for whatever you need it
to be
alright that wraps it up with our two
extensions check it out we have
everything in vs code we have our live
server running we have our preview right
in here very cool setup
now this next section of the course the
keyboard shortcuts section or the key
bindings section is my absolute favorite
part of this course
keyboard shortcuts are kind of the badge
of honor when you're working with a text
editor or an IDE
and keyboard shortcuts is really where
when you're starting to type or you're
having people look over your shoulder
and you're using keyboard shortcuts
that's when people really say wow
they're pretty fast and that's all done
with keyboard shortcuts
if we talk about productivity
the way that we save time is by keeping
our hands on the home row which is the
middle of our keyboard anytime we move
our hands off of the keyboard go touch
our Mouse trackpad whatever we're using
we're taking away precious seconds
milliseconds that add up over time and I
know that sounds pretty ridiculous
you're like Chris it's just grabbing my
mouse it's fine and it is totally fine
but if you want to be a faster developer
touching your mouse less will make you
faster and more efficient more
productive
so this entire section is about learning
about these keyboard shortcuts and
seeing how we can integrate them and
learn how to integrate them into our
workflows
a big thing I want to stress about this
section of the course though is that
you're not going to learn all of the
keyboard shortcuts overnight or in these
videos I definitely still don't even
know all of the keyboard shortcuts but I
want to put forth a path where you can
say well I think that should have a
keyboard shortcut maybe I can find it so
by giving us the tools on how to find
and learn these keyboard shortcuts I
feel like we can be better developers in
the long run it's like that saying where
they say it's not about Googling it's
about knowing what to Google
so really here it's not just knowing the
keyboard shortcuts it's knowing how to
find and learn the keyboard shortcuts
so to start us off here are the docs I'm
actually just going to skip the docs and
go into vs code and I want to show you a
trick that you should memorize command
shift p command palette I'm going to
type in keyboard shortcuts
this one right here help keyboard
shortcuts reference
and you can do this by command K and
command R so I want you to note already
that the command palette will always try
to give you the keyboard shortcut
possible if it exists so here we want
the keyboard shortcuts reference that's
keyboard command R so that's keyboard
shortcuts reference that's pretty easy
way to remember it click that and it'll
actually open up a browser with the
keyboard shortcuts cheat sheet that vs
code has provided for us and if you're
on Windows it'll open the windows one if
you're on Linux it'll open the Linux one
if you want you can even print this out
hold it next to your desk and kind of
commit these to memory we're going to go
through a couple of my favorites and
show you how these can help us be more
productive
the reference sheet right there which we
can always access from command palette
command K command r
that's always easy to access right there
or again command shift p
keyboard shortcuts reference
so if I go back to the docs here if you
are coming to vs code from another
editor which many of you probably are I
came from Sublime Text myself there is
down here in the section called key maps
extensions this is the second section so
if you scroll down key map extensions
vs code does a great job at helping us
migrate away from other editors into vs
code
so if you want you can download the
Sublime Text keymap install that
extension and now all of the keyboard
shortcuts that you're used to in Sublime
Text are carried over into vs code
the other thing about this is that we
can go into vs code and say command
shift p keyboard shortcuts we can open
keyboard shortcuts right here and by
doing this command K command s we can
see all of the keyboard shortcuts that
vs code has available to us
so this reference plus the keyboard
shortcuts cheat sheet are good enough to
look through and make sure that we can
commit these to memory and if you ever
don't know what the keyboard shortcut is
try opening this up and typing it in
like let's say an easy one copy
command c as per usual for all computers
out there and I know I'm starting to get
a little repetitive with this keyboard
shortcuts are going to make us faster
developers but could you imagine if we
opened up a file right here and I wanted
a copy this if I had to do this and go
right click and say copy down here could
you imagine having to do that every
single time we needed to copy and paste
something that would be tedious
so just think how much faster we are
with command C right here and command V
right there
imagine what we could do if everything
we did was keyboard shortcuts
and I know I'm trying to drive that
point home a little bit too hard sorry
for saying it so many times I just
believe in it so strongly I want to talk
about a setting which will help us out
I'm going to open up settings command
comma
and I'm going to search for cursor
smooth
now cursor smooth carat animation is a
fun little visual thing not necessary at
all it's more of a visual
feature if I click this
and I go over here and I click through
there's actually this really small nice
subtle feature where the carrot is
animated from point A to point B so you
can see it kind of really quickly
animate over
and if I turn that off we go over here
it'll just jump if you can really tell
it's really subtle but for me I think
this is a really fun feature that vs
code offers
and we'll be moving around a lot with
our keyboard throughout the rest of this
course so I thought you know what let's
turn this on let's get a nice visual
feature in here
so to recap if I close everything out
the one things that we need to remember
is
keyboard shortcuts reference keyboard
shortcuts reference
we can enter that and always open up the
keyboard shortcuts reference and read
through these
we can always command shift p to open
the command palette type in like copy
and you'll see the keyboard shortcut
right there
and part three to that is we can always
open keyboard shortcuts right here and
I'll click that to open it and you can
kind of search down here and see all the
keyboard shortcuts oh my gosh look how
many
so those three techniques are really
good to keep in mind we can use them
while we learn and grow our keyboard
shortcuts that we memorize let's start
our keyboard shortcut section by going
over the basic editing keyboard
shortcuts
to start I'm going to open up a new file
with command n
and you can do this as many times as you
need
command W closes the tabs
we can also do command n to open up a
new file and if we wanted we could split
this out into a split editor and do
command backslash
so now the same file is in two different
editor tabs if I wanted to jump between
these two editor tabs I would do command
1 for this section this group Command 2
for this group
I can do command W to close that command
W to close another one
let's go over to our Explorer right here
let's open up some files there's
comparisons conditionals functions
command B closes the sidebar there
and I will actually close this one as
well
if we make any changes to our files we
have the ones that we're probably used
to already that we've used in other
editors say hi we can command s to save
we can command C to copy let's highlight
something command C
paste
with command V
so those are the ones we're used to
right there
undo with command Z
save command s
and I'll close all these tabs out
command W command W command w
to reopen a closed tab we have command
shift t
just like you would see in Chrome
let's open up a new file command W to
close that tab command n
and I'm going to write out some stuff so
this is my new file hello everyone let's
learn
keyboard shortcuts
all right so this is where we get to
working inside of a file let's work with
line keyboard shortcuts so that's
anything to manipulate lines let's say I
wanted to cut this line I could command
X and cut that whole line and then I
could go over here use my arrow keys and
then paste it up there
that's cool right there I can move lines
up and down with option and the down
arrow
and I can move it back up with the
option up Arrow
we can copy lines down shift option down
and I don't know why my keyboard
shortcuts aren't showing in the bottom
there I'm not entirely sure but let's
see
shift option and the arrow keys will
copy lines up and down and this is
really useful let's say if you had some
Li's close those lies right there and
then you did shift option down and you
copied all those
some more stuff we can do with lines is
that we can add lines above and below
add new lines so if I wanted to add a
line below this I would do command enter
if I wanted to add a line above this
command shift enter and now I can start
typing there
so all of these line keyboard shortcuts
are very helpful when we're trying to
manipulate all of our lines
those are the main ones that I use but
the two more that I want to show in the
editing of lines is you can actually go
here and do command this Open Bracket or
I guess that's the closing bracket and
that can indent
and you can do all the way back to the
other way with command and then the
square bracket that way
moving beyond lines I want to talk about
comments
what you'll see me do often in this
course is command forward slash to
create comments and if you highlight
multiple lines if I hold shift and press
down a bunch of times and you do command
forward slash that creates a comment
across all of the lines that you're
already on all in all as far as editing
a single file those are my favorite
keyboard shortcuts to use you've seen
opening and creating new tabs and editor
groups you've seen editing inside of a
file using the line helpers and you've
also seen a little bit about comments so
with those three put together there's a
lot that you can do there but there is
more and always command shift p
ELP keyboard shortcuts reference right
there
and if we open that up and bring this
over here
we can see basic editing this is where
we pulled most of these ones in this
video the editor management section also
has a lot of this from this video file
management is from this video as well we
are going to get into the other ones in
the next videos but overall definitely
keep referencing this file and you'll be
on your way
the next set of keyboard shortcuts we're
going to do here is the section for
navigation
now this navigation workflow video is
going to be a very important one it
actually ties together a lot of what
we've already learned but it gives us
one of our first workflows we're going
to see in this course and what I mean by
workflow which we'll talk about more in
the workflows section of this course is
that we're going to try to do a little
bit more real world scenario things here
so I'm going to actually go into our
project and use these keyboard
navigation shortcuts and let's see if we
can do all of this without ever opening
the sidebar or the Explorer
and that's what I mean by workflow
you're going to see what it kind of
looks like for a day-to-day workflow
that I would do in my coding Journey so
if I go here
for myself I usually don't have the
Explorer open I just code just like this
and even sometimes I'll actually hide
the activity bar command shift p
activity bar you can toggle activity bar
visibility I'll actually code like this
a lot of the time
I'll even hide the status bar but we'll
talk about that in the minimalist
workflow
so let's bring those two back status bar
and activity bar and let's see how we
can do this without our sidebar
to start I want to open up a file to
open up a file we have command p
and there's go to file so now you can
see all of the files here let's say we
wanted to open up this functions file
I can type in functions and we'll see
that fuzzy search has shown functions
file right here I'll press enter that
will open up a file here
now to navigate around this file let's
use some more shortcuts we have command
P so far to go to a file
let's go to the bottom of this file I'm
going to press command down
so we're at line 63 right here let me
try to zoom in so if we are at line 63
let's say we wanted to go up here to
line 50.
to do that we can do Control G
and we can type in a line we can say 50
and that jumps right to line 50 and I
press enter right there to complete that
command
so we have the ability to open a file we
now have the ability to go to a line
next up let's go to a symbol in this
file and we've already seen this a
little bit by using the breadcrumbs so
if I click here you can see there's the
script tag and inside of that there's
the say something function which we can
see right here there is squared which is
a const right here other squared and
this punch function right there
so I'll click this and you can see all
of the symbols in this file
another shortcut for that is command
shift o
and that shows the symbols in this file
if I type in punch it would go down to
that file right there something we've
also seen before is if I use a function
right here and let's say this is used
way way way far away from where it's
actually defined you can right click
here and go to definition
but you can see that F12 is the keyboard
shortcut there so I can actually
hit F12 on that and go to the definition
where it's defined
another way to do that it's kind of a
keyboard shortcut plus a mouse click is
you hold Ctrl you hover over it and now
you see that underline so it's kind of a
link you can click that and it'll jump
to the definition
we are able to navigate the
symbols in this file just like you would
with these breadcrumbs command shift o
gets you all the symbols another fun
thing we can do is bracket matching so
if I'm here and I'm on this bracket
right here I can hit command shift
backslash and it'll go to the matching
bracket right there so if there's a ton
of code in here and even if there was an
if statement like a snippet and let's
say there's some more stuff a for Loop
in here
and some more stuff maybe a four
each Loop oh I already did a for each
Loop let's do a four in Loop
if we are in one of these we can just
say command shift backslash and it'll go
to the matching bracket and notice vs
code is nice enough to highlight the
brackets that it is matching
just a fun trick to kind of jump between
the top and bottom of brackets
so all in all command P to open things
up we can say conditionals
press enter there to open that file
we can go to align with Control G
we can open a symbol with command shift
o
we can go to a definition with F12
and we're able to bracket match with
command shift backslash
the other thing about this is those go
to shortcuts we can command shift p open
the command palette and notice how the
arrow right here this carrot is going to
show us the commands that vs code has
if we delete that we can actually say at
is going to find symbols colon is going
to find line number and the arrow is
going to go back to finding commands so
all of that can be done from here inside
of the command palette
all in all command p is what I really
use a ton of the time command shift o I
use as well to go through our
breadcrumbs or symbols
go to line number I don't use as much
these days but it is very helpful
especially if you can see the line
number in your editor and you want to
jump to it
all right that's our navigation workflow
a lot of fun stuff that you can
integrate into your daily
coding
this video is going to talk about my
absolute favorite feature of Visual
Studio code but it's not even a feature
that is specific to vs code it's a
feature that is found in many editors
and can even be found in online editors
like codepen and code sandbox
here we have our basic editing docs
here's keyboard shortcuts which we have
talked about a little bit and here is
multi-selections or multi-cursor as it's
named and this is my favorite feature of
any text editor because this is what I
feel like is going to make us very very
productive and make us have fun editing
if I go back to vs code I am going to
open up a brand new file with command n
I'm going to change the language of this
file command shift p type in language
mode
I'll change this to HTML so we can start
using emit
I'll do exclamation mark which in Emmett
is going to bring us a whole new HTML
document
and then down here let's zoom in a
little bit
I am going to create a UL instead of
that Li times 5 and then let's say the
text is whoa
perfect so we have a UL with five lies
and this is kind of a common thing
you'll do maybe you have a bunch of list
items or maybe these are a tags whatever
you need
multi-cursor helps with editing multiple
things in a row
so let's say I have all of these the
quickest way to start up with
multi-cursor is I'm going to click right
here and then I'll hold the option key
and click down click
click click and now if I just press
arrows over I can delete right here and
say whoa this is really cool
and the cool thing about this is this
can even be done with Emin so I can say
a
dot link
and do tab right there and now I can
type
and type over here
so let me tap that over just get my
indentation again one of the things that
I like to do also is to not just option
click my way through these right here
right here right here right here another
easier way to do this is to highlight
the text that you want
and I can double click that so now I'm
holding over this type area
I can do command D and that will
duplicate the next instance of that same
exact text so I can do command D command
D command D and keep going and now I can
say hi here
so that is an easier way to activate
multi-cursor is just to highlight
something and do command d
in this instance let's say I wanted this
href to actually be a hashtag for a
placeholder
if I did command D here notice it would
highlight everything right there
so we have to find a way to
differentiate this side over here
one way we can do that is we can
highlight with the quotes because that's
going to only highlight these down here
command d d d and I'll press right
left and then delete all this and do a
hashtag
another cool way to highlight a section
of code normally you would have to
highlight all of this right here if you
wanted to use your mouse
if I want to highlight just this href
section I can click where I want to
start highlighting a section I can do
shift option and I can drag down like
this and now I am creating multiple
cursors on each line
like that
so that's another way to highlight based
on a column which is really helpful
let's say I wanted just the text over
here I could do this shift option and
highlight straight down like that and
now I can type here
so that's a really cool way to activate
multicursor as well
let me show you another way to activate
multiple cursors
I can click here and instead of
highlighting with my mouse I can
actually hold option command and press
down
and that will highlight down or up
depending on if I press down or the up
arrow and now I can type in here hi
or https
example.com like that
that is another way to create multiple
cursors so you're seeing that there's a
couple different ways we can do this a
lot of options start to find the ones
that are best for you I personally
really lean towards the command D
version
I think that's the easiest to remember
option click also helps when you need to
highlight different areas and maybe
things don't always match up
another way we can even activate
multicursor is using the find or search
inside of this editor so if I did
command F opened up search right here it
actually highlighted class because I was
already highlighted on it like that so
whatever you're highlighted on you can
press command F and it will auto
populate in here
so here's how we activate multiple
cursors once we have find working we
press option enter
and now that gets us to all of the areas
where we can type in here and let's
change the link to like nav item or
something like that
so again I can even Search Command F
delete that and say I can type here so I
searched up here and then I do option
enter to highlight them all
whoa
if you are coming from a different
editor I want to show you how you can
update this so let's say I had right
here command comma to open up our
settings you can do multi cursor
modifier
if you are coming from Sublime Text or
some other editor that has command or
control as the
multi-cursor click holder you can click
that and that'll work or alt is kind of
the default in vs code you can use that
as well I personally lean to control
command because I am coming from Sublime
Text and I know that world so well
but everything will work the same except
I just hold command and now I can click
into a bunch of places command D still
works
there's also one more I want to show you
about multi-cursor if I click here
and I double click a bunch of times
command D and I say red and I'll
actually do blue and if you want to exit
out of multi-cursor I just pressed
Escape there
yellow
let's say green and let's go for purple
whoa purple
let's say I wanted to highlight all of
these I could do option command down
down down down I could highlight the
back ending tag of a command D D D D and
I can click left and type that in or you
could do like this right here command d
d d press right a cool thing we can do
here is let's say we wanted to maybe
style out the class based on this we can
shift option highlight that word
copy
come over here press left a couple times
and paste right there and we can say
like nav yellow green blue so that's
another way to use multi-cursor there's
a lot of different options and
possibilities for using multi-cursor
here that helps us save time writing
all right to recap there's a lot of ways
that multi-cursor can activate and help
us we have alt clicking or command
clicking we have duplicating with
command D we have the ability to go
straight down with option command down
down down
we have the ability to find by doing
command F and then alt option enter
and we also have the ability to
highlight straight through with shift
option right here shift option and I can
highlight like that
a lot of cool ways definitely work them
into your tool set and try to look for
ways of when you are able to use them or
when you could benefit from them these
have worked into my workflow pretty
often nowadays and I can't imagine
having an editor that doesn't have this
multi-cursor feature
the next part of this keyboard shortcuts
reference that I want to work with is
over here on the right side under
display
so if we go over here all of these are
going to be used on a day-to-day basis I
actually use these so much for my
workflow so I just wanted to show you
these
and really what all of these are is to
get around the UI of vs code
so if I'm in here and I close this out
and I click don't save
so I did command W to close that if I
wanted to open up the Explorer right
here you can see that it gives us the
keyboard shortcut up there command shift
e
so if I click that or I did command
shift e it would open up the Explorer
and then command B closes the sidebar
so command B will open up what was
previously in the sidebar in this case
the Explorer so I'll actually close and
open the sidebar a ton and you'll see me
use this keyboard shortcut a lot when
I'm working so that I can focus on the
code and not have to worry about any
sidebars open
so let's go down the line let's open up
the Explorer which is command shift e
let's open up search which is command
shift F and I'm not sure why it didn't
pop up right there
let's open up the source control and
this one's a little weird because it's
Ctrl shift G so it's not exactly the
command shift G but you would expect but
it is Ctrl shift G and this one I go to
a ton so it's inconvenient that it is
Ctrl shift G
the cool thing about this though is that
we can go and close the sidebar open up
command palette keyboard shortcuts
we can type in command shift G
and see what is in our editor for that
keyboard shortcut so I actually don't
use command shift G to find previous or
terminal find previous so I'm just going
to go ahead and remove those
I'm going to click here remove key
binding and remove key binding
now I'm going to make sure that this
Source control panel I can use with
command shift G so I'll type in control
shift G to find it
view Source control I'm going to click
edit right here
command shift G is what I want and I'll
press enter
alright so now if I go over here command
shift G shows up and I can do that
command shift e is Explorer command
shift f is search
command shift G is get Source control
now
and that's a personal preference I like
them to be uniform you don't really have
to do that for yourself but I dig it and
over here let's do debug command shift d
and extensions is command shift X
and I'll close the sidebar
reopen the sidebar
so navigating the UI like this is really
important because when we need to go and
find the search panel command shift F if
we need to go into git control command
shift G if we need to go into the
Explorer command shift e
so really get into a habit of knowing
these one two three four five keyboard
shortcuts
in addition to the things in the sidebar
there we have one that we've already
used a bunch of times in this course we
have command comma to find our settings
we also have the ability to open up the
panels at the bottom with control tilde
and that'll open up the terminal which I
use pretty much on a daily basis
you can also hover problem C command
shift m
output and debug console which we won't
use too much in this course but we will
use them a little bit
so control tilty will reclose the
terminal and open the terminal
get into a good habit of learning these
sidebar shortcuts they'll definitely
help you be more productive on a daily
basis
we have been able to do a lot in this
keyboard shortcut section there's a lot
of great things and I want to note that
there's a lot of cool things that we've
done here but it doesn't really help us
unless we practice it every single day
we try to internalize it so that it is
second nature remember the less that we
touch the mouse or the trackpad the
faster as developers we will become
so here I am on Visual Studio code I
want to point out a resource that's
really helpful if you go to Docs under
get started
under key bindings
and over here under keyboard shortcuts
reference here are the cheat sheets for
each operating system
I'll click into the Mac OS one and maybe
you want to print this out and keep it
on your desk while you're learning the
keyboard shortcuts maybe you want to
just have the link handy in your
bookmarks but I use this a lot when I
was learning the keyboard shortcuts very
helpful to just reference and look
through and also remember that you can
always go into your command palette and
search for the words for each of these
like let's say I wanted to go to file I
could go to my command palette search
for go to file and it would usually pop
up the keyboard shortcut on the right
and that's a good way to keep practicing
your keyboard shortcuts keep getting
better at them and keep getting faster
here I have our better.dev website and
the cool thing about the betterdev
website is the GitHub repo is right here
and all of the posts and content here
are in this underscore posts folder and
that's how we're writing everything is
in markdown
and when I say we it's me cap and my
cousin Lynn codes who's working with me
on this project
if I go to pull requests we'll see that
the pull request that she has in for
these articles are the new articles that
are coming down the pipe and these are
the ones that are assigned to me and I
need to review them
so I can go in here and I can look
through the files that are changed over
here I can add comments down below
I can request changes all that stuff
that you'd expect from github's UI and
being able to handle PR's inside of here
but being that vs code and GitHub are
owned by Microsoft it makes sense that
they would have a fantastic integration
so I want to show you something really
cool that we can use and that's called
the GitHub PRS
and that'll be the GitHub puller request
and issues extension right here
and what this does is it takes a lot of
the stuff that we just saw in github.com
and it moves it directly into vs code
I'm going to install this extension
and you can read through all these great
features that we have but I want to do a
quick walkthrough of a couple of them
I'm going to close that I'm going to
open up our activity bar I'm going to
bring the activity bar back
let's bring the status bar back
I've gone ahead and switched over to the
better Dev site GitHub repo in vs code
and if you look here this is the entire
next.js site all right here
here we have a brand new icon with the
GitHub pull requests and I have to sign
in to make sure that this works let's go
ahead click sign in
and it says Hey GitHub pull request and
the issues wants to sign in using GitHub
I'll allow it
we go here and then we say open Visual
Studio code
allow an extension to open this URI yes
all the security features let's get it
going
and now it will go ahead and in our
panel our sidebar panel for GitHub it
actually pulls in the pull requests and
the issues
and it says all the ones that are open
here I can go and look for waiting for
my review
I have this one that I created for
myself
mostly for this demo
what you can do is you can click into a
PR
and you can click into the description
here and you can see exactly what's
going on in this PR
we can see over on the left there is one
file that has been changed there's a
comment on that file
if I go over here you can actually add
reviewers assignees Milestones all that
good stuff
and if I scroll down you can see the
changes so it looks like I removed that
word absolute right there
and there's also a comment right here
and I can manage this pull request by
merging the pull request and leaving a
comment all that good stuff
so that's really cool to see let's go
take a look at one of lens that's
waiting for my review I'll click this
right here
I'll click on description
and it looks like Lynn just did one
single file here making testimonials
with Tailwind CSS that's a new article
coming I can
try to read through here but what I can
do also is Click checkout right here
so I'll click checkout
and this actually switches to the branch
for the pr
and now here I am you get some changes
on the sidebar we have this is the file
that we're working in down here I can
add comments to the entire PR
and I can go over here open this file
and I can scroll down and start editing
and reading through this article
what's cool about this is we can say in
this article we'll create four
testimonial designs quote testimonial
let's say I wanted to change these out I
could say hey Lynn check this out turn
that into capitalize the T on
testimonials so I can add a comment
right here and start a review
Lynn might be confused by this because
I'm fine with the lower case so I'll
start a review
we'll have a pending comment here
we'll go down
and let's say we wanted some other
changes let's go over here
text color additional classes are used
to style the text here enter the name
and title over here we can just say
this is looking great
I can add comment there
and once I'm ready to exit the review I
can go to review which goes back to the
top level here I have a request here I
have a comment there and you can say
request changes right there
so we have requested changes and I think
we're good to go so I am just going to
wait on changes from Lynn for that I can
now go up here and click exit review
mode
or you can click down here on the get in
the status bar and you can switch over
to the master branch
or you can open up the terminal and do
git check out the master branch
these are all great ways to do the same
git actions
so let's say I'm good with that let's go
over to the code now
that's all fine let's go make sure
that's showing up in GitHub
let's go to this PR let's go to
testimonials
and I scroll down all the way let's see
there's the comment I made there's the
other comment I made and down here
changes requested so we'll just wait on
Lynn to do that work
let's go to our Explorer the next thing
we can do with this extension is
actually create pull requests so let's
say I clicked on this and I did create
new branch
let's say I clicked on this and I said
create new Branch from
and also provide a new Branch name we'll
call it tester
and where to pull from let's pull from
the master branch
so we're now in this tester folder right
here this git Branch let's go to Pages
let's go to app.tsx and I don't know
let's do something dumb in here and just
say hi everyone I know I say that a lot
in this course
we'll click save there we'll go over
here and we'll commit this dumb thing
there are no stage commits would you
like to Stage all your changes and
commit them directly I'll say always
that's because I use the keyboard
shortcut for command enter which stages
and commits
and now over here
in our GitHub side panel we can click
this button up here that says create
pull request and as always a lot of the
stuff is in the command palette we can
say create pull a request
I'll press enter
and you can say merge changes from this
tester Branch into the master Branch
dumb thing right here
and I'll go ahead and click create
there is no Upstream Branch for tester
do you want to publish it and then
create the pull request so we're going
to push this local branch up to GitHub
and then create the pull request and
I'll click publish Branch there
so it's going ahead doing all the things
and now if I go and back to the sidebar
panel for the GitHub repos thing there
we go dumb thing is the brand new PR
that I just made
now this extension does a lot with PR's
commenting reviewing great stuff what it
also does is issues it is called the
GitHub pull requests and issues
extension so I want to show you
something cool I don't have any issues
right now but let's go ahead and create
one
we can add the issue title right here
assignees labels and then just write all
this stuff right here
and then up in the top you just click
this check mark and it creates the issue
I want to show you another cool way to
create an issue if I'm in a folder right
here and I go over here let's say I
create a comment and say to do delete
this line because it's useless
I should probably make that comment a
little bit more
informative delete because it is
not required
delete hello
and you probably see this light bulb
right here we can click and we can
create a GitHub issue so this extension
will read through find our to do words
and create an issue from there so I can
click that
and we create the issue right from the
command palette I'll press enter right
there
and if we go back to this GitHub issues
and pull requests extension over here my
issues created issues I can refresh this
button right here and there we go
and the options we have here are two
start working on issue and check out
topic Branch or we can just open the
issue directly on GitHub and see what's
going on in there
it also pulls in the line for where that
comment was created which is really nice
all right very helpful extension the
GitHub pull requests and issues a lot of
your GitHub workflow can go directly
into vs code making us that much more
productive
in this video we will be talking about
GitHub a little bit more and we will be
talking about the remote repositories
extension in vs code
this is a really convenient extension if
you just want to edit a little bit of
your repos or if you want to send in a
pull request on somebody else's repo but
you don't want to have to pull down the
whole repo do that whole setup you can
just remotely edit it
let's go into vs code I have the remote
repositories extension right here I'll
click install
we get this nice icon on the bottom left
I can click that
and it says open remote Repository
I'll click that
we can open remote repo or a pull
request from GitHub I'll go ahead and
open a repo
it wants us to sign in just like we did
with the GitHub puller requests and
issues extension
we'll do that here
and I'll go ahead and open vs code I'll
say OK open
and then we can choose a repo I'll click
this productive vs code site one
and you can search for it as you would
in the command palette
and it opens these up in a virtual file
system
so it's not exactly downloading these
files to your computer or anything it's
just putting them in a virtual file
system so that we can view them edit
them and work with them
let's say I wanted to go into my
tailwind.config.js right here
let's say I wanted to change the mode of
this to mode is jit
I'll save that now if we click on the
remote repos extension right here
we can see the previously opened remote
repos we can see the previously changed
files and what changed in them
and now if we want to commit this change
back up to the GitHub repo I can click
on the GitHub Source control section
right here
we can commit this and Commit This to
the curse of productive vs code site
repo
so I can commit a jit change right here
and then I can press command enter or go
up here use this little check mark to
stage and commit
what I can also do is go up here and
click create pull request
so I can say jit change I'll press enter
right there
name a new Branch we can call this maybe
Chris jit
and that goes ahead and creates pull
requests number one on that GitHub repo
if you want to switch to the new Branch
to continue to make changes no I'm all
good but that should be up and running
on our GitHub repo right now under pull
requests there it is jit change
and once we're done with this in vs code
we just close everything we don't need
to have to go into our file system
delete everything it's just working and
we're working and editing remotely
it's just a nice way to edit and update
our repos maybe send in pull requests
and not have to download the entire repo
in this video we'll be talking about
using apis and consuming apis
now let's use the Pokey API here and I
use this for every demo I do and I
probably should find a better API now
but we are using the Pokemon API for
this
if you go here you go https Pokey API
this whole URL right here
slash Pokemon slash ditto you can paste
that in here and say slash Pokemon slash
ditto
now that was an easy one because it is a
just a get request to go get information
but sometimes you may have to do a post
request sometimes you need to pass along
authentication like a bearer token or
any body parameters
to do stuff like that a little bit more
advanced is to use Postman
now in Postman you can do something like
the Poke API Pokemon slash Pikachu and
maybe you want to create a move you
would do Post request and then you would
go into your body and you would add
informed data or Json data right here
but then you'd have to go into your
headers and make sure that content type
was application Json
so there's a lot to using apis rather
than just going to your browser and
using it
and Postman is fantastic you're going to
use Postman or a tool like insomnia to
go work with apis then you go back into
your code then you go back to the docs
so there's a lot of process here
something that makes us more productive
in vs code is moving everything into vs
code so we never have to leave this area
right here
there are two extensions that do this
really well one is rest client
I can install this one right here
I don't use this one as much as the
option number two but I want to show it
to you just in case you find it useful
I'll create a new file
and the one thing that is requirement
for rest client is this needs to be a
language mode of either HTTP or plain
text
I'll go with HTTP here
and then I can just paste in the URL I
had Pokemon slash Pikachu
we get this nice button here that says
send request I can click Send request
and it opens over here on the right side
and should give us the request and if we
scroll down it should give us the object
the Json response
or abilities ability of static let's
hide that one forms Pikachu where's the
bigger version was it Raichu
or maybe it's not in there maybe it's
under evolutions
but my Pikachu nerdness is showing so
let's keep going let's move forward
there's a couple other things you can do
here you can turn that into a post
request you can add parameters here you
can do URL params right here
but that's a lot of work and knowing
that format is very specific
so we'll do something closer to what we
have for Postman where we can actually
use a GUI or a graphical user interface
to design our API requests
the one we want here is thunderclient
I'll install that
came out not too long ago but now it
gives us a nice little button on our
sidebar we click Thunder client
let me close that and close that you can
click new request
and we get what looks very similar to
postman we have a get with a drop down
here we're gonna do the Pokemon right
here Pokemon and let's go for Charizard
you can change out your auth for a
bearer token if needed or none you can
change out your body all that good stuff
but I'll just click Send here
and we get our response down here
so rest client and thunderclient are
great ways to work with API requests
especially not having to leave vs code
thunderclient is fantastic just go in
here work over here and then when you
need to test out API calls you can click
here and do a new request
you can see all your previous requests
right here as well and if you're working
locally let let's say you have a next JS
application with serverless routes you
can just do HTTP localhost 3000 slash
API slash hello
so you can also use your local API
routes
another helpful tool in bringing a lot
of our workflows back into vs code so we
can stay productive and stay in one spot
this video is all about Vim editing with
Vim is probably my number one most
effective productivity tip is to learn
Vim I think it's such a fantastic text
editor and a way to edit code
the problem with Vim is that it has such
a high learning curve
so for me I jumped into Vim which is an
editor that you can download over here
install it and it is different than vs
code so it opens up as its own editor
not vs code and you can learn to work
with it but it takes configuration it
takes learning how it works
so for me that setup I did all of that
it took a little bit too long
the cool thing about this is that there
are Vim extensions for vs code so if I
go into vs code and I go into my
extensions type in Vim
there's two that I want to call out
there's Vim which is the big one
and the one that I use is amvim
now amvim has far fewer installs now am
Vim has far fewer installs so I'll tell
you right now the reason that I use am
Vim instead of Vim
is that amvim is a little bit simpler it
doesn't have all of the features of the
Vim editor
but it has just enough for me to feel
happy about the medium between I'm using
vs code and Vim whereas this extension
Vim pretty much takes over a lot of the
editing capabilities of vs code and it
throws you into the world of Vim
if you don't know Vim I definitely
recommend trying to learn it there is a
website here Vim Dash Adventures which
is really nice to figure out how to use
Vim
so I've talked a lot about Vim so far
but I haven't really shown what it can
do so let's go ahead and take a peek if
I go to my extensions and I type in
amvim
I'll click install here
and let's go open up a file let's go to
this package.json
let's say I wanted to go down a bunch of
lines so normally I would go over to my
mouse click down here
and that would be the end of it but I
have moved my hands off of my keyboard
what Vim tries to do is keep your hands
on your keyboard and on the home row
which is the middle keyboard section
to make that task even quicker I can
press the down arrow a bunch of times
and go down and up
but that even gets me off of the home
row
so what Vim does is it has two modes for
text editors there's one which is the
movement mode and that's what I'm in
right now you can see the block right
here the block cursor if I press J it
goes down if I press K it goes up
if I press h it goes left
and if I press L it goes right so all of
those are on the home row I didn't have
to leave the home row to move
now you might be wondering okay now that
I'm in navigation mode how do I get to
my text editor mode
to do that I can press I to insert and
now I can type like normal
and then I can delete all of this by
going here to my mouse highlighting all
of this stuff right here and then
deleting it
once I want to exit insert mode I press
the Escape
and now I'm back to navigation mode
so that's the two big things to know
about Vim is there's movement mode or
navigation mode and then there's also
the insert where you're actually typing
mode
now you might be wondering okay I get to
stay on the home row but what benefits
does it get me
let's say I wanted to go up maybe five
lines I would normally have to press up
one two three four five
with the navigation mode in Vim you can
actually type in a number and repeat a
command so let's say I wanted to go down
five lines I could press five J and that
goes five down
let's say I wanted to go to five words
before this that's what the letter B is
for it goes B beginning of the word
beginning of the previous word beginning
beginning or I can go to the next word
with w w w
or the end of the next word with e
there's a lot of really cool smart
keyboard shortcuts like that in Vim
and once you start learning Vim even
more there's some really great ones like
pressing V and then I can highlight all
from the home row
but let's say I wanted to highlight
everything from this L all the way over
to This n so I want to delete all of
this text right here I could press V
right here
and I can press
BB
or I could do that differently I could
say
6 B and go all the way over there
or I can do what's called a find in Vim
where I can press F and then I can type
in the character of what I want to find
I can type in the quotes and it goes to
the first quotes on that line
let me open up the status bar because it
shows you a little bit of what we're
doing in our Command so if I press f you
can see down here in the status bar it
says F and what I can press comma and it
finds the comma
let's say I wanted to search for the
quote that is in the previous character
so I can do capital F and the quote so
that goes all the way over to the quote
there's a lot of really cool navigation
tricks just like this that Vim comes
with and once you learn them all you can
move all around your editor without
having to ever touch your mouse
like here I can say V and then I can do
find n find n
press left one and then I can press X to
delete all that
Vim comes with even more I I want to
keep going but maybe I'll put this into
a larger course if you're interested
let's say I wanted to change everything
inside of these quotes right here
normally you would go to your mouse and
highlight all of this and change all of
that out but here what I can do is
change inside the quotes
and now I can change everything inside
of those quotes
let's undo that
I'll press escape to go back to
navigation mode I'll press down a couple
times change inside quote there and I'll
say next export
and then I'll click escape to get back
to movement mode
this isn't even just to do these quotes
I could do change inside and the bracket
right here the curly bracket and that
would be that entire object so I can say
the bracket right there
and check that out we're in this brand
new scripts object
if you do want to learn Vim a little bit
more I am using the am Vim package
there is a really cool package called
learnvim
click install here and it's a really fun
tool to learn Vim inside of vs code
and there's some steps right here and
then it opens up an editor and shows you
a little bit of a tutorial
let's go ahead and do that command shift
p learn Vim
I'll press enter right there and here we
go we are able to open up the game
we can read through this thing right
here and then over here on the right we
can play around with our Vim skills
over here we can say install them let's
go to baby steps
and under baby steps we scroll down
what is normal mode
editing mode
and we saw insert mode type w normal
mode type w I highly encourage you to
try out this learn Vim extension and
learn Vim from right inside of vs code
really great tool
but overall
also recommended to learn Vim if you are
interested maybe I'll put together a
course about vim and go more in depth
but I truly believe that learning Vim
will make you a far more productive
coder and also it's really cool looking
when people see you flying around your
cursors and your editors without ever
moving to go grab your mouse
in this video we'll be talking about
smart helpers that help us write code
better using AI
now I know that sounds a little scary
will AI take our jobs will it just do so
well that we aren't needed anymore
from what I've seen especially so far is
that AI coding is here to help us
think about it this way if we are
getting stuck on a problem we usually
have to go over to stack overflow
we'll see what everyone else is writing
we'll copy something we'll come back to
our code and we'll try it out
what these AI coding tools do is they
distill all of that public information
on stack overflow on GitHub repos and it
brings it directly into your editor so
you can get some nice helpful Snippets
without having to go out and Google
search for them
so with that in mind it is a nice Helper
but it's not a replacer
I'm going to install one right now tab 9
is probably one of the most popular ones
there's tab 9 in kite I would think are
the two most popular Microsoft has their
own called intellicode
but I like how tab 9 works I like their
extension and their Snippets that they
give us the intellisense and the
recommendations are pretty spot on I
would say
so once we are here we have installed
tab 9 down here you can see tab 9 is
working
now we have a brand new Javascript file
here let's start typing let's say
function add
anything with this hexagon icon will be
a tab 9 feature it says add event ADD
child we don't want those I'm just going
to say a oh there we go there's a nice
one from tab 9 A and B and I'll click
enter there
I'll press enter
and let's say return and check that out
tab 9 already knows hey you probably
want to return a plus
so I'll click that
press space and tab 9 says oh let's
probably complete the rest of that a
plus b
tab 9 gives us a little bit extra
intellisense for what we think we should
be writing let's say we have const
button is equal to
document
it says create element I don't want that
let's go for
query selector
there it is tab 9 coming in finally and
we can say oh it probably wants that
button one
because we named it button over here so
this is where you start to see the AI
kick in it says hey your variable is
called button maybe you want a ID of
button
and then let's go over here and say
button dot add event listener
and look it already started Auto
completing that click right here because
it knows it was a button so I'll click
that and let's space
it can either do an on click Handler or
click function
there we go I'll press enter e dot
prevent default
so it doesn't really write the code for
us it just helps us out to write a
little bit better and the cool thing
about this AI code helper is that the
more we write and that the more we work
with it the more it'll understand how we
code and how our code works and then it
can start recommending us for our own
style
for instance I already have query
selector here I already have this add
event listener here let's go down and
say const form
check it out it already inferred from
the previous example it says hey you
probably want query selector
I'll open this up it says hey you
probably want form
and then we'll say form Dot
add
event listener it gave us a click even
though I wanted submit but it did do the
full function already
e dot pre
and then we have prevent default
there we go
and I can change this out for submit
so give it a try install tab 9 or kite
and if you look at tab 9 they do have
some premium features if you have the
free version it apparently works
decently but there's deep completions
there's a pro version
but also if you sign up I believe you
get these deep completions in the cloud
whereas right now everything is
completed locally
give it a shot see what works best for
you I think their Pro Plan is like 12 a
month which may be too much for a code
completion for a vs code extension but
give it a try see if you like the free
version I think the login where you sign
up is a free version still you just need
to sign up
yeah give it a try see what happens
Beyond tab 9 there is a really cool one
that just came out from Microsoft and
GitHub called GitHub Copilot
and if you go down here you play this
little GIF that they have
as soon as you write the comment
GitHub copilot gives you the full code
and this is the most I've ever seen an
AI code helper do
more than tab 9 and I haven't really
tried the tab 9 pro version but copilot
does fantastic and I want to show this
off it is in private beta right now so
sign up and hopefully you'll get access
pretty soon hopefully everybody will
I will go into my vs code and let's go
install copilot I got access to it
so here is the GitHub extension for it
you can install it but if you don't have
access it won't really work
I'm going to install it
and it says sign in to access the GitHub
copilot technical preview I'll go ahead
and sign in and this is really exciting
I love showing off Copilot
once I am logged in with copilot let's
go ahead and create a brand new file I'm
going to change this out to language
JavaScript
down here you see the GitHub copilot
icon
and I want to show you a quick thing
let's say I wanted to create a function
that added just like I did in tab 9.
here you can say function add
and here's copilot coming in and giving
you a whole bunch of code that you may
or may not want so I'm going to keep
writing here I'm going to say a
oh and it says oh you probably wanted
this so now I can press Tab and see all
of that happen
let's go even further let's say I wanted
to function pick random from array and I
could pass in an array here
it can give us all of that code so I
didn't have to go to stack Overflow to
look up how to randomly pick from an
array
let's go a little bit further copilot is
cool because it reads from your comments
so if I said go over here and create a
random array between 0 and 100. let's
say random array of
30 items between 0 and 100
VAR random array and I'll press tab
there
and it just writes all of this random
code for us
there we go
we can even use copilot to go fetch data
from the GitHub API for a specific
user and I spelled GitHub wrong
function
fetch user data and it does get Json
let's see if we can get this to use
fetch I can click next here and check
out all of the other recommendations
that it has
there we go now it's using fetch dot
then response I'll press tab there and
all of that code is coming in it even
knew what the GitHub API URL was
so co-pilot is the newest launched AI
code Helper and I think it's really
fantastic it's already helped me a ton
in my code and mostly it just saves me
time from going to see stack overflow
I recommend you installing tab 9 or kite
and seeing how that works for you
letting it learn your writing style and
your coding style and then once you get
access to copilot definitely try out
copilot because it's so cool
really promising as far as tools for the
future
in this video I want to talk about a
setting that
is maybe controversial a lot of people
don't use it and I did not like it at
first but the more I use it the more I
think I like it
let me talk about the problem here right
now if we are in vs code and we use the
sidebar on the left
notice how my eyes are right here along
the left side of my code
it'll push my code over and then I have
to shift my eyes
so a trick to this is moving the entire
sidebar over to the right move sidebar
right
and now look how weird this is already
the code is on the left the sidebar is
on the right
but as I press B there is no shift in my
code so I can do command B command B and
it moves the sidebar over on the right
side
I can use the Explorer I can use the
find panel I can use the get panel I can
use extensions all over there
and nothing ever changes on the left
side
so that's a small setting give it a shot
it took me about a week to start liking
it and before that I just did not like
it it was too weird but I am enjoying it
and I think I may use it into the future
right click on your activity bar and
click move sidebar left or move sidebar
right if you want to try it out
give it a shot let me know if you like
it
and that wraps up productive vs code I
hope you learned a lot I hope you
learned maybe little bits and tips and
tricks and extensions all over the place
that you can add together to make your
customized workflow for vs code
and hopefully we get closer to being 10x
Developers
but with all things it's gonna take
practice we don't just become 10x
developers overnight we don't just learn
all of these keyboard shortcuts
overnight it's going to take practice
and repetition to commit all of these
things to memory so that we can use them
in our daily workflows
so maybe you won't jump to 10x overnight
but you will jump to 2x 3x 4X gradually
and that's the goal here we're trying to
do gradual progression so next steps
this course the cool thing about it is
that we're not going to stop here we
will update this course whenever we find
new settings new workflows new
extensions I'll keep this course updated
with all of the latest and greatest I'll
make sure you get those updates and
we'll keep going forward and we'll keep
making vs code workflows better and
better and more customized to who we are
thanks for watching